the resistance uh you know saying that what I like look at when
when I saw that Hassan mentioned me on on a stream. Do you know
what all the ads were? They were like, "You got your wish. You
got your wish. You You just wanted to get in with us on." That's
what people think of me because of you. That's what people think
of me because of your audience. And that's not true. And I resent
that a a ton cuz that that's not what I'm >> If you resent
it, bro, you've been accusing me of being bad faith for the past
week when I've just >> That's such an obvious thing, right?
Hey, you are clearly directing your audience to go after me.
You are clearly pointing out how I'm like brain broken on these
things. You're clearly doing it. Why are you pretending that
that's not the case? This go was literally on stream yesterday
this and this morning talking about how he's going to go super
hard and then as soon as the debate happened he's he opens like
super hard lol. How can he possibly blame any animosity on me
or whatever? It's actually insane. He was going hard on you because
he feels lied about by you. He feels like your entire audience
is totally disingenuous about his positions. That's the entire
point, right? He's going hard because he feels like you have
misrepresented him and he feels like you didn't engage with any
of his core criticisms in that debate.
Destiny did go on Pisco stream last night. Destiny did do a whole
bunch of cope. Destiny kind of got totally blown the out. So,
it is all centered around Ogre Boy bringing up the clip that
we watched last night. Hold on, let me go find the clip for you
guys. I'll I'll give you a quick click breakdown and we'll go
back to the Darius stuff. By the way, I'm totally good to cover
all the Darius stuff. I just don't want to like zoom around in
this VOD with no timestamps so we can spend some more time on
it. We can comb through it later and find the time stamps and
then I can cover it. All right, but I need Ogre Boy posted this
for me yesterday. Where is it? Here. Where's my Ogre boy post?
It's this one right here. It's gonna be all around this clip.
Okay, >> so this is uh him talking to Paul's ego. And basically,
he's complaining about how leftists don't collab with each other.
Okay, they don't collab with each other. They're like totally.
And this is on November 29th, 2024. It's after the election,
right? So eight months ago, I would wonder what we've learned
in the past eight months that makes us go from I would like to
collab with us on which I'm claiming this clip says right on
electoralism on on positive things for the Democratic party when
working in concert or sorry when working together in furtherance
of the Democratic party I would like to work with this where
he said no actually I wouldn't exise I don't want to be on I
would excise Asan I don't want to platform him right these are
his positions now what has changed in these eight months that
he went from I would work with Assan to I actually hate his I
would work with him.
>> Yeah, but remember that's his fault. That's his fault.
That's his fault.
>> It is. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. >> Okay. Hold on.
I need to back up a little bit. >> Logically opposed and
seeing you try to have like a normal conversation, >> but
you catch so much [__] [__] for >> And
I I just hate
I hate that we've reached the point now where you and Hassan
can't be in the room. >> Yeah, but remember that's his
fault. That's his fault. That's his fault. Is it Here's the thing,
right? Hey, why can't you and Hassan work together? That's his
fault. That's his fault. That's his fault. That's his fault.
That's his fault. That's his fault. Right. That's he's he's saying
I don't have any commitments to not being with Hassan, to not
uh to not doing content with Hassan. That's all Hassan's fault.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. So, you were open to talk to
him anytime, right? >> I've said a million times like me
and Hassan and Vos could even if we were doing antagonistic content,
it would be amazing content. These are million view videos every
single debate. It would be >> okay. So even if we were
debating each other, it would be million views videos every single
time. So he he would want to debate them. >> Crazy. And
if we were doing synergistic content, bro, the like me and Hassan
and Vosch having like a competition between like how many people
we could get to like post pictures of voting at booths or whatever.
Like the the amount of so in furtherance of electoralism, in
furtherance of hey guys getting them to vote, working with Democrats.
Hey, Hassan and Bosch us work all all of us working together.
That would be awesome. Right? So again, he is totally down to
work with Hassan in furthering the goals of the Democratic party,
right? Which is Pisco's exact position. This is literally Pisco's
precise position, right? The whole time Pisco has this position
that this is, hey, if I feel like I can I can further my own
platform, if I feel like I can help Democrats, right, then I
would work with these people. And if I disagree with them, I
think I should debate with them like vigorously. Yeah, I should
totally debate with them. So debate plus, hey, if we're working
to together towards a common goal, then yeah, we can work together
and we could be friends, right? That's Pisco's position. Destiny's
position, too. Destiny is not saying anything like, "No, Hassan
actually hides his belief and any help towards him, any helping
him at all will actually be harmful to America or harmful to
the Democratic party. That is not a position he's had." Right?
So basically, you can take from this point all of the positions
Destiny was aware of before this date, which would have been
Hassan's, you know, Marxist beliefs, right? Hassan wasn't wasn't
hiding those would have would have included that and you can
say okay what's changed since here right and there won't be a
thing he will not be able to point to a thing that has changed
about Hassan that has made him go oh actually I can't work with
at all the synergy there would be it would be unbelievable we're
the three largest I think like of all like the live streamers
I'm pretty sure we're the three largest live streamers for politics
on the internet that like not just like podcast I think it's
me Vos and Assan all of us are on the left but >> seeing
a president turn out five things per week is some trauma That
might change your perspective a bit. Wait, would it change your
perspective
in the actually Hassan is worse than Trump
>> Is that how it's changing your opin? How would that
work? How would Donald Trump being a unhinged lunatic as president
make you go actually now Hassan is worse than Donald Trump? That's
crazy. >> We don't do any content together. None of us
do. That's crazy. So I What are you going to >> It's It's
legit stupid actually. So, I'm like I thought that um you know
and honestly I'm glad that that you cleared that up because I
thought it was kind of like this mutual like [__]
them. I'm kind of done with them. I'm not going to help signal
boost them kind of >> Well, no. The issue is that both
of them have lied about me so much they can't have me on or show
any of my content because of the lies that they've told about
me. Right. When I criticize Vasher Hassan like right now, so
basically Destiny is saying they've lied about me so much it's
their audiences and and they they they would look like total
hypocrites if they hung out with me. I don't have a principal
position to collaborating with them. Like the clip just him in
every way, right? >> Oh, like I'm watching this whole thing,
What he says and I think it's dumb. But when they talk about
me and now you can see us not do this against Ethan, so it's
not just me being personal. They never bring up the original
videos. They have to build us up. They have to build me up to
be this insane caricature of evil person like that Nick Fent.
>> Wow. He c he's certainly describing a pattern of behavior
that I've not seen him apply to anybody else like Pisco or me
or Quimman or Wow. Seems like he's got a lot of knowledge in
how to totally character somebody without representing them effectively.
Is he at least going to shout Vos and Hassan out for this that
he like totally learned the tactics from them and is now employing
them against people who criticize him or you think you'd at least
give them a shout out, right? Feels kind of up to steal their
entire flow and then use it for yourself against your enemies
and then be like me. They also suck too. Also, Hassan wants to
kill Americans. Anyway, so all of the debate, I think a lot of
the debate with Pisco is going to center around that clip right
there, right? How, hey, you used to have Pisco's exact position.
What's changed? And Destiny will not be able to identify what's
changed or why Pisco's position is >> Done is we've decided
to focus on MAGA, the crimes of MAGA, the attacks of Trump, the
uh what's going on in our institution. I go on to Crystal Ball's
show last week, uh, Breaking Points to talk about how Trump ising
up in every conceivable way on the epsene issue, how he'sing
up in every conceivable way with respect to the due process issue.
Like, what's wrong with that strategy? If if if we're going to
have any effect, it's going to be reaching out to certain people,
people we vehemently disagree with, and making the case that
Trump is awful, that we're in hell right now. We're like expanding
and trying to talk to people and see our point of view. I'm trying
to get them to be more based about constitutionalism, liberalism.
I'm trying to give him the rundown on law stuff. I'm trying to
build but but your audience is trying to me over. That's my intuition.
You tell me it's wrong. >> If you think, >> dude,
the audience is totally trying to you over. I wonder why the
audience would be so bad faith towards Pisco. I wonder why they
would be so insane towards Pisco. It's almost like Hold on. I'm
not going to I'll wait until that comes up in the debate to bring
up some counter evidence for that. >> That will encompass
some socialists because you're pushing some aspect of liberalism
so hard. I think that's fine. Okay. Hey folks, please like, comment,
and subscribe. And make sure to check out my newsletter. Information
is in the >> Like, let's assume that we both had to our
heads. Okay, peace gun. We had to guess. If you and if Lib and
Learn and the Vanguard and two other whatever you guys have equivalent
size audiences, if you were to do highly collaborative content
for 6 months, do you think that more of your guys's audience
would be completely turned off from voting for establishment
Dems, or do you think more of their audience would be completely
turned on to voting for establishment Dems? Because
So, I've only ever seen the flow work one way. This is why I
said in our conversation two days ago or yesterday, whatever
the where I was like, if the media environment was like half
the socialists were kind of like supportive of the mainstream
Dems and the other half were like relentlessly on them, you know,
whatever. I'd feel differently about it, but I've only ever seen
this pipeline, this flow go one way. >> I I think I want
to give it a try. And the reason I want to give it a try is because
I like I said before, I think there's an evolutionary niche for
um these socialist people. They're going to exist no matter what.
I can't make them not exist anymore. And I I think that I have
seen, for example, Breaking Points become, and I don't say it's
because of me, but I have seen it become criticized now for being
more lefty as opposed to before. It was a right-wing show, and
now it's highly critical of Trump. I think that there are ways
to change minds and change minds. But it's hard to do when when
we try to do that, we get accused of beating sweepers for tankies
and communists when you can't even identify a single criticism
you have of the [__] I did in the one interaction
that started this whole thing. God, Pisco is mad. Also, yes,
he's wearing the Eminem 8 mile getup. We get it. Yes. Yes, he
is doing that. So, you don't have an actual criticism. You have
zero moral prescription. You have zero moral problem with what
I did. You can't identify anything. You didn't identify anything
before. you won't be able to identify anything now. Okay. >> Okay.
So, f first of all, if you want the criticisms, just go go back
and listen to what Hutch said because he's the one who had all
the initial criticisms. I basically agreed to amplify them. I
agreed with everything that he said. I don't remember the exact
um the video. We we could go over it. I guess my issue is
So, again, we'll just I hate to have to pause every single time.
Destiny literally Pisco just said you're you're too much of a
[__] to actually point out your criticisms. And Destiny
says, "Yes, I am too much of a [__] to point out
any criticisms, but I have like I agree with Hutch. Actually,
I'm too much of a whiny to give you my criticisms, but like you
could look at Hutch's criticisms,
that's exactly what just happened there." Again to the broad
way what I'm saying is that the flow only works one way where
when you start associating not you but in general when liberals
and socialists associate the goal of the socialist is always
to extract as much from the liberal side as possible and then
to move away with as many people as they can steal. And that
always seems to be the case. And then electorally you can tell
me if you agree or disagree like >> okay this would actually
be interesting if he tries to defend this position that socialists
when they do content with anybody who's a liberal they always
try to sabotage essentially and steal audience from that liberal
with nothing in return. There's no synergy there. It is just
parasitic is the is the actual point he's trying to make now.
That'd be interesting. That could be interesting for an actual
debate. It feels like like the issues that Biden like was hurt
the most on and that eventually Obama was hurt the most on, weren't
these issues that we were like were too far theoretically to
the left on anyway, like stuff like immigration or stuff like
trans issues. Like what even is the idea that if we would appeal
more in that direction, we would have picked up more voters?
>> The Wall Street Journal The Wall Street Journal ended
up saying that Ko's economic policy was muddled and that it she
fell flat on her face because of it. It goes beyond culture worship.
>> Okay, ogre boy, with respect, I'm going to disconnect
you just for a second. Um, thank you for bringing the clip to
attention. Um, thank you. Um, I >> Oh, wait. Does this
cut off a whole bunch of the start of the debate where Ogre Boy
was here? Oh. Oh, do I have to go back to the Ooh,
hold on. Some of the stuff when Ogre Boy was there was actually
quite good. Hm. There's 55 minutes left here. Huh.
Oh, we'll keep we'll keep listening
that if we would appeal more in that direction, we would have
picked up more voters. I >> the Wall Street Journal The
Wall Street Journal ended up saying that Kamo's economic policy
was muddled and that it she fell flat on her face because of
it. It goes beyond culture worship. >> Okay, ogre boy,
with respect, I'm going to disconnect you just for a second.
Um, thank you for bringing the clip to attention. Um, thank you.
Um, Mantis, whatever. I did say Ogre Boy when I watched this
that it needed to be get rid of Mantis, get rid of Ogre Boy and
just have them talk because it's it's when other people interject
it prevents the person who like you're act I'm here to watch
Pisco's to state his disagreements fully, right? So Destiny has
to respond and when there are other people to pull away from
that, it actually just muddies everything, right? But so >> I
I don't know like if you're saying it's hopeless to get these
people in our or like in our orbit or to agree with us if it's
all a useless cause or that it can only do more harm is like
what is the prescription here? Like what what do you want me
to do? >> My prescription is that I think that there is
a huge base. I had the fear that they didn't exist prior to the
that no kings march and then after it happened I was like oh
I think there's a huge base of center-left people and I feel
like the issue with the moderate dems right now the reason why
people feel like there's no leadership of the Democratic party
or anything else is because there's no like strong platform of
democratic values that are being championed by a democratic media
apparatus that does >> is that not just so there's I guess
two tactics here one refuse to take a position two pisco I'm
going to just repeat what you Okay. And pretend that I didn't
understand that before. I'm just going to repeat what you say.
Hey guys, that's literally why Pisco says Joe Biden needs to
use his bully pulpit to actually say, "Hey, these are the policies
we want. This is the Democratic vision." That is like their entire
criticism of Biden, right? You're not actually out there and
active and saying why these policies are important to us as Democrats,
right? You're not unifying the party and you could be doing that.
>> Doesn't exist. So, when you look to the Democratic media,
there's two there's two things you can look You can either see
the mainstream media who are all literally terrified of Trump
derangement syndrome and are like constantly reminding themselves
how horrible Biden was and how he was scenile and everything
and blah blah blah. That's all they could talk about to to prove
how like good they are and that they're not like the other Dems.
And then you got the leftwing there the leftists, the socialists
and the commies who are all exclusively on the Democrats. So
you have nobody standing up for you in the center left media.
And then when I look at like we dominated in in 2008 with with
Obama, he won his re-election. Um, we lost unfortunately to Trump,
but we lost with Hillary getting three million more votes than
Trump. And then Biden came back and he destroyed it with more
votes than have ever happened in the history of presidential
election. Okay. And all this like appealing to the kind of like
moderate left Dems and then and then for some reason >> What
about this? You think I disagree? Like like I agreed with that
criticism. >> Yeah, that's the whole point. Like Destiny
just yapped a whole bunch, right? Like he just yapped a whole
bunch and said nothing
that answered any of the disagreements Pisco has. Why do you
lie about me? Why have you continued to lie about me? Right?
That's one. Why did you misrepresent my position um in that debate
and then before when you were doing content on it? Like these
these are the things he actually cares about. Right? Here's my
here's my exact prescription. What are your criticisms of it?
And Destiny goes, "Well, I'm going to describe the state of the
world." It's like a counterpoints like debate tactic, right?
I'm just I that's a difficult question to answer. So, I'm going
to describe the state of the world and talk for like 10 minutes
and not say anything. I agreed it on the day after the election
when Brian Tyler Con was there and we were like all talking like
yes and and and we were like preach and cook BTC because what
PTC was saying was uh look at how much they give each other flowers.
Look at how much they collaborate. Look how much the media like
makes connections and builds bridges with each other and builds
the system. But when we are like reaching out to So here's a
really really easy way to boil this down.
Basically, Eerodite and a whole bunch of other people are arguing,
hey, you need to collaborate, collaborate, collaborate. Right?
No more purity testing. Collaborate, collaborate, collaborate.
But us on us on,
right? That's what you have to justify. Justify, but on that's
that's all it is. Everybody agrees we should collaborate. Everybody
agrees the Democratic party should be more unified and open and
accepting of like slightly different views. It's just why is
it on and why does that make sense here, right? Like why is it
that you cannot amplify Hassan at all?
Saying it okay >> to to audiences >> now I'm going
to say it that way. [__] you guys. >> Yeah,
maybe they have bad views. They disagree on [__]
You have [__] bad views. I disagree with you on on
on [__] People disagree on stuff and and but okay,
fine. I I am trying to use their platforms. I'm trying to build
those connections. I'm trying to go on breaking points to get
them to [__] hate Trump. >> You show a clip
of Destiny lying about Pisco. Yes. When he implies that Piscus
is a socialist by webbing him onto socialists, that is a lie
without showing any clue any any clue or any inclination whatsoever
that Pisco has changed a position. So if you want to say that
Pisco is like socialist or he's having his mind changed by socialists
so he defends Hassan. Okay. No, Hen Muse, we can find clips of
this, right? If you want to say that he's had his positions changed,
if you want to intimate that via logs, via anything, right? When
Destiny says, "Oh, we've lost so many good liberal bros to socialist
girlfriends with regards to Pisco." What do you think that means?
What do you think that means? So, I'm asking you, I'm going to
show you a log of Destiny saying with regards to Pisco and how
he's like unhinged on his Assan opinions. I'm going to show you
a log of him saying
we've lost so many good bros, so many good liberal bros or something
like that to socialist girlfriends. What does that imply? Go
ahead. I'm going to let you go. I'm not going to show the log
first. I want this guy to admit that that would obviously be
implying that Pisco has changed his positions in a socialist
direction because he's dating somebody who is who is socialist
like sympathies or leanings.
That is a clear clear implication. So, is this guy going to respond?
I don't see him responding yet. Show the log. No. You tell me
that that is what it is, right?
You agree that if I show you that log, it's a clear implication.
No. Like, it's obvious what he's implying there. Yes. Oh, where
do we have this log? Let me go find it. Let me go find it. I've
got it somewhere here. Where do we grab
I have to go. Hold on. I've got it here somewhere. Say it again.
That somebody is asking about Pisco's defense of
Pisco Destiny says basically for why Pisco would have changed.
We've lost so many good like liberal bros or something to socialist
girlfriends. And I'm asking you what that implies. Where the
did I have this? I'm going to have to go find that Imager album,
but it's going to take me a second so he doesn't name drop Pisco.
The conversation is about Pisco, but you're going to you're just
going to debate anyway. Um I'm probably just going to time you
out. You can join the Discord if you want. Like you're not going
to engage in good faith whatsoever. So get out of here. >> But
I'm getting sty cuz all of my >> It's such a waste of time,
right? I'm going to try to find that real quick in my background,
but it's such a waste of time. Like that guy is absolutely not
going to engage at all. >> Getting downloaded as all the
responses. You're covering for tankies. You're doing this because
you're trying to appeal to Hassan's audience. You know, everyone
calling me a like what is going on? If there was any like ever
going to be like no, I'm going to say we're small potatoes. Live
and learn small potatoes. But it we are like a description of
the kind of pro-democrat
uh like budding I don't know media people that we would want
to encourage, but instead it feels like at every opportunity
you're trying to destroy us and you're trying to break us apart.
It's like you're trying to split up live and learn. Like you're
trying to give your flowers to Hutch and be like look at all
these they should call it socialist and learn. Like it feels
like it's incredibly acrimonious, personal. Um and and yeah,
so it it doesn't feel like the the effort here is to Okay, real
quick. I'm just going to pull the logs up just so I can show
it. So it starts off with um this guy Jay Barton complaining
about Pisco's argument around the word antifat and probably I
I would guess not 100% sure July 1st, right? his argument around
the word antif antifod. So I'm guessing that is to do with protests
and stuff, but I'm not 100% sure. Doesn't really matter. It's
a it's episc argument, right? And Desi says, "What? Jay Barton?"
Jay Barton says, "Watch the last 30 minutes of Pisco stream."
Damon comes in and says, "Sounds like some commies got in his
ear." Uh commies in his ear got him on that fast track at Destiny.
Destiny responds, "Damon, how many good men are we going to lose
to socialist girlfriends?" Right? Pretty simple that he is implying
that Pisco's socialist girlfriend is in his ear.
Yes,
obviously.
Thank you. These are Destiny's logs. I'm not making this up about
him, right? Can we go watch how Destiny represents Pisco's arguments
from the debate in the chat after like two? Sure. Like in two.
Yeah, exactly. Pretty simple. Pretty easy. Not a difficult to
follow. >> Like I thought recognize was important to do
after the election. >> Is Pisco dating a socialist? Uh
Joanne, I don't know if she's exactly a socialist, but she is
very socialistleaning. You can add this in the fact that Destiny
thinks Pisco is associating with socialist, right? He says he
blocked Pisco when he found out she he was doing content with
Aaron. He says that in this conversation.
>> Sure. So, let me repeat this. So, you you feel like
you're the frustration is that you're trying to find ways to
build what you view as being an important coalition to vote for
hopefully the Democratic president and that every single time
you try to reach out and do or at least in this particular instance,
we try to reach out and do this. As soon as you reach out to
who you feel could be a valuable coalition member, you're just
getting annihilated by somebody else that you thought was supposed
to be electorally at least an ally basically,
>> Okay. Take that feeling. >> Uh he does talk about
Aaron a lot more in this debate. Yes. Uh he could be referring
to Aaron there. He's he's referring to Aaron or Joe. Uh he is
also I believe that's Dude, he knows exactly who Pisco's girlfriend
is. He's implying something about Joe, too. especially because
it's about right it's about Palestine and she has the socialist
or leftist position on Palestine
>> and amplify it 50 million times more and then replace
me with leftists and then replace you with the Democratic party
and you have explained completely the entire left-wing media
apparatus for the past 8 years. Okay, how many times do I have
that
was robbed of the election? But those are the people that are
constantly attacking you. And they're not attacking you because
they disagree with your >> No, your people are attacking
me. Your people are attacking me. The people who >> No,
wait. But when my people are attacking you, right, it's because
I think that you're making a bad strategic choice for Democrats
to win. When the left is attacking you, leftists, it's because
they disagree with the ideology. They want a total reformation
of the party. They're not talking about like I think that you
need a 20our minimum wage instead of a 15- hour minimum wage.
They're saying things like minimum wage is a distraction from
class struggle and that's why the left and the right are the
exact same in the United States and we need a revolution. >> I
haven't heard that. I haven't heard that from Crystal or Kyle.
Maybe the Vanguard say that. Uh I'm not sure but I just don't
think that it describes my content and notwithstanding the fact
that I'm not reaching out to be >> like I just Yeah, I
have no idea. He's he's making points. So hopefully they start
grounding out with examples because Aaron is the best example.
Like has Aaron said that has Aaron said that Democrats and Republicans
are the same? Did she say that? That's by the way Destiny will
admit in this debate that what what made him block Pisco and
in distance apparently is that Aaron did a show or reacted to
her take with Pisco, right? That oh he's hanging out with socialists
now that right he said that's what made him block Pisco. If that
were the case, you'd have to show me that Aaron believes that
Republicans and Democrats are the same. to be in line with this
position, right? And then you have to contend with the fact that
Aaron canvas for Democrats, votes for Democrats, canvased with
you, destiny for Democrats.
People like Mike from PA. >> Did you see Clint's interview
with the Michigan senator? >> Yeah, with Alyssa Slotkin.
I didn't see it. I I've heard of it. I heard it was a hard-hitting
interview because guess what? Breaking Points for all it is is
not a show for Democrats. It's initially like it's like a show
for
all media types and like right-wingers often. It started as a
show for right-wingers. So, I'm not surprised that Crystal Ball
who is a journalist. All right. She's not just a Democratic stoogge,
right? She's a journalist that she's going to give a hard-hitting
interview to Democratic candidate because she doesn't have an
allegiance to Democratic Party. And we just have >> to
give a hard-hitting interview. She did a purity test on Israel
Palestine. It is not >> a purity test on Israel Palestine.
Now that's that's a position you can only have if you a priori
frame out the opinion the the ideology that says gazins are being
genocided right now. You need to say that only people who are
insane and can't be engaged with have that opinion. Right? There
is not a single solid good faith actor who believes that the
gazins are being genocided or that there's an ethnic cleansing
and starvation happening there. Because obviously if you truly
believe that you believe that you have a moral imperative to
stop what you see as ethnic cleansing or a genocide or mass starvation,
you would question a senator, a congressperson on this, right?
Obviously, the only way you could have that position is it's
just a loser moral purity test is if you think that that people
who believe that are totally wrong, totally. It's not a hard-hitting
interview to scream at somebody for 10 minutes. Is it a genocide?
Is it a genocide? That's purity testing on an issue that you
will never win a single election on. If that's going to be like
our standard for leftwing media figures, because now I could
be wrong and maybe maybe you've just said what you just said
there that Crystal is just a media person and you wouldn't consider
left or right. Is that really the position you've had? You would
say that Crystal's just a totally independent media figure. >> No,
I think she's leftwing. No, no, no. I I think she's leftwing,
but I do think that she's a journalist and she's not just there
to give hand jobs to senators. And yeah, I agree. Like I haven't
seen the interview. I I I'm not saying that I've seen the interview,
but it doesn't surprise me that she's being pressing on Israel.
I'm I'm going to be honest like because of what's going on in
Israel in Gaza and the Democratic Party, what many people have
feel like is lack of leadership on that issue. And she's, you
know, speaking voice now to a growing resentment of the Democratic
party and its members, not just its its leaders, right? The people,
the Democratic me is Porter Beller out there. Can I get a link?
I somebody has linked me to this. I can't remember if it was
Rhinox or Porter Beller. The polling amongst Democrats on who
they favor more between Israel and Palestine, right? Or whether
or not you have a favorable view of of Palestine. Somebody sent
me this before. The polling is like rough for Democrats right
now. Like very rough. members have soured on Israel and and so
in that sense like yeah maybe she's given an antagonistic antagonistic
interview to the candidate leader of the Democratic people but
people's approval the Democrat's approval of Democratic party
is shambolic and so maybe it's okay maybe it's okay to do that
>> the framing but the framing on this issue is >> yeah
yeah dude Americans overall view of Israel's military action
in Gaza approved was in October okay in November there was like
a little bit it it dropped off then we kind of stopped paying
attention to right now. Oh my god.
Unfortunately for Destiny has to contend with the fact that this
is working right. The reality on the ground combined with the
push from media figures to hold Israel accountable is working.
It is people have a feel they have a moral imperative to argue
for this and it is working
right. I understand that Dusty doesn't like that it's working.
I understand he's very upset about it. But Democrats opinions
on this are changing significantly. It shouldn't be working.
Wait second. What do you mean it shouldn't be working? >> So
bad. If you like when people say people are super off about Israel
Palestine, that should be a reason to vote in larger margins
for the Democrats than to abstain from voting altogether. This
and the only reason why somebody could justify abstaining. Why
you get almost 20 percentage points of of of voters in in Dearborn
for Jill Stein is because voters were hoodwinkedked by socialists
and communists that Democrats and Republicans had the Yeah. Well,
there are a lot of Muslims in Dearbornne, Michigan who are socialists
or communists. Really? You don't think that they possibly just
knew brown people who were getting blown up in the Middle East
and were like, "Hey, this seems pretty up. I actually don't like
what Israel is doing." Right? Like, oh, it's a we got all the
people here. I feel like I feel like it's way easier to just
go, "Oh, these people are all Middle Eastern. They probably have
family in the Middle East still. They probably see what Israel
is doing. They probably just don't like it. Why would they be
listening to Hassan for that opinion instead of just the people
they know?"
Democrat sympathies in the Middle East situation 2001 to 2025.
So for a long time, sympathetic to Israel, sympathetic to Israel.
Oh, suddenly we're not sympathetic at all to Israel. Okay. Same
position on this issue. And that somehow that we can say like
a 50 vote Senate for Biden is like the best the Democrats can
do. >> And your solution
>> and your solution is what? I mean like >> to give
them more votes to give you think that Biden would senator I
want that but but like it seems counterintuitive because like
when the moderates right when people say you lost the moderates
usually the response is you should appeal to the moderates or
like when you lose the voters in Dearborn maybe you should appeal
to the voters in Dearborn. I don't understand why the response
uh from an electoral perspective is control the information streams
which you're never going to do. They just exist in a anformational
niche which we're unable we don't have if if we wanted to we'd
be unable to stop them from having the kind of assuming it's
significant the significant impact that they have. And so I just
don't understand like >> that's our that's literally where
we live is the information stream. If we if we say that we can't
win that, then the then then at that then run a ton of ads cuz
like the war is over, right? Cuz this is where Republicans dominate.
Like if if I would have bet you, you know, 10 months ago, if
anybody would have bet me 10 months ago, do you think that Trump
could admit to trafficking that woman at Mara Lago to Epstein
and his fan base wouldn't care? I would have said no. That's
obviously the breaking point. It would be way over before then.
And holy, where are we at? Like there has to be some level of
of like support. >> Wait, I hold on. And I was looking
at these polling figures right now. I actually I'm going to roll
that whole thing back. I listen guys, we can we can cover this
for as long as we want. I'm going to roll that whole thing back
and listen to that argument cuz I'm I'm very confused what like
Republican support against like even if um Republicans still
supporting Trump in some way after the Epstein revelations with
regards to the woman at Mara Lago eventually going and meeting
Epstein. I I have to actually I don't know what that's relevant
to in this debate. I have to go and see >> the kind of
assuming it's the significant impact that they have. And so I
just don't understand like >> that's literally where we
live is the information string. If we if we say that we can't
win that then the then then at that then run a ton of ads cuz
like the war is over, right? Cuz this is where Republicans dominate.
Like if if I would have bet you you know 10 months ago or if
anybody would have bet me 10 months ago, do you think that Trump
could admit to trafficking that woman at Mara Laka? >> Have
we figured out how the information stream is working for Republicans
right now? Do we know what Donald Trump's polling is at? >> Epste
and his fan base wouldn't care. I would have said no. That's
obviously the breaking point. It would be way over before then.
And holy, where are we at? Like
why is he just arguing that like actually we just need to propagandize
way more and having anybody who disagrees with like an Israel
first democratic strategy is untenable cuz I want my thing to
be what the only thing we You have to understand that, right?
this kind of like um oh shut the up unless you're falling in
line strategy doesn't work with the past 30 years of democratic
strategy right the big tent strategy where you say actually shut
the up little coalition we don't have to listen to you at all
that doesn't work the whole thing is being is about being accepting
of multiple coalitions you can go and we weedle that down to
a much smaller base of stronger support if you want but that
doesn't necessarily work that you're basically assuming that
all and by the way this is built into their assumption that all
of those groups that they quote unquote excise will still vote
Democrat that they'll take that excision from the party that
will go, "Oh yeah, now that these guys have cut me out and they
argue that I'm like an anti-semite who shouldn't be listened
to, I'm totally going to go blue no matter who. I'm going to
tell my whole audience to vote blue, right guys? We're all going
to just go hard on this." And I don't know, like you can decide
you want to rejig your coalition so that you have more stronger,
more um like rapid support amongst a smaller group of people,
but you have to understand Trump's coalition is not that big,
right? So you could say, "Oh, well, we'll let it we'll let it
be so that these coalitions make like a better decision. We won't
include Assan so we don't have to include some issues that turn
off some people in the middle." But I don't I think you're I
think you're ignoring how that how that exact thing could put
more people off than you're expecting. There has to be some level
of of like support for the Democratic party. It can't be that
like we lost the election and now we have to appeal to a group
of people who fundamentally disagree with the entire existence
of the de of the Democratic. Nobody's saying you have to appeal
to Nobody's saying you have to go oh actually we are we're going
to do $15 minimum wage so we get your votes. It's saying that
hey here are our positions. If you want to go and talk about
some of these positions in a positive way we'll do that. If you
want to go argue about some position we disagree on in a negative
way we'll do that. That's not appealing to them. party. >> It's
it's just a total misnomer. That is not Pisco's position.
And what Josiah and I have done and >> that so appealing,
you should actually work that out. Like appealing as in I'm going
to amplify positions they agree with. That's fine to appeal that
way. Appealing in terms of I'm going to actually change a position
here to try to appeal to that base. That you don't necessarily
have to do that. >> I think as well is regardless of this
whole social socialist thing, which I think is like it's to me
it's not as important and maybe I'm I could be clueless about
that. I could be clueless about Marxisonism. I could be all that.
But what we've done is we've decided to focus on MAGA, the crimes
of MAGA, the attacks of Trump, the uh what's going on in our
institution. By the way, this is the actual strategy that works,
right? This is the actual strategy that Donald Trump uses to
win. You guys want to focus on my problems? Democrats are you
guys want to focus on my fraud, my total like selling out of
the American people, my total billing of all of my fans through
crypto, through uh through NFTs, through all of this. Uh Democrats
are Democrats Democrats Democrats are right. That's that's how
they work. They only attack the other side. That is a far better
strategy, a far more proven strategy than saying, you know what,
I don't want to talk to Hassan anymore that guy. The only reason
they cut Nick Fuentes out of things is because his positions
are one, it's like totally toxic, but two, he only goes to like
the DNC and to mock Democrats. Like, right, that's not true of
Hassan. Hassan helps candidates. Hassan absolutely helped Mandani
Mandani. Hassan absolutely helps Bernie. Hassan absolutely helps
AOC. He helps damn candidates. That's just true. You know, I
go on to crystal ball show last week uh breaking points to talk
about how Trump is up in every conceivable way on the epscene
issue. How we up in every conceivable way with respect to the
due process issue. Like the last time the before that I was also
talking about immigration like I go on these shows in these platforms.
I I actually had the Vanguard on separately. Maybe you guys if
you want to find more clips of me like being nice to the Vanguard
I had a separate interview with the Vanguard just me. So if there's
any like bad clips you can go find that and see if I'm inconsistent.
But yeah, so go watch that video. It's really great. Um, but
in that video I'm agreeing with the Vanguard in terms of like
this is how bad Trump is. This is what why it's bad for Mad Khalil.
So what what's wrong with that strategy? If if if we're going
to have any effect, it's going to be reaching out to certain
people, people we vehemently disagree with, and making the case
that Trump is awful, that we're in hell right now. And I don't
know what what's wrong with that. >> Here's the problem.
This is what the It's not enough to say it's not enough to say
that Trump is bad. You have to say that the Democrat is better.
>> That's not a thing that I don't think any of these people
would admit.
>> Well, they if what you mean is they don't admit it.
They lit. >> What? But what? Again, Pisco is not saying
he Why would they have to admit that? He's saying that's his
standard. That's what he's been arguing about the whole time.
Wait, why would why would Pisco need the Vanguard to say Trump
is bad, Democrats are better? like he could just he he's the
entire purpose of him is to go on that and say, "Yeah, Trump
is bad, but Democrats are better." Right? That's what he's arguing
is if I go on that platform, I say Democrats are better. That's
the whole point of engaging with them is I say Democrats are
still better. >> Literally do admit it when they say they
voted for them. Now, that's cold comfort. It's not enough. I
agree. It's not enough. But they do admit the Democrats are preferable.
Kyle does admit that. Crystal does admit that. Crystal had a
whole debate with Jugger about why it was I watched that debate
and she did. She did amazing. So, like it's just not true. These
people don't acknowledge the benefit of the Democrats. The problem
is sometimes they have critiques that are unhinged, untrue, we
don't agree with, they go too far. I get it. Some of them I don't
even put in the same bucket Hassan [__] and these
other people who I'm not trying to build bridges with. But the
resistance
uh you know, in saying that what I like look at when when I saw
that Hassan mentioned me on on a stream, do you know what all
the ads were? They were like, "You got your wish. You got your
wish. you you just wanted to get in with us on that's what people
think of me because of you. That's what people think of me because
of your audience and that's not true and I resent that a a ton
because that that's not what I'm doing. >> Why the [__]
have you resent it, bro? You've been accusing me being bad faith
for the past week when I've just >> Dude, that's such an
obvious thing, right? Hey, you are clearly directing your audience
to go after me. You're clearly pointing out how I'm like brain
broken on these things. You're clearly doing it. Why are you
pretending that that's not the case? By the way, these comments
were from last night. like they're from like that day. Okay,
it's very obvious Destiny has done this. And by very obvious,
I mean he literally went after the debate and complain complained
consistently about Pisco, right, bro? Pisco is saying Adam Freeland
would help us on Lau. Here's my Secretary of State, Adam Freeland,
guys. Was that Pisco's argument? Was that Pisco's argument? Was
that his argument at all? Dude, the normal set of assumptions
when choosing Hassan or Trump. Basic. Yeah, but it's so annoying
to see it happening. Holy sh Like, dude. Uh, sorry. I'm actually
not reading these totally in order. I didn't I didn't like clip
any of this. I just saw that he was whining about Pisco for like
a whole day,
right? Like hours and hours of Pisco was literally on stream
yesterday, this and this morning talking about how he's going
to go super hard and then as soon as the debate happened, he's
he opens like super hard, lol. How can he possibly blame any
animosity on me or whatever? It's actually insane. He was going
hard on you because he feels lied about by you. He feels like
your entire audience is totally disingenuous about his positions.
That's the entire point, right? He's going hard because he feels
like you have misrepresented him and he feels like you didn't
engage with any of his core criticisms in that debate. He went
off on Ethan for like a week over the lawsuit thing. He spent
two weeks doing a victory lap on the TSA thing. Then he ran the
most insane defense for Assan I've ever seen in my life, the
Last Day of Collins. So he's literally saying it. He's literally
saying it.
Okay. Do we not understand that he is literally saying it? He's
literally saying Pisco is like a son orbiter. So when Pisco says
all of that stuff, that's your audience. That's you who says
this is what I want. Destiny has to say yes I did do that. Yes,
I did say you wanted that with Hassan. Yes, I did say you were
defending Hassan and Saley. Yes, I did imply you totally disingenuously
went after Ethan Klein. But you that's what he has to say, right?
And if memory serves, I believe he does say something along those
lines. Let's listen again. Uh Pisco is going off about all the
things >> I'm not trying to build bridges with. But the
resistance
uh you know saying that what I like look at when when I saw that
Hassan mentioned me on on a stream. Do you know what all the
ads were? They were like you got your wish you got your wish
you you just wanted to get in with Hassan. That's what people
think of me because of you. That's what people think of me because
of your audience. And that's not true. And I resent that a a
ton cuz that that's not what I'm doing. >> Why the [__]
have you resent it, bro? You've been accusing me of being bad
faith for the past whole week when I've >> because you
won't take any position on what he's done wrong. You can't take
a position on what he's done wrong. And you soyed the out about
him repeatedly. And anytime he asks you to answer a question,
you either have counterpoints get up and pull his out in the
middle of the train so that nobody knows what's going on anymore,
right? Say something totally and waste everybody's time or you
just spur at 90 words a minute, right? You totally spur the out
as Andrew Wilson would say, right? You just spur the out, don't
say anything of relevance and then try to move on. every single
argument I've given and you just spent 20 minutes talking about
a clip of me from 10 minutes ago saying that I'm a hypocrite
on this issue like yeah all my a clip so a clip of Destiny from
after the election where he says he would still collab with Hassan
and apparently that's bad faith to say here's Destiny's strong
position on Hassan right here's Destiny's words I'm showing you
Destiny's words to talk about his position on Hassan and I don't
know what changed and Destiny implies that's bad faith and the
same kind of bad faith as Destiny implying Pisco is trying to
be a Hassan orbiter That is transparently not true. You would
have to be totally brain to believe that or to think it at all.
That is not happened. >> Politics sucks. No like Holmes.
You don't have to tell me for a decade. Yeah, it's horrible.
No, but I'm just >> sorry. The part that I cut off for
our low IQ friend over here is that Destiny says, "Yeah, obviously
that's all bad. What do you want me to say? That's online politics,
baby. That's online politics, baby." as if Destiny hasn't like
tried to present himself as somebody who doesn't do that to other
people. As if in the clip in question that we're actually talking
about, Destiny doesn't say the difference between me and Hassan
and Bosch is that they've actually totally undermined me repeatedly.
They've totally undermined me repeatedly to their audience. They've
lied about me so much that they can't engage with me in good
faith anymore. They don't watch my clips. They don't actually
attack my positions. They just attack a caricature of me. Now
Destiny's doing that to Pisco and Pisco's upset about it, right?
They've just swapped
Okay, hold on. Assan is bad from before. Assan is bad. I did
two of them and then uh boom thing that you said. Whoops. Wrong
video. Wrong video. >> Resent that a ton because that that's
not what I'm doing. >> If you resent it, bro, you've been
accusing me of being bad faith for the past whole week when I've
justified every single argument I've given and you just spent
20 minutes talking about a clip of me from 10 minutes ago saying
I'm a hypocrite on this issue. Like, yeah, online politics sucks.
No, you're like Holmes. You don't have to tell me for a decade.
That's horrible. No, but I'm just saying that when you're >> So
basically the answer is that like yeah, I am totally maligning
you and you are using a clip of me from 8 months ago and asking
what changed. But that's bad faith, right? And so my bad faith
to you is totally misrepresenting how your relationship with
Assan your goals in like saying that I don't think Hassan like
necessarily did what you're saying here, right? Like basically
with the Ethan Klein lawsuit, let's use that as an example with
the Ethan Klein lawsuit that Destiny clearly misrepresents Pisco
on, right? Hold on. Where is it? He went off on Ethan for like
a week over the lawsuit thing. He spent the So, let's do this
one first. Okay. Is this a valid criticism? Do we think Pisco
particularly wanted to go off on Ethan over this? Pisco's position
was I think Ethan will win this lawsuit,
but I think he's pretty disingenuous in filing the lawsuit in
the first place. So, that's it, right? That was misrepresented
by Dan as oh, Pisco won't agree that the lawsuit is strong. That
is totally false, right? Destiny didn't didn't go to like tweet
that publicly or or distance from Dan's position, right? So,
he doesn't correct him. By the way, we'll see that a lot. If
you don't remember, Destiny felt it was incumbent on Hassan to
correct opinions about Ethan in his audience and amongst his
mod staff, right? But when Pisco asks for the same thing of Destiny,
Destiny thinks that's insane. That you could that you could blame
Dan for any position or you could blame Destiny for anything
Dan says is totally insane. But Destiny was 100% okay with saying
Hassan is responsible for Froggen's rhetoric, for his mod's rhetoric,
for his chat's rhetoric, right? And Pesco is saying, "Hey, your
chat's in my comments like spamming the [__] out
of me, lying about my positions, right? Lying about me and what
I want and my positions." And you're doing it. I I feel like
that's just built in. It's just bolted on. We see it clear as
day. I see it clear as day. I don't know how anybody else couldn't.
Right. So with Ethan, the entire thing that made Pisco debate
it was actually DJers and probably more uh not more but like
Dan fans DJers wanted to go and debate with Pisco that Pisco
was wrong, right? And Pisco went, "Okay, you want to debate me?
You want to come in and challenge this position? That's concrete.
I'll let you come in and humiliate yourself. Come debate me."
He told Dan, "Let's debate." He told Ethan, "Let's debate." He
told everybody, "Hey, let's debate." Ethan covered it on his
stream. Ethan called him out. Pisco just says, "Let's debate."
Right? If you're Yeah. Obviously, if we agree on 99% of things,
we only disagree on one thing, and we go to talk, we go to have
a debate, we're going to debate on the thing that we our whole
job, Pisco's entire channel is political debate, right? That
is a ton of Pisco's content. Political debate. You'd think Destiny
would empathize. Hey, if people disagree with me, they're going
to come on. We're going to do content on disagreements.
So, he didn't have a broad categorical disagreement with people
on how the Ethan lawsuits would go. He said, I think they're
going to go in Ethan's favor. Right. Anyway, Dooby Booby, if
you don't like it, you can leave. You can just leave. That's
a bad comparison. Ethan and his son had a show together. He should
still do it because you shouldn't misframe people's positions.
If you're confident, you're correct. Oh, so Pisco and Destiny
didn't have like a collaboration together that Pisco had to distance
from because Destiny couldn't, you know, just respect the consent
of people he has relationships with. Is that is that really a
fair
Okay. All right. I just I I try to highlight to people why I
think what I do Booby and I'm going to do that all of the time
because that's how I like watching content. If you just want
to watch this debate, it's on Pisco's channel. Please, by all
means, off cuz you're here to watch my opinion. That's the whole
point. Thank you. I'm a hypocrite on this issue. Like, yeah,
online politics sucks. No like Holmes, you don't have to tell
me for a decade. That's horrible. No, but I'm just saying that
when you're trying to appeal to a side of the media where the
entire goal of that that side is the destruction of the Democratic
party, listen, I mean, I can disagree and maybe maybe listen,
you Pisco is not trying to appeal with them. He appeal to them
at all. He's saying, I disagree with here's my position. Pisco
comes out, he goes, here's my position on this and then people
will come to disagree. It turns out that a lot of liberal people,
a lot of people who would have been former Destiny fans, right,
probably came on and were like, "Wait, I think Ethan's totally
justified in all of this and they went to debate." And so Pisco
debated it. That's how it went. It wasn't I'm going to figure
out what position I can use to defend Hassan [__]
which is the implication when it says you're appealing to that
side of the internet, right? Pisco, he looks at an issue, he
builds up a positive position, and he states it. And the implication
from everybody else is Pisco is going from a position from a
base level is saying what can I do to appeal to Hassan? And then
he builds his position from that. This is false. This is incorrect.
You know what? You know what I love? You know what would be the
best thing in the world is if 12 months from now I'm on stream
eating and all of these leftists are like it we're going to support
the Democrats. We're going to camp canvas for them and Pisco
was so right. I'd be like oh it I was totally wrong. You know
the last 10 years weren't indicative. I don't think anywhere
Pisco is literally saying I'm not trying to appeal to Hassan.
I'm like I'm literally just giving my opinion and now Destiny
is saying yeah if your appeal to Hassan works like I'll eat Crow
on this. That's not Pisco's position. Pisco is saying he doesn't
have to cut Hassan out and he will give his position and then
people will come and debate right >> with the motion for
you know me I guess but in my mind and I bet money on it with
odds like what's going to happen is in six to 12 months all these
guys are gonna be on Democrats constantly. the only candidates
they're going to support >> So this whole this whole diet
tribe on the side here from Destiny is not tangibly responding
to any criticisms.
Destiny Pisco's complaint is Destiny, why are you misrepresenting
my positions and the way I arrive at them to your audience causing
them to come and brigade me? Destiny, why are you Bro, what is
happening with Pisco's eyes? Was he crying? Lol. Right. Like
this this entire thing where he's like continued to malign uh
Aaron. I can't believe Pisco is so insanely bad faith. Oh, dude.
The fact that Pisco is legit demanding me to produce clips of
Aaron's belief on the spot. Like, what? That's an insane demand.
I can't believe Pisco is so insanely bad faith. Pisco literally
said, "What makes you think that?" Like, "What makes you think
she's an ML?" Pisco knew she was a communist was like, "What
do you think from the from the communist perspective, like the
step towards Marxist Leninism? What do you think makes her take
that step? Or what basis do you have for believing she's taken
that step?" And Destiny goes, "It's so insanely bad faith of
you to request a clip for me on the spot. Like, it's so disgusting
that you would do this." No, I'm saying you could just speak
your words. Just use your words and tell me what you think takes
her from communist to Marxist Leninist.
Right. So, Pisco's complaint is this is insane to do to somebody
who's your friend who whose political positions and and approach
you've championed for years and do to do so with no actual basis.
you are you are lying to your audience, right? And Destiny's
response is, "Well, if your reach out to Hassan does work, that's
already framed up. That is not a part of the conversation." He's
not asking if you think he's cuz he said, "I'm not appealing
to Hassan. I'm not like trying to go and appeal to Hassan from
this." But I just have to explain it to people because if you
don't actually listen and pay close attention, you would think
that Destiny's responding to something Pisco has said or a position
Pisco has. He's not. He is implicitly lying about Pisco's position
by responding this way, which I it's it's actually he's obviously
been very good at debate for years and years and years. And so
I feel like it's it's important that people can analyze these
things and show you what's actually happening because it's very
difficult to follow for most people, right? And if anybody disagrees
with that, they can come on and explain to me why I'm wrong.
Let's continue. Are going to be ones that are avowedly socialist
communist, maybe mostly ones that are primary um like the the
already elected Dems and that's going to be it. And then at the
end of the day, they're going to continue the rhetoric of both
sides are the same. Both sides are the same. Like, why do you
think the Republican party is so unpopular right now, but the
Democratic party isn't popular at all. It's not just because
the Dems suck. It's because literally everybody tells you the
Dems suck. The Republicans tell you the Dem suck. The Dems tell
you the Dem suck. And >> that's that's Pisco's position.
He's now he's now giving Pisco's position back to him, right?
Pisco's position is we should have a strong identity that people
want to support. And I think it starts with Joe Biden. And like
like he's just going to restate Pisco's position as if there
wasn't already a contention as if he wasn't calling Pisco >> The
Dems suck. The leadership right now is and >> Oh, hold
on. Hold on. >> You agreed with that. >> Sorry. The
strategy from the Dems suck. The the the positions the moral
positions don't suck. That's my bad. >> With that on the
No, what I mean is the current leadership, the makeup right now,
the Dems are in disarray. The the leaders are not doing a good
job. And I have talked about it. doesn't make me uh like my critique
bad faith or I'm trying to appeal to lefties when I say that
you know Joe Biden did a Trumpian thing. I'm not saying that
to appeal to tankies. I'm not saying that it's a Trumpian thing
to do to like put your family before the country that kind of
thing and that it's just as bad as what Trump did. I'm not saying
it because I'm trying to appeal like what commie is appealing
to like is listening to that being like oh yeah he's on Biden
for the pardon. Most commies are like oh I think it's based that
he pardoned. So the whole point Oh, actually there's a great
point here that I don't even know if Pisco gets into. I'll let
him finish >> They're like, "Oh, yeah. We love that he
parted Hunter because he's a good dad." That's usually part Hunter
because the Dems and the Republicans are the same anyway. And
if you want to criticize Joe Biden for pardoning Hunter, Joe
Biden made a massive mistake. The mistake was saying that he
wouldn't do it. It wasn't actually pardoning him after three
years of a Republican witch hunt of of the 15th one they've done.
It was that he said that he was going to do it. He should he
shouldn't have said. Well, you can say you can say that's reason.
But my intention when it's when when I say things like Joe Biden,
you know, he got the election in in that sense. He screwed us
over. Uh Joe Biden, you know, despite all the good things, I
say he's the best president. I still say he's the best president
of my lifetime. I still say that um that but that he did a Trumpian
move by closing the border and by and by pardoning his son. I'm
not trying to appeal to commies and when I criticize Chuck Schumer
and say he should retire. when I criticize uh any all everyone
who voted to censure Al Green, I'm not >> Pisco believes
that his job is to give his opinion as it is, right? And that
by doing that by by people will eventually accumulate towards
him and and follow him as an influencer because if he gives his
opinion as it is, he will be like reliable over time and people
will continue following him. He'll amass something that he can
have a significant political impact with, right? So, I want to
give my position as it is. If Pisco believes that Chuck Schumer
is too old to run the Democratic party, if Pisco believes that
uh Joe Biden pardoning his son was wrong, he has to say so because
what he doesn't want, this is the thing. I will ride with any
criticism people have of me and I can deal with it. If I've done
something wrong or I say something wrong and you criticize that
and I believe in it, I will take that criticism
on the chest, right? I I don't need to dodge it. It's fine. But
what's untenable, the worst thing in the world is to try to lie
or mitigate your opinion and then that's proven wrong, right?
To help somebody else out. I'm going to try to help out, let's
say, um, let's say I was good friends with Pirate Software and
I wanted to lie about what happened in that raid to help him
out, right? And then the whole thing blows up the way it does
and I end up getting like semi-cancled myself or I have a whole
bunch of people leave because I gave a horrible opinion on what
happened in that raid and how he ended up roaching out. Right?
If that happens, I can't stomach that. If I had to if I hid or
if I hid my position or I lied about my position to to cover
for him and now I'm getting because of it, that is the worst
feeling in the world. There is nothing worse than that, right?
I'm literally getting with for an opinion I don't even have.
No, Asold's actually a [__] And when he got criticized
for that, he really believed that opinion probably. But I'm telling
you that I getting criticized over opinion you don't have. So
if you are doing politics and you see something wrong that's
happened and you claim you're a moral actor, you're a lawyer
and you're saying morally this is wrong, right? You call out
Republican corruption all the time, you're the guy who calls
out corruption and then Joe Biden does something that is transparently
corrupt. How do you look to your audience if you refuse to call
that out? And how do you deal with that criticism a year from
now, three years from now when people pull that clip up and say,
"Hey, when Joe Biden pardoned his son after saying he wouldn't
do it, why did you run defense for him? Why did you cover for
this guy? That seems totally
so Pisco is doing the thing that everybody should do, right?
You actually make the Now, does he did he focus on it? Does he
like hammer people on that?" No. Unless Unless people want to
come and say, "Hey, Pisco, you're really us over by not calling
this out, right? or by calling this out, which is probably what
happened in that case, too. I'm guessing he doesn't really want
to talk about that all the time. But if people are going to come
on and say, "No, no, it's totally legitimate for Biden to pardon
his son," he'll go, "Okay, we'll debate it." Right? That's how
all of these issues that they're hitting him over end up coming
about because somebody, okay, I'm not going to blame it all on
DG, but it probably is significantly DG. They disagree with his
position very significantly, right? They totally disagree with
his position. and they come in and they argue and they keep arguing
and he keeps like kind of cutting their heads off and sending
them on their way, right? Totally owning them and then he just
keeps keeps rolling. But I'm telling you that you dude, it's
so much easier to deal with a bad decision if it's the bad decision
you wanted to make. Making a decision that isn't even the decision
you actually wanted to make in the moment and then having to
live with criticism for it because it's the wrong decision, that
is the worst feeling in the world. You never want that feeling,
right? And I'm sure Pisco knows that. And it doesn't even have
to be big things, right? Like it could be, you know, you get
caught doing something bad in elementary school and you you like
lie to cover for one of your friends and then they find out you
lied. Somebody finds out you lied and you end up getting for
that, right? You get get over for that. Like kids don't like
you or something, right? I'm trying to make up a situation. It's
just like one of those things where it's like so much easier
to deal with a criticism of you rather than a criticism of somebody
you're not. >> Not trying to appeal to commies. I'm trying
to make the Democrats better. I'm trying to make the Democrats
stronger cuz I
>> uh I would say I would say this is probably a big thing
here. uh Berkeley, whatever your name is, that Hutch saying Biden
should say a candidate. I would say if your if your rationale
for saying Biden should say the candidate is I just need to fall
in line with Dems. That is tough. And you now you're going to
get cooked for it because Biden ended up being like brain damaged,
right? His brain melted out of his ears. So now you look stupid
for a position you didn't even want to take. That's rough. >> I
think these guys if these guys are in charge, we are we are cooked.
And the only the only way we're going to win an election is just
because maybe the Trump is so unpopular. But it's we're not maximizing
our chances by having these people in charge. And so, yeah, I've
sh on the Democrats a great deal. Josiah has, Hutch has, Economy
has. Now, there's some bad faith criticism. There's some good
faith criticism. But what you can't say what you can't say is
giving a hard-hitting interview to Alyssa Slotkin is like incompatible
with us like going on these shows or like or you know, >> sorry,
that is just the best example, right? Crystal Ball has a moral
compulsion to help the people in Gaza. She's close to the issue.
She's been pro Palestine from the start. I don't know if she
totally opposed the ground war from Israel, but she has been
in uh she's been in on this issue from the very beginning and
she sees what's happening and she feels morally compelled to
stand up for her position because what she could probably do
what she could stomach is being wrong on that issue or or you
know it turned out that she was wrong in in supporting Palestinians
and oh I don't know way more people supported or something than
like at least that's what she believes but if she didn't stand
up for her beliefs in that interview and then people criticized
her for it and it turns out that like like 400,000 and gazins
die in the next like two months because of starvation or something
that wouldn't be something she could bear right you have to stand
up for what you believe in especially when you strongly believe
it right and so I don't believe in any way that a a hard interview
on the Israel Palestine question with an elected Democrat representative
is a thing that should be a priority ruled out for people who
are in democratic media that's insane >> fundamentally
trying >> you know it's not it's not it's never just that
in a vacuum it's just that like like I agree that dem leadership
is [__] on the Dems, too. I thought I I joked that
we I don't even know if I was joking. I I would primary any Dem
that voted to centra out. Insane. Okay. Like, yeah, they definitely
have their problems, but like, holy, if you're a Democrat, like
Oh, this is a good point. Desi argued till the last minute for
Biden to stay in and looked as a result. Polls showed Biden was
hurting Dems's down ballot nationally, and Destiny ignored it.
Yes, Destiny argued against it the whole time. No, Biden, keep
Biden, keep Biden, keep Biden. And he'll say because Kamala lost
that like probably keep Biden was the position. It was never
the position. and him holding that position hurt Dems long term.
People trying to appeal to loyalty instead of to logic or instead
of to evidence, right? That is never going to work for a political
party long term. It seems to be working for the Republicans and
I understand that it looks bad, right? It seems to be working
for Republicans, but I don't even know if they argue for loyalty.
I feel like they just spend a lot of time focusing on criticizing
Democrats. I think that's more what it is, right? They try to
get out of appealing to Trump's loyalty or or loyalty to Trump
like personally, right? Except Tim. Tim's gross. like best president
of my lifetime. >> What do you even build? >> Sorry,
I have to use the bathroom really quickly and get more water
because I've been talking a lot. I'm going to back it up like
40 seconds. I'll be right back. We are cooked and the only the
only way we're going to win an election is just because maybe
the Trump is so unpopular, but it's we're not maximizing our
chances by having these people in charge. And so, yeah, I've
on the Democrats a great deal. Josiah has, Hutch has, Economy
has. Now, there's some bad faith criticism. there's some good
faith criticism, but what you can't say what you can't say is
giving a hard-hitting interview to Alyssa Slotkin is like incompatible
with us like going on these shows or like or or you know fundamentally
trying to >> it's not it's not it's never just that in
a vacuum. It's just that like like I agree that Dem leadership
was like I showed on the Dems too. I thought I'd [__]
I joke that we I don't even know if I was joking. I I would [__]
primary any Dem that voted to centra out agree. It's [__]
insane. Okay. Like, yeah, they definitely have their problems.
But like, holy [__] if you're a Democrat, like I
don't know what are you even building towards and who are you
building for, right? Like, what was the constant criticism? Like,
these guys need to go out and do podcast more. They need to go
more. I remember joking before the election, if Kamla went on
any right-leaning podcast, she'll be eviscerated. Um, her interview
on her interview on like CNN, I think it was with Walt, that
was a hard interview and that was on like a liberal platform
and no centrist podcast is going to host her without it being
incredibly contentious. And it's like, okay, well, cool. Look,
it looks like they're trying to go and do podcasts now. And the
first one she goes on Sagger or whatever is nicer than Crystal
Ball. Crystal Ball's first question to the to the senator was
a why did you even come here? It's like Jesus
journalism stuff like
>> are we are we going to have like a are we going to take
a moral position against somebody in Democratic politics a streamer
being an is that is that what we're going to do? That was really
wrong. It was really wrong of Crystal Ball to do. It's really
wrong of Crystal Ball to be a total [__]
Is that Is that where we want to go? >> Crystal gives hard
interviews. She's not like I don't know what to say. That's She's
known for this. Like I I don't think that she just when it comes
to politicians, especially politicians cuz she Yeah. She thinks
it's a genocide.
would would the politician if if Crystal's known for this, where's
the politician's agency there? Why did the politician decide
to go on that on that
where does the politician have no culpability there to know who
the person is? Know that they're very pro Palestine, know that
they're aggressive in interviews where they disagree vehemently
on an issue. I feel like those are all things you can figure
out, >> Like given her view that Israel is committing a
genocide on Gaza and on the Palestinian people, it makes complete
sense why she would ask that question. Like just grant her view.
Grant her view that she's doing that. like
uhoh.
Am I seeing am I seeing a a Queenman Jtock talking point here?
Uh-oh.
Hey, can you just for a second adopt their worldview and just
say just say if you had that worldview that it's a genocide happening
right now, then that question is totally reasonable, right? Uhoh.
I feel like it's very difficult to argue this, right? It's sorry.
It's incredibly difficult if you grant the worldview to argue
this and I I don't think Destiny wants to give that away. She's
trying to improve the democratic like like imagine that she she
really thought that the democratic base is moving sign >> just
agree with me and you'll see I'm >> No, no, no, no, no.
It's uh what is it? So, Brazilian lad, it's not just agree with
me and you'll see I'm right. It's if you agree on some moral
principle, right, that this is if you agree that genocide is
bad and if you agree on one fact that what's happening there
is akin to genocide. It's either genocide or it's akin to genocide.
It's it's that bad. then obviously it's okay to ask those questions.
There are a ton of people who believe what's happening to the
the Gazins right now is akin to a genocide. That's not really
like a that's not really a fringe belief anymore. It's really
up. So it's not saying agree with me that Israel needs to be
stopped. It's saying we agree on this moral position that it's
okay for me to pressure a senator and say hey I want to pressure
you on this point. We're not saying the senator has to agree,
but the the crystal ball should be able to make her points, right?
>> Significantly towards being pro Palestinian and anti-Israel,
then in some sense, I don't understand why we wouldn't be pressuring
our elected officials to more represent the >> There's
I don't think that the Democratic Party is moving to being pro
>> The polling seems to suggest that. I don't know. Like,
have you seen it? >> I think there's I mean, like I >> He
just said I don't think it's happening. He just like Oh, man.
Thanos with the reality stone right now. >> Like who has
more like I have more sympathy for the Palestinians than Israel.
Like how how you have sympathy for the Israelis. Okay. Intercept
missiles of the out of the middle of the sky. Like there that's
I mean like people are having more sympathy for the Palestinians.
But like when it comes to like the solutions that a lot of the
socialist sites would implement like I don't know how many people
would vote to like pull all support and all fighting for guys.
It's really complex. So ignore all those starving zombies like
fighting over each other for food. It's a really complex issue.
We don't know what solution is best yet. So, we need to figure
that out before we do anything. Before we say, "Hey, Israel,
you need to stop. Hey, Israel, we'll cut off aid if you don't
stop." Right? It would be terrible for us to do that. But just
ignore that pile of zombies over there who are like eating each
other. Don't don't pay any attention to that. No, no, no, no.
We have all the time in the world to argue this right now. >> That's
like a much deeper, much darker question, especially when >> I
feel
the Democrats base is basically saying we don't like the leadership.
I don't think in that context,
that's not just the crazies online. It's not just me and Jaziah
Konboy. It is the broad consensus of the Democratic uh members
that the people who are currently in charge are not doing a good
job and they should be replaced. And I haven't watched the interview
and so I I don't want to comment. Maybe it was inappropriate.
Maybe it was. I I don't in principle have a problem with that
interview um or a hard-hitting interview. But in terms of the
prescriptions, what I what I want to know is how are we up? How
am I up? What am I doing wrong that would cause such an upheaval?
Like like my my my mentions are insane. Like people saying like
you abandoned liberalism. It it's crazy.
>> Like appe I mean like going back to I guess to say I
think appealing to the values of socialists is the same thing
as appealing to the values of other illiberal groups like fascist.
>> Okay. I haven't I don't know how I've done that. when
you say because if you define socialism in the sense that like
of that of the whatever your version of it is I don't how have
I done that I'm we're debating the Vanguard for example like
how to implement Biden's strategy Biden's policy Biden's promises
Biden's $15 minimum wage not some crazy >> sorry I have
to pull this back just a
>> up what am I doing wrong >> yes sorry sorry I
do need to pull this back online it's not just me and Josiah
Connor boy >> it is the broad consensus of the Democratic
uh members that the people who are currently in charge are not
doing a good job and they should be replaced. And I haven't watched
the interview and so I I don't want to comment. Maybe it was
inappropriate. Maybe it was. I I don't in principle have a problem
with that interview um or a hard-hitting interview. But in terms
of the prescriptions, what I what I want to know is how are we
[__] up? How am I [__] up? What am I
doing wrong?
>> Yes. Where is the challenge for Pisco? Right. So basically,
okay,
I don't think I don't think uh Crystal did something wrong, but
even if she did, that's still not even a criticism of me. So
what what prescription do you have for me? And as much as Destiny
can get mad, right? He gets mad that this clip's from 8 months
ago, right? He gets mad and says, "It's so totally unreasonable
for Pisco to pull this clip and to hold me to anything here."
Destiny had this exact position that collabing with these people.
If it works towards my goals, my goals as in Democratic candidates
being elected, which is Pisco's primary goal, right? Then I can
do that. >> That would cause such an upheaval like like
my my mentions are insane. Like people saying like you abandoned
liberalism. It's crazy.
>> Like appeal I mean like going back to I guess to say
I think appealing to the values of socialists is the same thing
as appealing to the values of other illiberal groups like fascist.
>> Okay. I haven't I don't know how I've done that. >> Appealing
to tankies or socialists. So he just keeps saying that is appealing
to tankies or socialists. How have I done that? Well, by arguing
with my audience when they say you're not sufficiently liberal
enough. When they say you're not sufficiently denouncing Hassan
enough. Like you're you're you're not sufficiently going after
Hassan. That's that's the evidence, right? Destiny's audience
coming over to Pisco and saying, "I disagree with you on the
Ethan lawsuit." That is Destiny's evidence that Pisco is like
appealing to tankies or socialists, right? That is that is the
thing. Hold on. Where's the Ethan thing? Yes. Yes. The Ethan
thing is right here. Right. He went on off on Ethan for like
a week over the lawsuit thing. It's like literally DJers who
come in and argue with Pisco that Pisco's positively built position
is like not suff. It's like too open to Hassan not being bad
enough. Right. That's it. That's it. He keeps trying to engage
Destiny on his audience. Smearing Pisco and Destiny won't budge.
Destiny is smearing Pisco directly to his audience in his chat.
Right. That's why Pisco believes he's doing it. By the way, continue.
>> When you say cuz >> Pisco's positive position
as in Pisco is not providing a critique, Brazilian lad. Pisco
is saying, "Here is my overall belief on the Ethan Klein thing."
And then when people say, "Oh, uh, even though you say Ethan's
going to win, you did also say he was disingenuous. I want to
argue with you on that." And then Pisco says, "Okay, we'll argue
on that." Right? If you define socialism in the sense that like
of that of the whatever your version of it is, I don't how have
I done that? I'm we're debating the Vanguard for example like
how to implement Biden's strategy, Biden's policy, Biden's promises,
Biden's $15 minimum wage, not some crazy >> I'm curious
then in your Okay, since Okay, if I'm brain broken on this, why
do you think Hutch had such a contention with the conversation?
Brother, I I just wish Pisco Pisco will probably get there eventually
if they talk more. But I would just wonder why Pisco doesn't
just say, "Why are you appealing to Hutch? Could you Destiny
and Zip both, right? Could you have a spine for two seconds and
make your own prescription? Could you have a spine and say what
your problem is? Don't say, "Well, Hutch is why did Hutch have
this problem?" No, you have to have a problem and then you have
to have the evidence. You are here arguing with me. Use your
big boy your big boy brain. Okay, pull your pants up. Get get
focused and tell me what your issue is.
Do not appeal to Hutch. Do not appeal to anybody else. Do not
go, "Oh, it kind of looks weird when you do this." Okay, don't
do it. Stop. >> And after it happened, I >> What
was his problem? >> Okay. I love Hutch. Hutch is my boy.
>> Take a shot. Take a shot. Hutch is my boy. Take a shot.
Hutch is wonderful and I always stand by Hutch.
I think >> that a bus I hear coming. You're about to throw
him under. >> I'm not throwing him under I what I I >> So
Pisco should have absolutely I believe in this exact instance
gone and pointed out directly, hey, I'm not asking for Hutch's
opinion. I'm sorry. Were you Did you not have a reason you agreed
with Hutch? What was your reason you agreed with Hutch? Because
I've argued Pisc. All Pisco has to say is I disagreed with Hutch.
But if you don't know what Hutch's positions are, then why are
you making a criticism if you're just going to fall back to talk
to Hutch? I could have just talked to Hutch. I got Hutch on Discord.
Are you doing here? If I wanted to ask Hutch what his disagreements
were, I'd go ask Hutch, "What is your purpose? Why the do you
exist? Why do you exist right now? What is your purpose on this
earth? You come here and you come, you say to me on the day of
my daughter's wedding, well, what why did Hutch have a problem?
Shut the up." and legitimately think this that when Hutch hears
us like granting some amount of agreement, which we legitimately
do with the Vanguard, which is basically that Joe Biden should
have signaled better. He should have seemed more strong. He should
have postured more. Not with the specifics of kicking Mansion
out in West Virginia. Not with the specifics of actually obtaining
a $15 minimum wage from Joe Mansion, which we both acknowledge
is impossible, but just with a more macro view of the Vanguard.
That is to say that the Democrats should look like they're giving
an abstract strategy that they think works really well for the
Trump administration and Trump himself. And so we'd like to adopt
some version of that less less aggressively for the Democrats.
Hey, how can we like like yes, we'll allow descent. Descent is
okay, but descent should cost you >> even a little bit
more which I think is a modest take a modest proposal. I think
that Hutch I similar to the audience which maybe it's reasonable
took that kind of optical stance of us being like well we're
you know middle of the road on the one hand you know Hutch has
a point here on the mansion stuff but you know the Vanguard is
saying this and he took that in the way that many people might
have reasonably took which is that we are trying to both sides
it and we're not really having his back here. Um, but it was
our honest take and it is still my opinion and I was more defensive
of Hutch with respect to like the personal comments that the
the Vanguard had made about like his lip ring and that kind of
stuff and it seemed like they ironed that out at the beginning
and so I was I wasn't really think I was just trying to give
my honest take in that moment. Um, and and Hutch might have felt
away about that but um I I I don't think it's because we were
genuinely stabbing him in the back or trying to gaslight him.
We I I promise you >> I don't know what the lip ring thing
is. I was like, "No, sorry. I promise you I'm not gaslight. I
promise you that I am just formulating my opinion in real time
and being honest about it." But people took that. >> If
you had to I'm just curious. If you had to guess for like a live
and learn audience right now, if you had to guess what percentage
of them um voted for the for Kamla in the last election, in your
mind, what do you peg that percentage
>> Okay. And then >> what? Why? How could it possibly
be? Dude, this audience is built, sorry, this group is built
entirely of like former Destiny Orbiters, like people who advocate
for liberalism. All like super liberal people up until a con
boy. A Connor boy advocated for like sock dem stuff and now has
come out as like he's thinks he's a full socialist, right? But
a boy like obviously would be like blue no matter who, right?
And everybody else is just like a full-on liberal. If you had
to feel like what percentage of them would have like enthusiastically
supported Kla as a candidate against Trump, not just hated Trump,
but enthusiastically supported Kla as a candidate. In your mind,
what is that >> My intuition is 80.
>> Okay. In my mind, those numbers are like 50 20. No,
not that. But like 60 40. >> Oh, this is um But this here's
what this is is this is Destiny trying to plant the seeds of
like, oh, this is like the this is like the Jtock Queen and Snark
audience that's here watching Pisco now. It's all the JTO, Queen,
and Snark audience, and they're they're going to warp your mind,
Pisco. They're going to warp your mind. They wouldn't vote for
Kamla ever. It's like, dude, I I voted for Mark Carney. Well,
not technically Mark Carney, but technically my MP, but I voted
for Mark Carney, right? Like, I I'm so I'm so flipped on this
over the Trump thing that I'm enthusiastically supporting the
most zogged neoliberal candidate in my that my country can offer,
right? Like I'm so done with populism that I will take, listen,
I'll take the most zogged up neoliberal candidate, world government.
Okay. Yeah, let's go. Globalism. Globalism now over whatever
this populist thing is. I'm done with it. Okay. I'm done with
it. Throw it out. Get it the out of here.
Right.
Who Who in my audience is sitting here like, "No, no, no. I hate
all these Democrats. I I I just not vote instead of voting."
I don't know. Maybe some of these people. Maybe the verain guy.
May
>> I have a lot of conservatives. I'll I'll eat the bugs
over having Trump like sell out America to all of its enemies.
I'll eat the bugs. I will. I'll eat the bugs.
>> Supported Kla as a candidate against Trump. Not just
hated Trump, but enthusiastically supported Kla as a candidate.
In your mind, what is that >> My intuition is 80. I don't
know. >> Okay. In in my mind, those numbers are like 50
20. No, not that. But like 60 40 is where I've >> I have
a lot of conservatives in my >> Why are they talking again?
Are they actually rekindling their streamer friendship? I thought
he jumped ship after the Pixie stuff. I think Pisco wants he's
got long-term aspirations and he didn't know like he obviously
wouldn't have like a ton of evidence and he felt like it was
incumbent on him as the as the person who is a lawyer who his
fans like him for being a lawyer to not comment on it and not
prejudice people even audience members either way. So he jumped
out and he said like and I think broadly, you know, the fact
that this could happen was already indicative. Even if he totally
believed like even if he believed it was made up, even if he
believed Destiny's narrative one to one right now, I still think
he'd be like, I'm kind of backing off because this is like this
is just not the kind of thing I want my name associated with,
right? That like you're you're sending all these all these things
non-conensually and multiple women have come out and accused
you of this. That's not something I want my name associated with,
right? So Pisco Pisco said, "I'm done with you for that." I don't
think he's ever but I don't think he's rekindling his streamer
friendship. I think he thinks that Destiny has a lot of audience
members. There's a lot of audience overlap probably and that
Destiny is explicitly lying about him to those audience members,
right? And his positions and I think he's kind of sick of it
and he sees debate as the best way to iron out these issues and
get people to stop with him. I think that is what he sees it
as. That's how I interpret this. I don't see this as like Destiny
and Pisco getting back together. Uh I don't see it as like Pisco
betraying like Pixie or something. That would be insane. It's
just he thinks everything I've seen about Pix Pisco says I think
debate's the best way to resolve any difference. Even like bad
faith people people lying about me and bad faith maliciously.
Right. I think debate's the best way to to answer this and he's
going to go in debate. Right. That's uh that's how he sees it.
Pixo. Yes. Exactly. Um you could say this at Bagel and Coffee,
but I think Pisco does a good job. It's good that Pisco does
this, right? I I can point out to you guys where they're like
where Destiny's being manipulative or his audience is being manipulative.
That can be what I do. I can watch this content and I can show
you exactly where he's trying to be manipulative the whole time.
I don't need Pisco to go do it. I don't need Pisco to do any
of that, right? I just want Pisco to be correct on the issues
and be somebody who like is morally good and doesn't, you know,
doesn't like malign people whose consent he's violated because
he wants to get away with it or something. I would just rather
have Pisco. I feel like I can engage with politics because Pisco
and Josiah and Acono Boy and Hutch are doing their show and there's
nobody there who I feel like is a morally like bad a moral I
was gonna say morally black, but like yeah, just somebody who
would like do these kinds of things, do these like consent violations
and then totally denigrate those same victims, right? I I just
I like that there's somebody I can watch in politics that I feel
like does a good job and I is not morally bankrupt, let's say.
That's that's what I like. So again, if if he were to like go
and like start, you know, hamming it up with Destiny, I'd feel
like weird about that just given the stuff that Destiny's done.
But I'm not going to I'm not going to go after Pisco over that.
Okay, that's not his job is to to go on
>> We'll just see. I I believe also, by the way, the truth
will win out. So whatever the truth is, I believe that will win
out in the end. Okay. >> I have a lot of
Sure. That's not fair. >> But but I I think most of the
people who watch my are Dems. I I do dem I talk about how Trump
is half the time. And when I >> keep say I don't understand
if you I don't know if you get this. Keep when you keep saying
I just talk about how Trump is. Like that's the end. They agree
with you there. Like the like socialists will agree with you
that Trump is bad, but they're just going to say that the Dems
are about the same. >> So wait,
hold on. What why is Destiny doing the Gen 6 documentary if if
that's like an in for socialist? Trump is bad. I I the whole
point there would be all of these people all the people doing
dem where Trump is bad those people would all have the same in
with those same people including Destiny. So the question is
where has where has Pisco been not like dismissive enough of
those people or where has he been aggressively like pursuing
some socialist agenda that those people like him more or stay
with him cuz otherwise you just have all of the you know anti-Trump
as it's called that exists on YouTube and Pisco is far from the
only person doing that. Destiny himself does that. Okay. My intuition
is that these people acknowledge like I wear my heart on my sleeve.
I
look at my >> post. I was curious like I see like there
like Cy Booker and stuff and it's like Jesus Christ. >> Yeah.
Cy Booker's cringe. Cy Booker is >> Cy Booker can be cringe.
Cy Booker is
cringe in many. >> Yes. Pisco. Yes. Pisco. Use my talking
points. Bisco. You're doing so terrific. Pisco. Come over to
the dark side.
Come over to the dark side, Bisco. Yes.
>> Respects. Now, I think Cory Book >> I I watched
a decent amount of this last night. I forgot that that's the
exact thing that was said, but uh I forgot that that was the
exact thing that was I watched I like have actually pre-watched
some of this >> for sometimes. One of the only ones doing
anything at the moment. >> Yeah, he stood up for 28 hours.
>> What do you want? >> Cory Booker's cringe. Like
the guy's >> I don't know. All I'm telling you is Cory
Booker sometimes does cringe things. It's me. It's me. It's me,
Pisco,
Hassan, Bad Empanada, and Queman in a group call as we all fall
asleep. Okay, that's what it is.
I It sucks that it it gets exposed this way. Okay, it sucks that
it gets exposed this way that I've known who Cory Booker is now
for years. I'm not telling you that Cory Booker shouldn't vote
for Cory Booker. I would need to know the context of the tweet
about Cory Ber. Now, I saw what he said about Pete Buddha Judge.
I think that's [__] >> Pete Buddha Judge >> stupid
wrong. and Pete Buddhaj I would be proud to support Buddhaj and
if it came down to it and they still were still talking and he
were the nominee you better believe I'm going to go on those
streams and be like why are you saying don't vote for Buddhajitch
why are you not enthusiastically supporting Buddhaj like I did
in the leadup to the 2024 election when I was debating vigorously
with lefties about not including ogre boy who just talk to you
I was debating them vigorously to vote for Kla Harris enthusiastically
so to >> well I think ogre boy claims he did vote for Kamala
enthusiastically >> act as though I wouldn't stand on business
when we have a nominee or like like part of the whole thing of
the beauty of the Democratic nomination process which you've
acknowledged
is to sus out what the direction of the part is going to be.
This is the time when the Democrats need to define themselves.
And so if there's ever a moment for internal critique, if there's
ever a moment for us to decide what the direction is, it would
be now. And so I'm going to be much more accommodating of that
kind of disagreement here in steading the ship perhaps towards
them. Okay. Trump bad. Trump bad. Trump bad. >> Okay. I
don't necessarily disagree with you here, but like
>> there there's there's a limit though. >> Nobody
wants you. Nobody wants you there, man. [__] out.
>> Like what could happen in the primary process, right?
So like if there's two candidates and one is like $7 an hour
minimum wage and the other's like 15 an hour minimum wage. And
I look at the sevenour minimum wage person, I'm like, "This person
wants to, you know, I think this is almost like a slave labor
wage. I don't think this is good. Like this is horrible." If
that person wins the primary, I can like kind of begrudging like,
"Okay, yeah, whatever. Fine. will support this person, but if
I spend the entire primary calling this person or calling them
genocide Joe, how the am I ever expecting that group of people
like let's like you said earlier, if you really believe that
that Crystal Ball believes that there's a genocide going on and
she's going to push hard on, you know, the the whoever she comes
to interview, well, if all the socialists literally believe that
it's an actual genocide and the Democrats are complicit in it,
holy, how do you vote for like Junior? Like, I don't think you
can get them on your side at that point. I don't think they're
ever going to join. >> It's tough. But the but but the
pro the but like I can't >> uh I mean uh realistically
the argument should have been that you have bridges with these
people and you talk about the reality of the fact
the reality of the of the the material facts on the ground okay
are that Trump was going to write a blank check for Gazin's Gaza's
destruction and there's at least some shred of a hope that Biden
could stand up and stand on principle and actually tell BB to
off. I'm sorry. Trump is like Trump was like the Trump was literally
gonna be like, "Yeah, you you want those people all starving
to death without any qualms from us?" Yeah. Awesome. Awesome.
BB Baby, have you bought your Trump coin? BB, have you bought
your requisite $50 million of Trumpcoin? Okay, show me the receipt.
Okay. All right. We can do it. We can do it. Yeah, you those
goins. It's fine. >> Can't change them into not believing
that. First of all, because I do believe it because one one is
because I do affirm it and I do believe it now uh that it is
a genocide. put that aside. But separately, like even if I didn't,
I can't change the that notion. I can't I can't change their
mind. But like if you can't change it, like that's part of my
point. There's too many beliefs that can't be changed without
sacrificing. >> It's really just the Israel belief. That's
like it >> like the whole other like the whole mask of
the ship of the party because now you have to basically become
socialist or quasi socialist and then you're gonna end up >> and
the the funny thing is is remember what Destiny said about why
Hassan and Bosch couldn't support him or couldn't be do content
with him, right? They lied too much about him and now they look
really bad to their audience if they flipped on him, right? I
wonder if he's not, you know, now when he goes back and watches
that watches that clip, he might not think the same thing about
Israel a little bit that he came out hard. He caped hard for
Israel, right? Totally talked down any talking points that said,
"Hey, Israel might not really want, you know, just peace in this
region. They might actually want more than just peace in this
region." Absolutely destroyed, eviscerated anybody who said that.
And now, if he's going to go back and explain to people that
like, hey, actually seems like those people are starving. It
seems kind of up. It's like now I I feel like he's probably he
might have a hard time going back, right? And I wonder if that's
not where a lot of this comes from is he also he probably's got
to eat crow from some of the people he hates most, right? Who
are arguing on the other side. Might have been arguing. You could
you could say they were arguing without the facts on their side,
right? He could say that, but he'd have to go, "Yeah, I guess
Assan was kind of right about this that Israel was going too
far, right?" End up bleeding off like like half the party doing
that cuz you're your base or your >> You totally can, King
Gedra. But I wonder if there's not something preventing people
from doing that. You totally can change your position. It's totally
justified to change your position, but it's also probably justified
to have thought that this would be the case before this. Assan
is bad. Assan is bad. Sorry, those just came through for me.
>> I I think that more and more people you're seeing in
the polling that yes, this is a very divisive issue, but the
Netanyahu and Israel is not popular right now. And it's >> we
keep saying that, but you know what's really not popular is socialists.
Like how many >> Yeah. I mean, >> what is that? What
was that? What is that? Hello, bro. This guy's losing it. You
know what's not popular in Israel?
What? How many years, decades have we heard that it's like, "This
is the election. This is the time where they're all going to
come out and over resoundingly, they get crushed over and over
and over again." Like, why do we think that this is the path
forward? I don't think if but what you mean by socialism if what
you mean by socialism is tankism
or Marxist Leninism I don't think it's the way forward but we
have Manny AOC you think AOC might be the way forward that's
not socialism in your mind so if that's what people mean by socialism
if that's what people think is the way forward people like AOC
and Bernie great and if people have
you know are too harsh on those people I'm going to fight them
for sure And I will support people like AOC and Bernie and I
agree that they're not left enough for the purists and for the
lefties and that kind of but at the end of the day like what
am I to do? I'm going to try to marshall what I can. I'm going
to try to push people in the right direction when I can to vote
for the Democratic candidate. And I don't think any mainstream
Democrat right now is the worry. The worry is as you mentioned
>> I think when you say what you do I think it's pushing
and building on the Democratic side of things. not building,
not joining a media apparatus that almost exclusively rewards
only attacking the Republicans and then only on Dems because
that's only attacking the Republicans and then only on Dems.
I I Okay. I rewarding them. So, the idea of I guess rewarding
Crystal Ball and rewarding her with collaborations where you
go on and say where you disagree, I don't Yeah, I don't even
get it. It's like it's totally discordant. It's totally different
from his opinion back here. like it's entirely different, right?
It's not rewarding them to go on and say, "Hey, I've seen your
opinions on Democrats. Let me change your mind." That's not rewarding
them, right? Which I assume Pisc would do in any case where he
felt like they were being very unfair and on Dems totally unfairly,
right? Apparently, from what I understand, this is what Josiah
did in his first interview with Crystal and Kyle, right? Was
he went on to argue like the Dem side of some issue. So this
clip being again his whole thing about doing synergistic collabs
with Vashan and Hassan after the election. >> If you wanted
to join right now and do media, you're either a Republican or
you're somebody that's probably going to spend a lot of time
on the Dems and or maybe and then maybe also attacking the Republicans
and like that's it. Like in the left wing media apparatus, that's
all there is.
Hey, now Destiny, you've said that's all that there is. Explain
to me why Li and Learn is not the exact thing you're describing.
Got the biggest Democrat shills on the planet. The only person
they're missing is I'm really important. And then they've aligned
the the
what is it? What's the Captain Planet squad called? The I can't
even remember. Oh, they've aligned like all of the stones of
Democrat like partisanship to be on the same side, right? That
is the planeteers. Yeah, the planeteers of DNC support. Okay.
That's literally what they've aligned with. Like all these people
love the Democrats. You're literally describing Lib and Learn.
He's saying it sucks that live and learn doesn't exist and my
proof is live and learn. That's what he's doing, right? I think
that's what he's doing is live and learn is the side that says
here's the criticism of the Democrats. We know that they're way
better than Republicans. We hate Trump, but here's like the criticism.
We'll engage with it. We'll argue about it. Right?
That's that is what live and learn is. He's just he's lamenting
the fact that Live and Learn doesn't exist while trying to drive
a wedge between the hosts of it and actually maliciously lying
about one of the hosts of it. Very sad. >> And I just think
it's really sad that like now how do we appeal to these people
who have all built careers out of just relentlessly attacking
>> you say that but there's just no example of me doing
that. Right. >> Exactly. I I I get that some people. >> Well,
not you, but you guys have a show called Live and Learn where
now 1/4 of your cast is socialist and now you're
>> he means by social but what he means by >> he's
by the way in case any DJers are watching right now and they
think that that was unfair for me to say that he doesn't like
Lib and Learn. He is there he is right there.
If he if only he'd waited a little longer I feel like I would
have had a DJ come in and go he doesn't hate lib and learn at
all
list. I I but I respect his truth. That's what he means by socialist.
But you take issue with that label even though it doesn't match
what you vision as of >> I don't really take issue with
the label. I respect his truth too. Okay. I don't think he's
a secret tanky. But what he sees as his new label, other people
see as an opportunity to infect and then spread the anti-liberal
ideology. It's not it's not like like again if it was like if
we were in a room full of clones of Bernie Sanders and AOC's
and econo boys like well let's build a socialist. I don't give
a [__] at that point. Sure. But if we were in a room
full of Stalins and Lenins and all these people and then AO boy
you know jumps in. And he's like, "Hey, I'm a socialist. Like,
we should appeal these guys, right?" I'm like, "Let's go to the
[__] other room." >> so what position or what
portion of American socialists do you think are Marxist Leninists?
Like, who's stalin here? What are we doing? >> What do
I do? What do I do? So, >> right. Like, what are we doing?
>> Theology. It's not It's not like like again, if it was
like if we were in a room full of clones of burning
he means by social but what he means by
but I respect his truth. That's what he means by socialist. But
you take issue with that label even though it doesn't match what
you've >> Jimmy Hennessy. Yes, socialism is supposed to
transition to communism. This is true. The speed at which you
do that dictates how much authoritarian power you would need
to seize to get it done. If you believe like Marxist Leninists
do that it is a moral imperative to violently by any means necessary
overthrow the capital capitalist class and using violence if
necessary. Right? Then you're probably somebody that Destiny
or Pisco wouldn't wouldn't appeal to at all. Right? That's a
reach saying one quarter is a socialist. Pisco is saying, "Hey,
I've never done anything." Right? I've never done anything to
to like align with these people. And Destiny's example of him
possibly like signaling out that he's cool, that he like has
socialist beliefs or appealing to socialists is the fact that
Econo Boy decided that he wants to label himself as a socialist
during the show. Destiny is saying that is a bad thing. Destiny
is saying that you shouldn't appeal to people who do this kind
of thing. And you guys are appealing. Lib and Learn has a socialist
on it now. So, you're not liberals anymore. or or he's basically
saying this is what's wrong. So he's arguing that what Lib and
Learn is doing wrong is having a connoy there. No. Pisco says
what have I done wrong? Do we have to roll that back? What have
I done wrong?
Well, you're on a show with like you're on a show called Live
and Learn and one quarter of your is a socialist. Okay. So yeah,
I'm sure Pisco would extend it to what has live and learn done
wrong because this entire thing is downstream of that conversation
with the Vanguard and there still is not a legitimate credible
criticism from Destiny of how they handled the the Vanguard interview.
There is not a single one.
So if there isn't a single credible critique, if his only critique
is, well, why did Hutch think it was bad? If that's his only
critique, I wonder why he's doing this. Why is he lying about
Pisco? Why is he lying and saying that Pisco is like a total
Hassan shill now that he's like he's he's shilling he's trying
to appeal to Hassan's audience by going after Ethan by defending
Hassan on the global entry thing. Why would he be saying that
if he's not trying to with their business? If he's not trying
to make people go and and and essentially like try to change
his mind, right? And not in a good way, not in a fair way, but
based totally on Desi's mischaracterizations of him. Sorry. I
think I think he hates the show because he's clearly arguing
that a Connor boy shouldn't be on the show. He's been arguing
that, right? And he is saying that that show is like appealing,
somebody is appealing to tankies or socialists. And he doesn't
like the idea of appealing to tankies or socialists. So maybe
I need to walk that back from hates, but thinks they're doing
something wrong. You are doing something bad. You are hurting
the Democrats by doing this, which I think he would say, which
I don't think it hates is even that bad a classification. If
you if you think the word hates there is like um what do you
call it? Is like somehow me misrepresenting it. I I don't think
it is. But I'll be even more clear and then we can move forward.
>> Vision is of socialism. >> Take the label. I respect
his truth too. Okay. I don't think he's a secret tanky. But what
he sees as his new label, other people see as an opportunity
to infect and then spread the anti-liberal ideology. It's not
it's not like like again. So where is that happening? Where is
that happening? Where is that happening? And if it was like if
we were why would you why would you eight months ago want to
synergistically work with Vos and Hassan? Aren't they using electoralism
for Democrats to spread the tanky mind virus? Why? Where did
this come from? What has changed about your views that says the
tanky mind virus is the actual problem now, right? That like
they're actually spreading illiberal views everywhere. What has
Hassan done in the past 8 months to change your mind on this
where you would have worked with him before, you would have actually
helped them out before, but now something has changed in a room
full of clones of Bernie Sanders and AOCC's and Econo boys. Like,
well, yeah, let's appeal to socialism. I don't give a [__]
about that point. Sure. But if we were in a room full of Stalins
and Lenins and all these people and then a Connor boy, you know,
jumps in. He's like, "Hey, I'm a socialist. Like, we should appeal
these guys, right?" I'm like, "Let's go to the [__]
other room." >> So, what do I do? What do I do? So, >> so
apparently a Connor boy is going to become a total [__]
who doesn't understand his beliefs, even though he understands
his beliefs far better than Connor or Destiny do, right? Objectively,
he absolutely understands his beliefs better. He has taken a
long time to study and figure out exactly what he thinks about
economics in the world, right? But even even assuming he was
like that much of a [__] what is Pisco supposed to
do about that? Or what what is Pisco looking for? >> Connor
Boy has this whole position about what? First of all, I think
capitalism is based. I've always been like in favor of private
capitalism, but what do you want the like me to do about it?
Like Econ boy, let's have a conversation about communism. A conversation
that you think that I'm not even equipped for. And like what
what what do you want me to do about that? Like he has his position.
It's grounded in this history of uh of you know the socialist
traditions in these other countries in these various countries.
I can't refute that. He's not going to be convinced by me. So,
you want to have struggle session every two seconds about should
be a communist. >> I don't think I don't think there'd
be a debate on him all. >> Okay. So, Destiny is providing
Oh my god. I don't think Destiny is providing us for the first
time. Not maybe not the first time, but one of the very few times
in this argument he's going to actually provide a prescription.
Oh my god. What I think you should do with a Connor boy is let's
hear let's hear what it is >> every two seconds about should
be a >> I don't think I don't think there'd be a debate
on him all the I think that I think if you think that there are
reasons why he's a socialist that are have like >> you
don't give a about this, dude. You don't give you really give
a [__] about this. You don't you don't you're not
scared of econom boy. You're not really scared that economy's
going to >> Oh [__] Pisco is going Is Pisco
Is Pisco going ape mode? Is he going gorilla mode? >> Be
you know he's going to be the Trojan horse by which we're entering
a thousand-year Reich of of Marxist Leninism. You're not actually
scared about that. I I I refuse to believe that like the two
largest leftist streamers in the world literally did that to
me. Like that's literally my life that they came into my community
as suck dems and they are the largest streamers on the left now
and there is an avowed ML and I don't know where the Vos is on
his socialist journey but that's literally my life and you're
telling me that I don't think this could actually happen like
what the wait hold on so so like you would maybe be the worst
person to ask about this? What part of you failing at this over
and over again, being the worst failure in this regard, of looking
at your allies and determining who is sincere in their beliefs,
makes me think that you would be equipped to give Pisco any prescription
here? You're actually just the worst person at judging people's
character that's ever existed. Here, here's a bunch of evidence
that I really suck at actually making any argument or coming
up with any prescription here. Um, so you should take my advice.
What? This is like This is like taking the advice on on driving
safety from somebody who's been in 12 accidents. No, I don't.
No, the accidents actually help me figure out exactly how to
draw within the lines here. Even though I don't make a prescription,
even though I have no prescription that's different from yours
and I can't identify why my position changed from 8 months ago.
Okay, actually, you should listen to me. Okay. Is that statement?
>> I I I think that you're not concerned of econo boy econo
boy becoming one of these figures, are you? Or or I mean >> I
no I I don't know if he in particular would. I'm just saying
that that's the entry point and that's how all these
>> to be fair you were a fan of the guy Jtock I don't how
is this even an equivalent point as soon as I saw who he was
morally I distanced myself right to be fair you were a fan of
this guy means nothing I didn't I didn't get a chance to see
all of this content right this way and as soon as I started watching
it as soon as I started waking up to who he was I got further
and further away from him I don't even know what this means is
work and I'm not sitting here I'm not even sitting here arguing
that nobody should talk to him I'm not sewing the out about Pisco
talking to him, right? I'm not going to pisco and going, "It's
actually totally morally wrong for you to even talk to Destiny
in the first place, even if you're disagreeing with him." So,
I don't know where the comparison is or why you thought that
was a useful piece of input, Red 473, but congratulations. You
said something totally [__] >> And they say
it openly. They openly say
>> Oh, I I mean, >> listen, I don't think Hold on.
I'm not saying that you should watch the show or you can you
should never do content with the Vanguard or anything like that.
I'm just saying that like it's so sad. Like Hutcher is one of
the only people I see now in the world who's not like yeah uh
I'm a Democrat but like oh yeah it's a massive [__]
>> Hutcher is one of the only people around me as a creator
who doesn't still have the DG plantation programming where Hassan
is bad. Hassan is bad.
Isn't Trump bad? No. Hassan is bad. He's like one of the few
people who are still on the plantation who still have the programming.
Right. Hassan is bad. [__] genocide and the Dems
suck and I wish that Biden wouldn't have been
[__] like I just want there to be so just spuring
just completely worthless spuring that bar people can barely
audibly listen to right not not a valid point just spuring >> crap
but like oh yeah it's a massive [__] genocide and
the de >> oh mumble debate is actually
mumble debate is actually something we're going to go with okay
oh Oh my god. Debate scat is like what it is.
>> [__] suck [__] And I wish that
Biden wouldn't have been [__] scenile. It would have
[__] part his [__] son.
Like I just want there to be likehere.
>> I do this sometimes, by the way. What Desi just did.
That's got to go. That's got to go. It's not compelling.
>> Oh yeah. It's a massive genocide and the Dems suck and
I wish that Biden would have been
like I just want there to be likehere in the [__]
world. He should.
Yeah. No, that's You just gave me solid criticisms and you did
them in a straw man voice. That doesn't make them bad. Why would
Why would you doing a straw man voice with those criticisms make
them bad? Excuse me. You just did a straw man voice, but like
I actually have a moral aversion to Biden pardoning his son.
donated $3. You want to do what to >> I don't remember
what I said, but thank you very much for the three internet explorer
guys. We are one sub away from two more hours on the stream.
I think one sub away from two more hours in the stream. I haven't
chilled very much today cuz I'm just enjoying the content. But
go ahead, get those subs in so that we can go a little further.
I'm not going to spend a lot of time shilling because I want
to get to the content. >> Have he liberal? I don't. That's
fine. But I like I need like one [__] other liberal
on the [__] planet on this platform anywhere that's
not just constantly, okay, bending over to take it up the ass,
okay, from every single other [__] political partisan,
okay? just somebody to that can actually just stand on business
for like liberal >> Well, you have 100 >> that but
but standing on business for liberal politics is not defending
you're literally just advocating for blue MAGA, right? Like it's
not defending Hunter or Joe Biden pardoning his son. That's not
that's not standing for liberals. That's literally standing in
the way of liberals. That is anti-democratic.
That is against your values, your state of values. standing up
and saying there's nothing wrong with him doing that. That is
wrong. Like you, the example you just gave because when he spurs,
he doesn't think. Okay, this is what you should always know.
When he spurs and talks a mile a minute and does his little straw
man voice, he's not really thinking. He is just spamming out
as much as he can to like it's it's probably like gish galloping.
I don't really know the logical fallacies all that well, but
it's probably gish galloping. Okay, so he just says little things
and Pisco picks it up. He's like, "Yeah, wait, but I I actually
have a like I have a moral reason to be against the Hunter Biden
pardon. Why would I not say that? That's not that's not failing
to stand up for liberal politics. >> Biden, you have
if you want to do content with like the Vanguard other people,
that's fine. But you can't. >> So he's just he's just going
to start if you want to do content with Vanguard and other people.
You just can't Why? Pisco is trying to make a point that you
just said that he you maligned the position that Joe Biden shouldn't
have pardoned his son. That is a good position. That is the position
Pisco has. That is the position he will defend. Right? You can't
just do that voice and then move on as if you didn't do something
there. That is you actually criticizing that position, right?
>> Can't be surprised when there's a huge I roll in a sire
like, "Oh, oh, it's these guys who are making the
>> I'm actually I'm going to go back again and listen to
his point." Okay. From every single other political partisan,
okay, just somebody to that can actually just stand on business
for like liberal >> Well, you have Hunter Biden. You have
Hunter Biden. If you're if you want to do content with like the
Vanguard other people, that's fine. But you can't be surprised
when >> So if you want to He's basically arguing that if
you do content with the Vanguard, you can't be surprised. That
is just I'm going to guilt by association with you. Association
you and you have to accept it. You just have to accept it. I
don't have to provide proof. I'm just going to say optically
if you do Vanguard with people who are left-leaning, people who
seem like socialists or communists, I get to lie about you. Them's
the brakes, buddy. That's online politics. Them's the brakes.
I get to lie about you. There's a huge eye roll in a side was
like, "Oh, oh, it's these guys who are making the jokes about
Buddha judge." Like one of the liberals out there doing more
like podcast work than anybody else. Okay, >> You can't
talk. >> By the way, you'll notice this uh in a lot of
his chat now. There's a lot of DJs who come in and are very mad
about me or Quean. Yeah, we'll watch for him. We'll watch for
him. Apparently, this is our line now, guys. This is our new
line. New moral prescription just came in. Actually
making gay jokes about Pete Buddha Judge is wrong. Morally wrong.
And not just in a homophobic way, but on the dimension of liberal
politician. You can't make gay jokes about liberal politicians,
guys. That's the moral that's our moral prescription now. Okay.
Do we think that that's going to last very long? Do we think
that, hey, Destiny's making moral prescriptions on how edgy people
should be or what kind of jokes they should make about people?
Hey, racism is bad. Homophobia is bad. Right? Destiny would never
do a racist or homophobic joke. He would never do it. >> Talk
about jokes, dude. I know you ain't talking about jokes. I know
that your act ain't talking about jokes. I know that you're not
saying, "Oh, roll eyes because they made bad jokes and jokes
that people disagree with." I know that you make bad jokes. Wait,
wait, what do you mean when I say make bad jokes? jokes that
people find that are
marginal in terms of whether or not you know they're in good
taste, >> problematic jokes, >> whether or not they're
you know >> issue with jokes about Pete Buddhajess is that
they're in bad taste. >> Yeah. What What is your critique
about
>> This turns out It turns out that given Desi's like total
totally erratic nature over the past let's say 6 months, it's
actually really easy to just ask him this. Yeah. What what's
your position on that? And he basically he'll basically fall
apart, right? He'll basically totally fall apart. >> If
you want to make jokes about people getting in the ass, make
up about Lindsy Graham, not about >> Yeah. So, it's not
homophobia. Homophobia is not bad. It's that you're making the
in the joke about about Pete Buddha Judge. I don't like when
you make Okay. If you're doing political stuff, so just right
there, not about homophobia, just don't make the homophobic joke
about a liberal. Apparently
that's the line
Buddha. >> So now so now you care about Oh wait. So it's
not the heteronormative. So because I was in tongue and cheek
saying het heteronormative heteronormative and it was like oh
my god soy soy pe
being attacked. I'm jokes about it's not about >> dude.
As long as you're destiny destiny be like as long as you're that
targets Republican kids. Okay. AOK. Okay in my book. Okay.
As long as your jokes target Republican kids, you're fine by
me,
>> It's not the fact that it's the fact that it's about
our candidates. I mean, you generally probably shouldn't make
homophobic or whatever, but it's about the fact that it's more
>> What was that? What was the mumble debate thing? >> It's
the fact that it's about our candidates. I mean, you generally
probably should make homop whatever, but it's about the fact
>> I mean, you should It's more about the fact they're
tagging our candidates. >> Okay. They don't like Pete Buddha
Jets. Guess what? If I you know, I hate Federman. You would you
say like if I'm pressing Baba Federman that like I'm bad faith.
I'm just attacking our candidates.
I know you see people differently than Federman, but that's just
because that's your view. >> No, is not fair. Okay. >> Oh,
so yeah. Basically, the way to beat Destiny in any debate now
is say, why do you think this? What is your prescription here?
What is your position? Because he's been so erratic for the past
6 months that he can't actually define where any of the lines
are. He is like the least compelling speaker. Like, by the way,
this is what counterpoints prevented, right? This is why counterpoints
is a totally worthless shill who should never be platformed on
any debate panel with any meaningful content on it. Okay, Counterpoints
would be fine to come on, you want to come on and jerk off in
the middle of the train car when when we're talking about drama,
right? I'm fine with that. But if you're actually I I do not
take you seriously in political debate anymore because you covered
for this repeatedly. The fact that this guy's fallen the off
and it's because you're protecting your investment, right? You've
invested in supporting him. I I am so dude this would have happened
in that debate on the wick panel by the way if Pisco had just
been allowed to talk to Destiny this would have happened in that
panel but instead we had to get it here and I don't know what
Destiny actually made off like a bandit here. I have no idea
why he decided to do this to come on and humiliate himself like
this. I think he he might have actually thought he won that debate
on some kind of merit instead of just spuring out being like
just it actually was debate tactics, right? Like it actually
was him like when Pisco misspoke him like screaming a caught
in 4K,
right? Like it wasn't it wasn't on anything tangible at all.
And now when Pisco says, "Could you give me your position on
the thing you just sawed about?" Destiny just totally contradicts
himself in 2 seconds. But Pete Buddhajger I feel like is somebody
that we should be like I feel like every liberal should largely
be like in in decently large agreement with Pete Buddhaj should
largely >> they're not liberals be supportive of the fact
that he's one of the only Dems that seems to be brave enough
to be running around on >> you like him but if you hated
him like Fedman you'd be making brain dead jokes and you wouldn't
give a because you >> Yeah. And if my Yeah. And if I had
if I had a oven in my stomach you could bake bread in my in my
tummy. What? What the you mean? the whole point. >> Amazing.
Amazing stuff from Destiny. Amazing stuff. Just incredible stuff.
If I had an oven in my tummy or sorry, if I had an oven in my
stomach, you could bake bread in my tummy. If I had an oven in
my stomach, you could bake bread in my tummy. Correct me if I'm
wrong. That is something along the lines of humans gonna human.
I I'm pretty sure he just tried to Britney Simon Pisco, right?
It is what it is. You win some, you lose some. Humans going to
human. You know, who do you? >> But if you hated him like
Fedman, you'd be making brain dead jokes and you wouldn't give
a because you think >> I just again, it's because he has
no actual lines. He doesn't have moral prescriptions in any way.
It's basically why you can't take this person seriously as a
political analyst at this point, right? Like I I hate to say
it. I'm not even trying to dance on this guy's grave. I'm just
like I'm kind of I feel like I'm being a little bit sensitive
here,
right? I feel like I'm being sensitive to the fall-off here.
Like, I'm actually not dancing on this grave. It is super embarrassing.
I could laugh at all of this, right? I could spend a lot of time,
but I'm just calmly analyzing it. I'm not doing the thing I normally
do where I like laugh and and mock him the whole time. I'm just
like pointing it out. It's just like an insane falloff that is
almost tragic. Yeah. And if I Yeah. And if I had if I had a oven
in my stomach, you could bake bread in my in my tummy. What What
the do you mean? The whole point is who do you support? I support
Pete Buddhist cuz he's a liberal Democrat. Yeah. Oh, that's the
whole point. >> Yeah. Yeah. >> When Pisco asked you
for like what's your position here? Why do you think that it's
valuable to criticize? Oh, Harat, thank you for the five gifted.
Let's go. That's two more hours on the stream. Awesome. Awesome.
Uh, so when he asks, he's like asking for his position, right?
He's asking, "Hey, what do you what do you think the line is
here on jokes?" I know you're not talking about jokes. You got
some really offensive jokes. What's the line here? And there
there really isn't a line. What is this clip? Hold on. And while
we're taking a quick break here, what is this clip? Oh my god,
the sometimes the thing I try to copy paste out of the thing
I actually have up during stream is a pretty bad widget for it.
Give me a second. What? What it is? What it is? >> Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. >> But you know what I mean. >> If my
grandmother had wheels, she would have been a bike. You know,
you know. >> Yes. Yes.
Uh, thank you very much for the five gifted hers. I really appreciate
it. Two more hours on the stream and and that means we're going
to finish all of this. We might even get to some of the Piscolafi
stuff. That'd be very good. Yes, Desty just said, "Yeah, my grandma
had wheels. Should be a bike." Yeah, I don't have a line on this.
It's just I like these people. So, anybody who doesn't support
the things I like is bad, actually. You don't support what I
like, you're bad, actually. And I don't have morals or a principle
here. There's nothing grounded. I just think if you like what
I don't like, you are bad. And if you don't support the people
I like, you are bad. Wow. Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy. Okay.
Uh,
I added the time. I started the timer. I need to reset the meters
here and then we're going to continue on with the content. What
the [__] It's not that. I swear to God, I just heard
birds
outside of my place. That's [__] crazy. That can't
be true. That can't be real.
Hold on. Resetting these timers.
No, it's like what the hell? No, it's not the time for birds.
There's no birds going on. Okay, >> but they hate people
who just because he's a liberal Democrat. That's That's my point.
Sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Hold. He's sping. He's sping. As
he as the wheels come off, he spurs more and more. He totally
spurked out the the bed breaking tummy thing. Bed breaking bread
baking tummy thing. Jesus.
I think I think Dan has cursed me. Okay. Dan has cursed me with
50% of his misspeaks until he starts coming on the stream again.
I just get I I'm cursed. He has to come back on the stream. I'm
I'm 50% of his misspeaks now. It's so up.
But yes, the it's spuring during the uh that bread baking comment.
It's spuring now. And then he says, "Oh, I'm sorry. I didn't
mean to spur like that." Very
>> It's f It's insane. And like, yeah, you have a they're
far >> 37y old man by the way. 37 38 37 38 >> far
left more to the left and they have strong critiques for centrists,
but >> they hate centrist. They hate Democrats. >> But
Federman is also the candidate. Federman is a Democratic candidate.
Federman is a Democratic incumbent in a >> general. I would
support Federman.
>> Wait, wait. I I would too. I would too. But that guy
is in my metaphoric bullseye. I don't want to be Global Entry
canceled. He's in my bullseye. And I'm going to talk about Fetterman
and talk about the Lake Riley act. >> Don't want to don't
want to lose my I want my fast pass. Okay. Metaphorical. Metaphorical.
I'm going to be talking about um all his like embarrassing moments
and being incredibly brutal through the primary cuz that's what
the primary process is about. Like if if there's some cringe
candidate that I perceive as Oh, I just hold on hold on. I uh
I like what Pisco is saying here, but I just realized there's
a whole reason why you have to stand on like your morals for
a lot of these things, too. I believe what led to a lot of Democrats
supporting the trans the trans youth medicine thing. I think
what what led to that was party loyalty. I think it was we're
kind of crushing and pulling right now. This is something that
the progressives want and it's actually party loyalty is going
to make us stick to this thing. It's like our party identity
is to be progressive right now. That's getting us votes. We're
going to keep doing it. We're going to keep doing it. And a lot
of people probably had concerns and didn't stand up with their
concerns in the moment, right? And now Democrats are losing elections
8 years after a lot of that stuff was big in the news and was
like really at its height, right? We'll say what 5 to 8 years
later, Democrats are losing elections because those people didn't
take stands morally, right? You should just you argue your morals,
especially as a political commentator. And then from from there,
it's like whatever, right? Or just empathy for them. Yeah, Porter.
But I'm saying so yeah, it could be party loyalty or empathy.
But I don't I think a lot of people would have had concerns with
the youth medicine, right? The trans youth medicine that they
would have kept to themselves because they didn't want to be
considered a bigot, right? Uh trans youth medicine, Kingler.
So, I'd say one of the biggest social issues that Democrats are
still getting cudgled with, it's being used as a cudel against
them, is the trans youth medicine positions. A lot of them took
during the 2018 to 2023 era, let's say, right? That's absolutely
a cudel against them still. They get beat over the head with
it every election. Oh, these people want to trans your kids.
They want to trans your kids. They want to trans your kids. And
I think a lot of people would have absolutely had a moral concern
about that that they would have failed to stand up for, right?
and it's being used against them. If Pisco comes out and says,
"Yeah, I don't Oh, yeah. I I uh I don't support the or if he
came out and supported the P the pardon of Biden's son. God damn
it, Dan. God damn it." Okay. If he'd supported that pardon, then
10 years from now, that's still a big political issue and he's
like actually getting just beaten down with it, right? That would
be a huge issue for him. Same thing with the Iraq war. A bunch
of people who supported the Iraq war, that became a totally untenable
position. That's possibly like a big reason that Donald Trump
won the 2016 primary. People were at the absolute height of anti-interventionism,
right? With with regards to populism, like we shouldn't be in
the Middle East. We shouldn't be in the Middle East. And Trump
came out on stage and went, "Look, all these guys supported the
Iraq war. I didn't support it. They all supported the Iraq war.
You got to you got to tell the truth. You got to stand on your
on on business." Because again, he's trying to form like this
this well-grounded moral platform, right? He he he says, "These
are the morals I have. This is how it goes into action." and
he has to argue from that place, right? And any any argument
that he should ignore the Biden pardon would be against his morals.
So if if it's against his morals and he's going to get destroyed
with it later, then why wouldn't he stand up business now? Sorry,
I'm just I'm finding examples. I'm thinking of examples as we
go for the same thing. In my bullseye and I'm going to talk about
Federman and talk about the Lake Riley act. I'm going to be talking
about um all his like embarrassing moments and being incredibly
brutal >> through the primary cuz that's what the primary
process is about. Like if if there's some candidate that I perceive
as cringe, I'm going to talk. >> But you're not wanting
you don't hate Federman because he's a liberal and you want to
replace with a socialist. You think he's a Democrat. They hate
Pete Buddha Judge because Pete Buddha Judge represents a lot
of things.
But they support Tim Walls. They think Tim Walls is based. That's
not a socialist. Tim Walls is like borderline for them. They
like Tim Walls. They like AOC even though they that they had
the >> I like this is more like the conspiracy left, right?
I feel like the reason like socialist types hate Pete Buddha
Judge is cuz they're like he's a CIA plant. He's a CIA plant.
The CIA like socialism in a bunch of countries, we hate him because
he's a CIA plant. I think that's like why they actually hate
Pete Buddha Judge. Like if you get down to it, if you ask those
guys, I feel like a lot of it would be the jokes about the CIA,
right? Am I crazy? I don't think I'm crazy on this. I'm not like
a lefty in the same way, but I think a lot of them would believe
that is >> disagreement there about the whatever funding.
But guess what? AOC made that vote before AOC did that vote years
ago. And guess what? They still like her. They'll still live
over her. That's what we when you were soing out, I couldn't
believe it. Right. Like when we were making the empirical point
that yeah, this one thing that AOC said, it's not going to really
change the lefty's disposition to them in over the long run.
We're making an empirical point that nothing ever happens. That
was just another example of us sweeping us sweeping us sweeping
and saying it doesn't matter. Totally misconstruing it. But but
the reality is these people, they'll critique their family member
if they're running for election. They're a purist to the core.
But at the end of the day, >> be clear, they absolutely
will not critique their socialist candidates. Absolutely not.
No way. In hell, they love their social
what? They literally hold on. This is Destiny stepping on his
own toes, right? Isn't his point that like even when Bernie and
AOC are like 99% in line with them and they step out of line
on Israel and all the socialists like on them? Isn't that his
point? Yeah, I thought they I thought they like destroyed those
people. Isn't that He's just making the totally opposite position
right now.
>> See, I thought that your whole point was that she was
not >> consider I know that you don't believe me when I
say this. Okay, talk to whoever in your life does socialism.
>> Wait, what are Hassan's positions on this? What has
Hassan said? Isn't this all about Hassan in the beginning? Like
Hassan is a Marxist Leninist. Wouldn't Marxist Leninists critique
this, right? And then we could go to Hassan and Straighter who
you've demonstrated apparently are Marxist Leninists.
>> Socialists do not consider AOC socialist. Okay. Nobody
that is like on theory and all these people, they will not consider
AOC. >> You think they consider Tim Walls socialist and
they they like no. >> Yeah. And they like Tim Walls. >> Maybe.
Maybe. >> And they like Tim Walls. >> I don't know
what their position is on on on walls. I Listen, if you want
to if you want to do what you want to do, I mean, like obviously
you can do what you want to do, but it's just like it's just
it's just another it's another episode. It's another another
liberal podcast. It's not like, oh, let's go talk to the guys
that hate our party just as much as they hate the Republicans
and let's see what we how we can talk to them in a friendly manner.
>> With Josiah steering the ship, with Josiah steering
the ship, he will never ever let it be said on that and let people
forget that the Democrat is preferable to the Republican. That
is his like mantra. Why did he say it like that? Jaziah. Is that
me and pondering politics in doing a fusion dance? Jaziah. Jaziah.
>> Do you really not have faith in Josiah? To make that
point clear, that clear
You really think that? Like I I trust Josiah with that. Josiah
would never let me like like we this entire podcast is premised
on the notion that we would be the kind Now I know econom boy
came out. That's his truth. He wants to be a socialist. That's
power to him. We I believe he's still a liberal. I think it's
compatible on his vision of what uh you know socialism means.
I I do think it's compatible. I don't think there's a contradiction.
But our entire thing was why don't we get a podcast of people
who actually like the Democrats more than Republicans and actually
talk them up. That was our whole mantra. And we're not Yeah.
This I as I said before that is the entire purpose of Live and
Learn. Like the whole reason that Josiah would do a show with
anybody is to promote Democrats. Like he is he is the guy who
most of all he's the guy who got Destiny on this page. Destiny
was not like this. Destiny was like, "No, no, no, no. I should
just be honest all the time. I should like and like if I if I'm
really mad at leftists, I'll take like a couple weeks out of
my time to go [__] with leftists or with Democrats
even if I disagree." Right? And Josiah is the person who's like,
"No, no, no. All of your energy should be on Trump. We we're
we're a we're a heat-seeking missile pointed at Trump. Okay,
we are we are going to get this guy." That's Josiah. That's all
Josiah. Like Republicans suck and Republicans Republicans are
rude and we need to be just as rude back then. We need to give
them the same energy back. That's all Josiah. That's all destiny
aping Josiah's points one to one. >> Now we're like expanding
and trying to talk to people and see our point of view. I'm trying
to get them to be more based about constitutionalism, liberalism.
I'm trying to give them the rundown on law stuff. I'm trying
to but but your audience is trying to me over trying to say that
like I'm like a person that I'm cooked and and it's making it
impossible. And I think that you want that to happen. That's
my like intuition is that you like that. You like to see, you
know, I don't know, sticking the knife in us and watching the
chaos. That's my intuition. You tell me it's wrong. >> Have
you seen any of my coverage of any of you guys prior to this
engagement? >> It was positive. It was positive before
my take on the Hassan Global Entry thing and before what I said
about the Ethan Klein lawsuit, which I want to remind the audience.
>> Oh, I have to go back. Hold on. I have to go back cuz
he's he's discussing. What did Destiny just ask? I missed the
question. I was reading chat. Your audience is trying to me over
trying to say that like I'm >> Yes. Yes. Yes. Your audience
is trying to [__] me over person that I'm cooked.
>> not just the audience, by the way. Just so we're clear.
Des uh Pisco, not just the audience. Destiny. Destiny is trying
to malign you. Destiny is saying you're bad faith. Destiny is
saying you're trying to court Hassan. This is all destiny. Hey,
I can't believe Pisco is so insanely bad faith that he'd asked
me for evidence that Aaron's an ML. Why can't I just call Aaron
an ML with no evidence at all? Not even evidence that I'll state
outright.
Oh, they found a clip and they clipped around the part where
she said she probably doesn't fit the communist label even. Oh,
no. No way. No way. Like it's it's just totally it's totally
crazy how but like historically communists equal ML. ML has always
been the main mode of operation for all socialist/comunist regimes.
Not true. Uh with the social with regards to socialists. Not
true. and it's making it impossible. And I think that >> just
the the well-known communist regimes are well known because they
are the the communist regimes that did like all the massive like
starvation genocides because they tried to have a planned economy,
right? Those are those are the ones that are wellnown. But like
lots of socialist parties were able to run in states, in provinces,
in countries and make meaningful positive >> You want that
to happen. That's my like intuition is that you like that. you
like to see. Oh, it doesn't have to be intuition Pisco. Does
Pisco not know about Destiny literally coming and saying the
exact things he's mad about in his chat? Is Pisco unaware that
Destiny came out and like literally said these exact things about
him? Wow. If I said a clip about working with Vos and Hassan,
my regret is that those two are so unhinged that it's impossible.
Pisco clip chipping/farmming me is actually unreal from two years
ago. From eight months ago. From eight months ago. Destiny. What?
>> You know, I don't know. sticking the knife in us and
>> from after the most recent election from after the election
>> watching the chaos. That's my intuition. You tell me
it's wrong. H >> I don't know how how could he say he can't
say it's wrong. He literally wants his audience doing this.
>> Have you seen any of my coverage of any of you guys
prior to this? >> Oh, this is what Destiny thinks that
like him saying stuff or doing stuff in DG chat goes without
like notice to people. Oh, like the way I talk about you in DG
chat isn't gonna get noticed. The way I suggest like the reason
you're so unhinged is because of your socialist girlfriend. That
that'll go unnoticed. Nobody will notice that. Guys, guys, we're
not noticing that, right?
>> It was positive. It was positive before my take on the
Hassan Global Entry thing and before what I said about the Ethan
Klein lawsuit, which I want to remind the audience, you agreed
with me, except for the my my focus on the Ethan Klein lawsuit
didn't seem to matter. uh the fact that we fundamentally agreed
that the lawsuit was strong, that it was the filing was [__]
unhinged. >> Okay. Wait. So, so you just said that you
feel like I'm doing this out of spite and then I asked you what
happened and then you just gave me two concrete examples. Reasonable
mind would say, "Yo, I maybe you dramatically disagree." >> Uh
I would say the stuff for the past two days that Pisco's talking
about like the bad faith here that is all like Destiny himself,
right? Before that, I would say more Dan going after him a lot
and Destiny not trying to rein that in. But it's not like I went
off for months and months on these particular things. This is
these are things that I disagree with. But I don't I don't think
I developed spite two weeks ago and I have >> Why did you
block me? >> Because of the I don't know how much I try
to jump in all the fact that Aaron is just somehow like crept
back at everything. It is that's just wild to me. But I just
for my own brain and my own sanity, I was like, "Okay, whatever."
Like, you know what? People can do their own and I'll just be
over here doing my own. Crept back in. What did she do? That
was what What is Destiny's problem with Aaron? Could somebody
explain that to me? What could Destiny's problem with Aaron possibly
be? I Okay, so I blocked you because you talked to Aaron. Surely
that has to be that can't be a new position based on his allegations,
right? That has to be a position based on her being an ML, right?
There's no way he would say just based on my allegations and
how she was a participant in, you know, the DM sharing and stuff
that I hate Aaron for this reason. >> Just leaking to Sunday.
Okay. >> Okay. Well,
final prescriptions. I mean, it's it's like what? So,
what is the >> I would So, I wish Pisco and I don't know
Pisco doesn't really have to do this and it it sucks. I wish
he would just say like, "Hey, um I I think you're not just lying
about me. I think you're also lying about Aaron. I think you're
like lying about her because you dislike her and it's like entirely
spite-based." >> The ethical Let's grant your semantics
on socialism. Let's grant everything and let's just say what
what do you think is ethical for us to do? >> This is what
I would want to see at the end of the day. Okay. If you think
that you can cast a net that will encompass some socialists because
you're pushing some aspects of liberalism so hard, I think that's
fine. Okay. What I would want to see at the end of the day ideally,
what I would want to see at the end of the day ideally is these
guys going back to their chats and their chats screaming at them
being like, "Why the didn't you guys like push harder for how
the Dems are? Why didn't you guys push harder and and get them
to admit that like the Dems are the same as the Republicans?"
That's what I want to see in their chats. Not after they leave
your chat, you know, like not like any like only the liberals
left or the pirates be like, "Oh, like why is this guy such a
>> Is that happening loser?" Like, you >> my community
my my community was mostly DGers. You know, my my community or
or you know, there's so much overlap. >> Oh, now he's got
to get back into Okay,
now you've got a bunch of Queenman and Jtock people in here.
They're they're totally with your mind. If you want to know like
my >> I don't think it was that way before the initial
when you guys did the initial I didn't watch it. I watched the
VOD of that when Hutch was the one who had problems who I guess
you're saying he had problems for no good reason I guess was
the issue or >> why why does Hutch matter here at all.
>> What you know my my or you know there's so much overlap
you want to know like my >> I don't think it was that way
before the initial when you guys did the initial I didn't watch
it. I watched the VOD of that when Hutch was the one who had
problems who I guess you're saying he had problems for no good
reason. I guess
>> nobody made a comment on Hutch. Why is Destiny again
trying to drive that wedge for no reason? Why would that be relevant
to this conversation right now? He's just like you almost wonder.
It's just so natural. You almost wonder if like this is a plan
or if he like is kind of naturally duplicitous like this that
he's like just going to naturally do this. It's very weird, right?
Like why would Hutch be relevant to what you're saying right
now? Well, I guess you like unless you're just saying Hutch had
like nothing relevant to say unless Hutch was like a like a total
moral. Would you say Hutch is like should Hutch be in your opinion,
Pisco? It's like Pisco said nothing about Hutch. Why are you
bringing Hutch up? That last part was unhinged and he didn't
say that and I was just sort of being hyperbolic. Okay, it's
a joke. We don't like it, but we don't like violence here. >> Was
the issue or >> I I think that he had problems with the
optics like a lot of other people did and I can understand why
some people that he might feel that way. I don't think that it's
based in some I I think it's based in kind of like how it felt,
but I don't think it's based on an objective like look at what
occurred if that's my my take on it. And I think that we I I
wasn't trying to gaslight him. I I [__] like Hutch
a lot. You know, we I Hutch is my boy. I'm I'm not trying to
betray Hutch. I would never try to throw him under the bus like
like >> uh this is by the way um just there's somebody
in chat there saying how about you both say I'm sorry at the
same time. Pisco objectively
did nothing wrong here. I'm sorry. He's been lied about. He's
been maligned. He's getting gaslit that there's nothing Destiny
did to do it. He's getting totally gaslit. He has every right
to be annoyed and upset. And Destiny is so is just such a for
not admitting the he does. It's so gross. Like, it's actually
so gross. If Destiny wanted to say, "I apologize for saying these
things about you. I I apologize." Destiny knows exactly when
he goes to his chat and he complains about stuff, right? He complains
about another creator, he understands how how
zealous his audience is. He knows exactly what he's doing. He
knows when he goes and reads messages from my Discord that he
gets people to go and brigade my Discord, right? He knows that.
He knows that's the way it works.
It's it's just not that way. Like offline, we have a very amicable
relationship. Um, so yeah, it just it wasn't that at all. and
my community over like is highly critical unlike you. I don't
delete all the criticism of me in my own discord and even in
my own Reddit now now that I have a Reddit like I don't delete
that. People talk mad and so it's just not the case that like
my community is becoming
>> unlike you.
I'm not even sure I would have brought that up. That was crazy.
>> Never mind. Sorry. Go ahead. >> Yeah, my community
is not becoming ML. It's not be >> Destiny does go delete
all like critical opinion of him on his subreddit. He absolutely
does. >> I mean like mass communists and the kind of fears
that you're raising is is like not true. >> Change peace.
>> I've changed how
>> uh Mantis you're saying the thing that people want said,
right? Mantis is just going to be Mantis is the Connor. She's
far less effective at drawing attention. >> how have I
changed? >> No, you're a community. Relax. I said your
community. >> Yeah, but you were talking. Do you know what
Mantis? Do you know what >> he's open about deleting them?
Then why did he just laugh at Pisco as if Pisco was saying something
insane there in Zane? When Pisco said that, why did Destiny laugh
and sort of imply that he was wrong for saying it? That's obvious.
It's obvious why you go, "Oh, I don't know why you'd say that."
Well, I don't know why you'd say that. If he's open about doing
it, I just don't understand why he would have that response.
But if you if you can give me a reason, he'd have that response
because apparently he's just open about doing it. So, he wouldn't
really get annoyed or think it was dumb for Pisco to say that,
right? He would just go, "Yeah, I do." I'm I'm actually waiting
to hit play until Enzane responds or until I ban him from the
chat maybe. I don't know because in his brain Pisco is being
red lines from the cabal. Oh well, I guess uh I guess technically
every person on January 6 should be let go, right? Sorry. Okay,
sure, sure, sure. I'm just holding people to consistent ideologies
or consistent ideas when they come here, right? The idea that
like you're having a delusion and so we have to actually entertain
that delusion and not hold you responsible for your speech would
be crazy, but it's fine. You did. You tweet at me. I No. >> I
know what I did though. That's why I'm here. And did you get
my response? >> No, I didn't get a response. >> Well,
you should look at your tweet, shouldn't you? Cuz >> Hold
on. >> Relax. I said your community. >> Yeah, but
you were talking [__] You >> I said your community,
not you. Your community, bro. I think uh
we're starting to There are people there who are like lefty,
by the way. Like Brazilian lad, I think is pretty lefty here
in in this chat right now. There would be people who would be
lefty in his chat who would like him because he was like reasonable.
But guess what? Those people are going to become Pisco fans.
That's what they're going to do. >> Mantis, do you know
what you did? You tweet at me. I know it now. >> I know
what I did. That's why I'm here. And did you get my response?
>> No, I didn't get a response. >> Well, you should
look at your tweet, shouldn't you? Cuz I responded. >> I
get so many ads and like but but it's just that's that's the
kind of it's everywhere and and and I do resent it. And so, yeah,
when I started that debate, I was angry as, but you know, it's
because of I feel like it's been a non-stop attack. You know,
uh, Dan is talking to Ethan Klein. Ethan Klein is adding me saying,
"I'm not a real lawyer." They're saying, "I'm I'm no different
than Mike from PA." They're saying, "I don't know about the law."
They're saying, "Uh, so this has been a campaign by at least
by Dan." >> Wait, really? Yeah. Absolutely. That happened.
Absolutely that happened. I talked about it earlier. Absolutely.
And Destiny in his chat as of like a day ago was actually was
totally on board with this, right? As of September 29th, so two
days ago, right? He went off on Ethan for like a week over the
lawsuit thing. He's totally selling that same sauce. He's selling
the exact snake oil Dan is on this topic, right? Exact same thing.
Insultment specifically to smear me to specifically attack me.
You you watch him whenever you know there's any controversy involving
me. You guys talked about me for like three or four weeks straight
talking about my takes there. And so there's a direct causal
role.
JC losing all sense of time. What? Hold on. This is This is two
days ago right here. This is literally two days ago. Oh, did
I say September? Oh, I meant July. Whoops.
Whoops. My bad. My bad.
Yeah, that's misspeaking. That's the That's Dan cursing me again.
Every misspeak I have is because Dan has cursed me. Okay, Dan
has cursed me and until him and I are friends again, I will never
be able to uh I will never be able to live without misspeaking.
It's >> How much I was covering the Ethan Klein and Hassan
story based on the unhinged response of of someone who lies about
me mischaracterizes me. And I think that you feed into it and
you play into it and I think that you have a causal role as well.
I think your audience does too. I feel I feel like you should
watch and I understand the temptation to especially when you
>> Why does he have to watch? This is 11 hours ago. This
is two days ago. This is you explicitly feeding into this then
ran the most insane defense for Asan I've ever seen in the last
day on Collins. The last day on Collins. Like this is we don't
have to look at what Dan says. We just look at what Destiny says.
Why Why wouldn't we hold Destiny responsible for the things he
says in his chat with the most? By the way, all of the people
who will take Destiny's Q and go to other YouTube chats that
will go to their Discord, all of these people are in DGG chat,
right? This is where the most aggressive, most zealous fans would
be and that's where he talks about >> You got um like actual
subhuman like Queen feeding you lines and in chat or in Discord.
You should watch some of the videos sometimes like >> Oh,
oh my god. Sorry. I don't even want to soy out anymore. Um listen,
listen. The cabal. The cabal has made their way into Pisco's
mind apparently.
Let's go. Let's go.
H like he has to do this on this just insane association. By
the way, all of the DMs I have to Pisco on like this account
are
on this account are which he's responded to none of by the way.
I think it's like oh I think it was like something irrelevant
to this conversation. And then two days ago I sent him the Aaron
clip and then I said recently like, "Hey, I'm sorry that Desi
is trying to like use me to malign you somehow to people." That
that kind of sucks, dude. He's never even responded to me. >> Dan
is unhinged. Dan does have an unhinged participation in a lot
of generally when Dan is like going in on >> Wait, why
would Destiny just throw Wait, is it unhinged to say the things
that to say that Pisco like doesn't know that he's like swinging
about the Ethan lawsuit or that he's defending Hassan? Is that
unhinged? Is that unhinged now? That's apparently unhinged. Wow.
Wow. And I understand the temptation to especially when you've
got um like actual subhuman like Queenman feeding you lines and
in chat or in Discord. You should watch some of the videos sometimes.
Like Dan is unhinged. Dan does have an unhinged participation.
>> Wait, what? What?
I don't think How much have we talked about Dan talking about
Pisco? That's all that's all Pisco, right? Pisco sees that on
his own. A lot of this generally when Dan is like going in on
people I'm usually telling Dan most of the time like bro this
is like kind of unhinged or this is kind of I think when you
give a take I'll say it's a take when you give a good take I'll
say you give a good take but yeah there's obviously I disagreed
with on your hyperfixation on um on the um on on the lawsuit
but also like you can't >> hyperfixation
hyperfixation
right he's trying to walk this line where he can make these accusations
without being held responsible for them he won't just say it
with his chest because he's spineless. He's totally and completely
spineless.
Right. You're I made a couple comments on your total mis on your
total fixation on the Ethan lawsuit, I guess. Right.
Right. We can all see he's he's doing the thing where he speaks
fast
is a six pest and he ruined me. So, I call into streams knowing
I'll get more. >> We don't have to talk about that. I'm
starting to see overlaps between >> like Conor. I don't
I don't want to use Mantis and Tom Fuller's reputation anymore.
I'm starting to see that like uh that feels pretty frustrating
when people try to attack me with my relationship. So, I'm I'm
gonna probably cut back on that a decent amount. You just want
to call Mantis for the things she says. That's totally fine.
But, uh I I feel like people coming in here and just trying to
use like my relationship to attack me relationship to attack
me or using me to like attack Cherry is just stupid. Just attack
the things each of us say independently. Don't be losers. Don't
be losers. Yeah, there's obviously I disagreed with on your hyperfixation
on um on the um on on the lawsuit, but also like you can't pretend
that you don't also feed into it too. Like when Hassan comes
out,
>> so yeah, the hyper hyperfixation >> and says like
okay guys, I lied about my whole timeline and then your next
stream is like 100%.
>> That's not the that's not the hyperfixation. Wait, wasn't
it hyperfixation? But also like you can't pretend that you don't
compete into it too. Like when Hassan comes out and says like,
"Okay guys, I lied about my whole timeline." And then your next
stream is like 100% vindication completely.
>> But you know why that is? But but it's not because he
because of the lie there cuz it has to do with the timing of
the global gentrification. So and where you agree with me. That's
that's what's so crazy. Like we disagree on the interpretation
and no one can say it's bad faith because I'm I'm I'm in my own
discord having these long legal discussions with members of my
own >> Peace. Peace. Uh,
she's doing the Connor thing. Should have disconnected her >> as
a as a viewer. As a just a viewer, okay, so separate from like
all the spite driven like Dan stuff and all that, but just as
a viewer of all, >> they just by the way, how do you feel
if you're Dan and and you like help Destiny all the time and
Destiny's move to like say why he's not unhinged towards Pisco
is just to go, "Hey, Dan's insane. Dan sucks, dude. I don't I
don't anything Dan does. I totally push back against Dan. Dan's
the worst, man."
Mantis, when you Yeah, Mantis is like, "Yeah, yeah, Dan. Dan
is the West. Dan is the West. We We hate Dan. We hate Dan." Dude,
why is it that me and Queen are nicer to Dan than they are? What's
going on here? >> Communities, all of both of yours, Destiny
and Pisco. Like, Pisco, you have to understand how it came across
as a viewer of yours where all of a sudden you've done you've
defended Hassan on the plane thing like and you really went pretty
hard and still. Yeah. See, look. Yeah. Your vindication lap.
Oh, it's still my position.
>> We got apes from real glo. You were asking for it from
Brazilian lad. Alpha kilo. Destiny sees enemies everywhere. Harvey
Marvy 3348. Destiny thinks of Queen when he goes to sleep. Holy
[__] Uh, he's doing the Hassan thing. Ethan, there's
only so much I can do. He is. Oh, Chappie D. Yes, Chappie D is
here right now. I think a lot of the people in his chat at this
exact moment in time, I'm looking at people. They are uh they're
my chatters, but they're not there most of the time. I don't
believe we all started watching this debate cuz obviously it's
Pisco versus Destiny last night, right? I don't think I typed
in chat at all. >> okay, I know. Just listen then. >> I'm
just laughing that a bunch of people are making fun of him and
then a bunch of people are like juicealkers are here. Like okay.
Okay. >> He went after Ethan for the lawsuit thing. You
kind of like you don't want to call it this, but there was a
little semi ganging up on Herwood like the Vanguard. then you
kind of do. >> Yeah. So, so this is something this is another
reason you don't want uh Connor or any other similarly
mentally impaired [__] in a discussion where Destiny
is being criticized because they will say now Mantis is going
to come say all the stupid things that Destiny knows he can't
say directly because he can't defend them. So Mantis is here
to say all the stupid things that Destiny can't, right? That
he wants to that he believes that he supported in his chat and
stuff. So Mantis can come in and say, "Oh, here's all the things
wrong with you." Disconnect her. Make Destiny make his own assertions.
>> Disconnect her. She's worthless. She has no purpose.
Get her out. Well, she sorry. She has a malicious purpose actually
right now. >> Talk about Dem sucking more than liberals
or moderates would, I think. And I think you're very clear that
you're slightly you're willing to say that. You just said it
in this call that you you do think that Dem suck right now. You
are you do think >> the leadership the way the leadership
>> no one Yeah. But the thing you don't understand is I
most reasonable people don't actually think you're a socialist
or don't actually think that you're like anti-democratic or anti-dem.
It just helps all of this like helps with that. >> All
of this helps Queen and Jtock and they make fun of me. This all
of this helps Queman and Jtock apparently
you Pisc when you stand up for your morals when you say hey it's
up that you misrepresent me that actually helps Queman and Jtock
and that's maybe the worst isn't that really the worst thing
that could possibly happen right when you stand up for your morals
it's just really disgusting how Queman and Jtock can make content
out of that is gross let Destiny lie about you let us lie about
what you and your community are driving at and and just think
about how it's really important that you don't give JC or queening
content cuz that's really where we're coming from. You can't
help these people. They're the worst. Wow.
So so amazing. >> Like optics narrative. It just all looks
bad in sequential order. It just does. And even I've been annoyed
by it. >> It looks bad. Looks bad.
Some people help it look bad, don't they? I think when when people
don't take it the full context of what I'm saying like like another
example of it was when we were going over the reeducation camps
and it was so clear what I was doing there. It was so clear that
what I was dealing with was someone saying explicitly this says
that he's in favor of reeducation camps. When it says the leftovers
clip says that he's in favor of reeducation camps. Obviously
it does not. Destiny's argument is let me mind readad Hassan.
Nobody else has a better argument, right? Nobody else has like
uh any art. It's just hey basically from some other clips by
the way probably probably more than two years old right apparently
you can argue that Hassan's an ML now the people who I know who
actually like argue the stuff learn learn about it they don't
think Hassan's an ML right but okay we have to read the ML beliefs
into him we have to read a want for violence into him to say
that oh obviously he would suppress capitalism or any capitalist
thought or any liberal thought I guess any democratic thought
with like violence outright violence And you have to just trust
our mind readad of him. We don't we don't even though this clip
doesn't show anything it says it shows. Trust our mind readad
of him. >> The direct opposite when I'm literally saying
give me the best evidence. Show me where he's saying Marx is
Leninist where where it is like cuz it could be the case that
other things inform this conclusion. Yes. Exactly. Oh my god.
Pisco it's okay. I just realized I just realized. Hold on. I
just got how Destiny thinks that Queman and I are feeding Pisco
lines. It's because,
okay, it is actually because we read the thread first and we
made the natural logical conclusions that you would come to if
you weren't biased against any party and read that thread, right?
It's that's what it what it is. We went through and we read it
and we're like, "Oh, obviously this is the case, right? This
clip doesn't even close come close to proving this." And Pisc
went through and was like, "Oh, yeah. here's how you would read
it. And Desi went through and went like, "Oh my god, these people
are these people are just like not gonna mind readad in the worst
intent possible onto Hassan. How how could they live with that?
How could they do it?" And again, just to be clear, the claim
of the clip is that the leftovers clip proves it conclusively.
It's not that Hassan is is this thing or is not this thing. It's
that the clip proves it. It doesn't. Notwithstanding the fact
that I'm making specific carveouts and saying I'm only talking
about the fork. Can we agree this doesn't literally say this?
Notwithstanding that fact, notwithstanding the fact the moment
that people pro provided clips to me that say that where he says
I'm a Marcus Lennus, I said yes, Marcus Lenn is happy to grant
it. When I specifically asked for it, I have hundred long comment
threads saying, you know, look at him, he's a tanky. And you
too, Mantis, you said that as well based on that. >> Can
I can I tell you why after that conversation in particular, I
was like, oh, holy [__] And you you can say it's
stupid if you want to say it's stupid, but like because those
of us who have >> Oh,
see this is how you know unfortunately for Pisco or sorry, unfortunately
for Destiny and Mantis, Pisco has a weapon in his back pocket.
Okay, somebody who cares about him and isn't particularly invested
in the furtherance of any economic goal by being associated in
this space. Okay, that's Joe. And Joe says, "What we can all
tell should be the answer here. You shouldn't even bother engaging
with this. You don't need to defend your honor. You're literally
You're correct." And they don't actually care about what the
truth is,
right? This is just true. This is just true. Like, they are not
invested in what the truth is. You all you have to do is watch
that Wick debate. That Wick debate was a hatchet job on Pisco.
That there was no chance for any real conversation to go on there
and they'll all gaslight him and say, "It's your fault, Pisco."
And it was not Pisco's fault. Pisco was angry, but Pisco is ready
to argue the points. Right. Pisco
Pisco's unironically I'm going to do it. Okay, I'm going to do
it. I'm going to make a fantasy reference right now. Pisco is
Ned Stark except we're all we're everybody else in King's Landing.
Okay, and we can make sure that Ned Stark doesn't get beheaded
by Joffrey and Cersei. Okay, that's Destiny and not Mantis in
this point. We'll call it Aerite. Okay, Pisco, we're going to
make sure Pisco doesn't get beheaded because Pisco is actually
sitting here and he's like, I'm right on the points. I'm right
on everything and I am honorable
and that's how it is. And they basically showed up in a back
alley with like shs for this guy. Shs that speak at 190 words
per minute and have a very high pitch sound to them. Well, actually
you you have to see you're trying to do this actually Marxist
Len. You don't have any any reason to ask me for a clip and for
to prove that
right. It's [__] up, man. It's [__] up.
But I'm I'm happy that he's got somebody who can like ground
him here. That's uh that's good. That's off. That's not really
like trying to get any clout from these people that is kind of
doing their own thing. Got their own stuff going. >> I've
watched a ton of Hassan's
>> Wait, did I up the seriously didn't want to beheaded
Ned Stark though? Nah. True. That's true. But also, that's probably
true for at least Herodite. She probably goes, "No, Stephen,
you don't understand. If you behead Ned Stark, that'll make you
look really bad to everybody and and we'll have a hard time maintaining
power later. I just need you to know that the human being thing
to do is not to behead Ned Stark." And then Destiny beheads Ned
Stark. Okay, that's actually that fits them perfectly.
>> We like you were taking his words literally like, "Oh,
he didn't literally say this. He didn't literally say that."
It it just comes across super when you can't take someone in
their >> Well, I maybe I'm a little >> devious in
their actions and devious and puts masks on and takes them off.
We already had this conversation and you you kind of agreed with
me that he does do that. So, if you're capable of understanding
that he does do this thing, but then when you get into a conversation
with someone who's providing you with all the best evidence they
can because he's a sneaky and then you say, "Oh, well, >> but
dude, that I don't know why Mantis I don't he shouldn't engage
with Mantis." Uh the the thing about engaging with these other
people is they have no shame. I we identified this in my community
a long time ago, right? They have no shame. They have no principles.
All their only their only allegiance is to destiny. That is how
they get all of their morality. The correct or right thing to
do in any situation is to defend destiny. That's how all of these
people are. And when you when you prove them wrong, they feel
no shame. Nothing changes. They have nothing guiding them except
the sound of Destiny's voice. So, like there's no reason to argue
with them because even if you prove them completely wrong, nothing
will happen, right? There's a solid reason for Pisco to engage
with Destiny here. He is making Destiny look horrible. There's
no solid reason for Pisco to engage with Mantis. Mantis doesn't
care. Mantis will say whatever she can to make Pisco look worse
and help Destiny in this situation. And even if she fails entirely,
she's just going to show up tomorrow and do the same thing. >> He's
not really saying this thing. I think you're kind of being a
little obuse. No, but I'm but I'm I'm just trying to understand
and clarify the term because I am a little bit like I am on this
linearization kick because I do think it's helpful to how it
reflects how I think and that's just how I approach these issues
because that's who I am. Um and but but I have no problem acknowledging
as I've often done that there's a broader context here. But even
just put that aside, man. Like this whole thing just leaves a
bad taste in my mouth and and so many assumptions. I've never
seen like like I'm not saying other people don't get it but um
yeah and I'm not trying to like play victim just try to >> Testy
thinks Pisco could be corrupted by a message from Queenman. He
doesn't think much of you actually that's a good point. Apparently
what who's the real anti-semite? Okayman sends one message and
Pisco's corrupted immediately.
Do people have mind control powers? >> I got to get you
like in my head paint you a picture like why I'm going into that
conversation. Um, and I think it's reasonable. I think that there's
lies being told. I think that there's malice. And um, I think
it's unfortunate. And, and now the prescription is like I don't
even know what it is. >> Well, hold on. I'm Okay, I'm curious.
Okay, hold on. Before I go to bed, what >> dude? The h
I just feel like hearing the voice, the slimy like uh I And this
is, by the way, this is totally bias. Okay, this is totally bias.
So, it's not a logical point. It's not something I'm seeing a
bunch of evidence for, but when you hear when Pisco is like,
I don't even know what to do now. And he's like, listen, listen
to the the the honey in >> description is like, I don't
even know what it is. >> Hold on. I'm Okay, I'm curious.
Okay, hold on. Before >> Wait, wait, wait. Hold on. I'm
I'm curious. Listen, man. Like, I do you think I want to fight
you? Like, what? Do you really think it's like we want to fight
here or Dude, I am like I just want to puke. I want to puke my
guts out hearing that. It's so gross after how this person like
treats him, after how he lies about him out, how he gets his
community to brigade his, right? He directs it. He absolutely
directs it. He doesn't say, "Go brigade, except for me." But
he does actually go and say like, "Oh, here's all the things
that Pisco is, right? You should be really Pisco." Pisco is totally
bad faith, right? Also, the socialist girlfriend thing. It's
condescending. Removes agency. Yeah, it's it's all like awful,
right? And and then he like comes in. He's like now Pisco's like
obviously frustrated, right? Obviously frustrated. doesn't like
where any of this has gone and he goes, "Oh man, could we fix
this?" That's what I hear. And I understand that that is mostly
based on, man, I I understand that's mostly based on like me
disliking this person thing. They're like they're the one of
the people I've engaged with online, right? So that's how that's
informed. I'm just letting you guys know. Just let me rub your
legs.
I'll fix it later. Pisco, just let me rub your feet your feet
and legs while you write your essays, okay? Will you write your
little legal papers, Pisco? Just let me rub your feet and legs,
okay? I'll fix it later. Don't worry about your reputation. I'll
fix it later. Before I go to bed, what what do you think? Like
what's like your top one or two things you're like, there's no
way you could legitimately believe this
>> Uh going after Aaron as an ML for one thing. Uh saying
Pisco's like obsessed with the Ethan lawsuit would be another
one. What else would there be? Um, there's just the general like
idea that he's hanging out with socialists now and like how like
the weird webbing that goes on. There's his refusal to stand
starkly against Dan and say no no I won't engage with episcoco
slander like it's obviously wrong. There's no like private conversation
that's gone on with Dan that says like hey when you say you're
when you're going to like tell Ethan Klein to cut off a major
opportunity for this guy who was my friend when really the only
thing he did wrong was step away from me when I was accused of
like things that I'm objectively kind of on the hook for. Right.
My argument for non-consensually sharing the picture in the first
place is it took place before Cardi. That's like that's his argument,
right? So like realistically he has no reason to be upset at
all at Pisco. >> I think and he won't slow down down at
all. He won't say, "Hey, that's like my former friend. He did
nothing wrong. I kind of Pisco over. That's what Destiny's thought
should be. I actually totally this guy over. This guy has to
deal with the stigma of being associated with me and he's trying
to make serious political headway. And now he has to deal with
the stigma of having supported me and been a friend of mine,
like a close personal friend of mine. That's how Destiny should
have thought about it, right? But instead, it's like Pisco actually
betrayed me. When he sends people's pictures, videos, when he
records them without consent, when he sends all of this stuff
without consent, he thinks I am the victim for these people stepping
away from me. That is his broad worldview. And so he doesn't
understand why Pisco would expect him to go and say, "Hey, Dan,
maybe chill." Right? Hassan went through the same thing, right?
Yeah. Hassan basically went through the same thing. I've gone
through the same thing. Bro, go look at like any of my that gets
insanely astroturfed, right? Go look at my post on Twitter. I
get like 15 DGs and a bunch of replies on my posts. Like my insanely
astroturfed by DGG. Happens to anybody who breaks away from this
guy
>> Think that there's no way that you could >> Wait,
did you see what Destiny said about Pisco in his latest stream?
He glazed Pisco. Yeah, he glazed Pisco because he lost, right?
He would have glazed Pisco because he lost horribly here. because
he exposed himself as a total like hack. His only option now
is to try to win Pisco back with Honey, right? He tried to he
tried to abuse him into coming back and now the only option is
to try to win him back with Honey, but Joanne already got it,
right? They don't they don't care. They don't care about you.
They don't care about you at all. Destiny knows that he looks
insane and that he can't have a war against Pisco and a war against
Queen and me and a war against Hassan. He can't do all of these
things at the same time, right? So, he's trying to close off
one of these avenues. he's trying to do with Pisco and I don't
think Pisco has any interest in going after him. So, but I just
hope Pisco can see it, right? That he doesn't want like DJ's
having this as like something they can question him over. Pisco
is a Destiny victim. Wait, Pisco's Pisco is just arguing that
all of his comments, if you go look at the response after the
debate, it's totally astroturfed, right? And it's astroturfed
with the exact things Destiny said after the debate. I'm saying
that Destiny's community is being signaled to go after Pisco
in the same way that they would have been signaled to go after
Hassan when Hassan broke away from Destiny. Right? It's going
to be the same thing. It's right here. This is right here.
Loki Coco, are you looking at what I'm looking at? You can go
look up Destiny's logs yourself and go look at all of the lies
he spewed about Pisco here. You just go look them up yourself.
I've read through a bunch of them. It's tough that you're not
following, but
>> many such cases. that specific point when we're talking
about just example from our conversation we're talking about
Marxist Leninism when you must know that I know that Aaron is
a communist you must know that we're oh yes so basically his
whole like the dude the debate is so bad faith the whole time
right oh man this is going to be this is going to be one of when
like the clip of Aaron comes through and Desi goes oh my god
caught in 4K
caught in 8K right like that whole thing like Pisco literally
wins that argument and Destiny totally soys out, totally spurs
the out,
right? Starts screaming and signals that he won it and Pisco's
like, "Oh, there's no good faith engagement to be had here."
Like, I'm I'm totally correct. And then he posts about it and
a whole bunch of people tell him he's wrong on Twitter, right?
Like, you're just going to spur the out instead of having any
actual real engagement here at all. Okay, I guess so. Why should
I be involved? You must know that I know that Aaron is a communist.
You must know that we're like having a conversation >> as
sorry just to prove this out. Destiny knew that Aaron was a communist,
right? Destiny pointed out on his stream today that obviously
Aeron's or maybe even in the Russell search vlogs that Aaron's
entry into the community was as a communist. Nobody really thought
of her. So Kami Aaron was like the thing. Now I talked to Aaron
about this and she said the label doesn't really fit me. We saw
the same thing be said on Adam and Sitch. Maybe she's more comfortable
with the label now, but the she doesn't sherk the label. She
is fine with people using the label because she thinks sherking
the label, saying no, no, no, having to spend every conversation
saying, "No, I'm not actually a communist." is more harmful to
socialism or her personal values than it would be to just say,
"Yeah, call me a communist. It's fine." >> Right?
That's that's what Aaron believes. That's what I believe she
>> Is Nathan a groper or something? I don't know what I'm
talking. But not enough people are talking about this. >> No.
No. Yourself loser in a video game. That person sucks. Don't
talk about Destiny's kid. You're You're just a total loser. Listen,
I Anything you do to try to weaponize someone's kids against
them is going to hurt the kid more than the parent. No matter
how you do it, okay?
So, don't do that in my community. You'll get banned if you do
that. You're lucky. Donated anonymously, right? You will get
banned but from my community if you do that. Off. Okay. I have
no interest in using that person's relationship with their child
against them. I'm never going to have an interest in that. is
gross. Specifically about these nuances and applications. >> You
acknowledge that this this point of intention spawned off from
you demanding in the middle of a debate debate for me to produce
video evidence of the lies. That's a lie. That's a lie. No, no.
I I I said specifically and you can and anyone can just go back
and hear it. You just listen to it. I said, "Tell me the thing
she told you. Tell me the thing it is that is." I I didn't say
specifically bring the clip. >> So Destiny does this thing
where it's like, "Oh, you expect me to have evidence? You expect
me to produce a full video clip of her explaining this opinion?
It's like, no. What gave you like you can literally just tell
me what made you think this? Just tell me what made you think
it other than Well, we can all tell. We can all see it, right?
Other than Destiny basically doing my tweet, right? That's like
Destiny's argument here is, "Hey, actually, um, where's where
is it? Where's the Aaron tweet?" Yes. Actually, uh, you can just
tell from this picture that she's a psychopath because of the
plushies. And I mean, do you really need more information than
this to tell that she's a total psychopath?
Right? That's like that's what we're arguing against here. Just
don't do that. As long as you're not doing this like you can
have whatever reason you want, but it has to be a reason. It
has to be something based in reality. Can't just be oh the vibes.
>> And the reason is because you brought up Aaron there
and you brought up Aaron. >> wait. Tell me the thing you
told her. How was that not asking like Okay, I'm sorry. My bad.
You didn't ask me for a video. You asked me for a a specific
quote. What? Like he's he's just trying to again he's trying
to make it sound like Pisco asked for something crazy. Pisco
is saying if you're going to call somebody a label, a Marxist
Leninist, a label you think is negative and actually negates
one of my arguments, then I believe that you should be able to
have evidence to support that. What was your evidence to support
that? Right? And no matter how many times you spur the out like
like the sped loser you are and go, "Oh, you you expect me to
be able to find this? You expect me to be able to find that?
No, I expect you to be able to find anything and I'll calmly
explain that to you again and again and again until it goes through
your dense sped skull and you can understand it. I'll just keep
asking you what evidence do you have of this? You shouldn't be
able to label somebody something with no evidence. Do you understand
me yet? I'll keep saying it very nicely, very softly for you,
okay? So you can understand it. Hey, show me evidence of your
allegation. You are alleging something. Please show me any evidence.
Thank you. >> What am I supposed to So, so what do you
want me to do in that moment? So, in that moment, I had just
had a conversation with Aaron uh on stream where I said, "Are
you Marxist Leninist?" And she said, "No, no, I'm not." And everything
I've seen of her, you know, she she might have an incoherent
theory because all communism leads to Marx Len. I don't know
what it is, but I just had a conversation with her. She's my
podcast host. And you say and and not like these good socialists
like a kind of boy, but these bad socialists like straight raid.
And in that moment, you want me to just sit there and be like,
and like what? Not defend and be like, wait, you just called
her a Marxist Leninist. I just had a conversation with her. She
said she's not a Marxist Leninist. I you know, I know her to
be about No, Pisco, don't you understand that? Obviously, like
her saying she's not a Marxist Leninist means nothing. It's like
a saying they're not. It's like, okay, but like it's it's a piece
of evidence. is something I can point to me having interactions
with her, being able to trust her with other things, other similar
things over time. Like I that is a piece of evidence. That's
why I believe that's part of the reason I believe she's not a
Marxist Leninist. The other would be that I've not seen any evidence
that she is. So while it's true, like right Destiny's going to
go, well, just because she says she is doesn't mean she isn't.
And it's like, okay, but just because you say she is doesn't
mean she is. Like you've said nothing. You've said literally
nothing. Once again, what is your purpose?
What point do you have in existence? You are
>> Straight. And in that moment, you want me to just sit
there and be like and like what not.
I just had a conversation with her. She said she's not a Marxist
Lenonist. I you know I know her to be >> understand that
like the whole like when you you can't like that's not you you
can't like you can't ask somebody if they're like a fascist or
a right. >> It's relevant. I know it's not the same. You
can't just but
fascist or a Nazi. Okay. >> Same thing. It's not that it's
not like the exact definition isn't self ID, but someone's ID
is relevant to the to but there's a broader >> I would
say that if you have an identifier you want to put on somebody
and they say no that identifier doesn't apply to me. You should
have any evidence whatsoever to say actually I do believe that
identifier applies to you. Right. Destiny says JSTO is involved
in doxing communities. Jtock is a doxer. Jtock does these things.
JTO amplifies Kiwi farms. I say, "No, I don't." Right. And he
says, "What?" Well, I think you do cuz somebody in your Discord
said I was a I was Okay.
Live with a 165 host. Thank you very much.
What game are we playing today? Quefers. What game was it today?
Was it Patapon? What? What was the game today guys? Making it
about you. True. I am the main character. Very based. British
politics. No, I mean like he was playing a game. I saw he was
playing a game earlier. I don't know what game he would have
been playing. Anyway, we're just about done with this. We're
watching Destiny continue to like burn the last of his credibility
in any way. Finally, now that he doesn't have somebody, you know,
totally tanking any question Pisco asks. He's failed to take
any position. He's failed to stake out like any tangible coherent
position in this debate. When he tries to stake out any position,
it's immediately proven to be like built on sand. There's nothing
there. So, it's good times. Total Pisco victory. We do love >> it's
relevant. I know it's not the same thing. It's not the it's not
like the exact definition isn't self ID but someone's ID is relevant
to the to but there's a broader amount of evidence that I'm that
I'm pointing to like the fact that she identifies as such. The
fact that she canvases for Democrats which most MLS do not do.
Most MLS do not canvas for Democrats. I've talked to her about
different fundamental rights. >> That's really the big
thing, right? That's destiny. Why? If you believe that MLS only
exist to leech from people, why did this belief develop? You
said it developed most because of Han and Bosch. Didn't Hassan
and Bosch leave you before Aaron canvas with you? If you felt
Aaron was an ML, why was she a part of your canvasing operation?
Could you explain that to me? Why is she a part of your community?
Why did you trust her? It's like due process and free speech
that she cares about. And so I'd have no reason to think that
she's an LL. I have no reason to think she's an ML. And in that
moment, all I'm doing there is when you you go after Aaron to
I don't know what your purpose was there. Um maybe to attack
me personally or maybe to attack the fact like what I'm >> It
is to web you to Aaron to say you're being you're being minded
by Aaron. That is the purpose. Yes. >> Um and and in that
moment I'm just defending her. >> Wait. Was it to attack
you personally or to further illustrate the point of like I feel
like the this whole project is like orienting in a very weird
>> Yeah. So he's he literally says that is him saying yes
obviously you hang out with socialists means that this project
is like not going in it's it's going to go towards Marxist Leninism.
You guys are are appealing to and building something for socialists
I guess. So it is just the it is just the webbing right. Yes.
I'm going to web you to socialists because I can't I can't actually
have a conversation with you. >> I'm not sure I'm not sure
which is this. I I don't know which it is. Well, you can't you
can't if if I were to if if I were to do start co-hosting with
Myron Gaines and you attacked me for that, what I think Wow.
I think Pisco is just >> What a comparison. What a comparison,
>> dude. I wonder did Pisco get sent the clip? I I really
hope Aaron and Pisco got to watch the clip of Destiny going,
"Well, actually, I think Myron Gaines would be way better for
the population in terms of like a potential genocide than Hassan
Piker." I really hope Pisco got to watch that. It would be very
good. Do you really think that Myron Gaines is comparable to
Aaron?
>> I think my Gaines is a little bit more radical, but
Aaron is incredibly radical. Yes, she's extremely radical. That
like this was like a running joke in my community for years.
Her whole entry point into my stream was debating me as like
the radical commie comm uh college student. Yeah. >> Okay.
So, that would be another point for like, "Hey, Destiny, why
did you so when Aaron admitted she was a communist and then pretended
Pisco was arguing she wasn't a communist, but now Destiny's arguing
that, oh guys, everybody knows that Aaron was a communist. Everybody
knows that. Everyone knows that, guys. So, apparently in that
debate, were you just being super bad faith when you pretended
Pisco didn't know it and you totally got a W on him when she
said in the clip that I guess I take the label of communist?
>> Even on the same level, I mean, what are we talking
about? I mean, this is crazy. My Gaines is a freak. An anti-semitic
>> Who the cares about the anti-semitism? Like, Aaron,
what what
Okay, bro. Who cares about the anti-semitism? I guess I guess
that's the tack we're taking. Now,
by the way, on the anti-semitism thing where he says that like,
oh, Aaron's like not
I don't know how he argues. He doesn't even say anything to defend
Myron from the anti-semitism thing, but he still says Bosch is
more anti-semitic. Sorry, not Bosch. Uh although he might argue
that Hassan is more anti-semitic. Dude,
apparently the anti-semitism doesn't matter towards one's political
radicalism. having like radical hatred for a group. That's not
really something I take into account. >> What are we talking
about? I mean, this is crazy. My Gaines is a freak. An anti-semitic
freak.
>> What the cares about the anti-semitism? Like Aaron's
positions on anti-semitism >> you do, dude. Dan, that's
Dan's whole MO. His whole project is to fire Dan Clansy and the
whole thing is like saying [__] Hassan is going to
genocide the >> Who the [__] cares about the
My guy, do you know who you are? Do you know what your like community's
project has been for the past six months or what are we doing?
You do.
>> Okay. Number Okay, again, I don't know if you don't
watch my content. That's fine. Okay. >> I totally disavow
Dan. >> Okay. Like, >> I totally Dan's a weirdo.
Actually, I actually totally hate Dan. Dan, why would why would
you think I support anything Dan does? Besides the fact that
we've been friends forever, that he's come on my stream for years
and years and years, spent almost as much time as my on my stream,
maybe more than anybody else, and the fact that we're business
partners and co-hosts of a podcast, but why would you think I
like Dan or or have anything to do with him? I don't I know that
the I know that you've been whispered this by every single person
that me and Dan are literally sitting at our out complaining
and scheming all this. I don't give a about like 95% of Dan's
commitment to taking out Twitch or any other >> Why would
you not care? He's literally using your community to do it. This
is just a total abolition of any agency at all. Abolition, abandonment
of any agency, right? Literally zero agency.
Literally zero agency.
He retweets Dan campaign all the time. Maybe. I'm not totally
sure, but it is the Destiny audience, right? It's the DG audience.
Abdication. Yes, abdication of agency. Thank you. Dan has cursed
me with his misspeaks. It's over for me. Destiny knows about
the EP. Bad bad empanada. Hassan, Queen Episcoco, Jtock calls.
He does apparently guys. He knows about all these late night
calls. I thought we were going to have a cabal meeting today.
Where's Queen is late for the cabal meeting. It was 15 minutes
ago. What the
I thought there was a meeting. >> Talk to Dan. Talk to
Ethan client on that. I don't give a time for any of that. You
can ask my You can watch literally any program. >> It feels
like he's >> like, by the way, Hassan totally needed to
clean up all of the stuff from his community, right? With regards
to Ethan. Need to clean all that up when Dan weaponizes Destiny's
community. And when Dan uses like the anti-semitism lens, the
pro ethan lens, the H3H3 connection that he built via that connection,
via the the Destiny community weaponizing it, right? When he
uses that to go after Pisco, Destiny goes, I got nothing to do
with that. I don't know what that's about. I don't I don't know,
man. I couldn't possibly say anything there. What am I supposed
to do? Is Destiny If Destiny just wants to claim that he actually
came out and said to Dan, like, it's totally insane that you
tell Ethan Klein not to talk to Pisco. That's disgusting. Go
and take that back. Go and tell him to talk to Pisco. You think
Ethan's right, right? Don't Don't just run away from Pisco. go
talk to him. Of course, Destiny did that, right? Because that
would be the right thing to do. After Destiny sued Pisco's New
York Democratic operation, New York DNC operation, isn't that
the minimum he could do? Go and tell his business partner not
to explicitly with Pisco's influencer career. Isn't that the
bare minimum that should be expected? I would say it is. >> Attack
dog. It feels like he's your attack dog. You have plausible deniability.
That's what it feel. I'm just telling you how it feels. I'm telling
you how it feels. >> No. No, you're wrong. It doesn't feel
like he's my attack dog. You've been told that he's my attack
dog. That's what you feel because that's what the people in your
chat are telling you. And they can't
cannot produce any clips of that because >> dude, all we
have to go do is go back to the H3 stuff, right? The H3 Hassan
stuff. And look at the expectation of community control that
he had of Hassan, right, with Ethan. That's all you got to do.
And and again, Pisco was planning to do Democratic politics with
Destiny in New York City, right? They set up a studio to do this
together. Pisco was all in. Pisco had that blown up by Destiny's
conduct. But Destiny sees himself as the victim, so he doesn't
understand how anybody else sees it, right? Destiny couldn't
respect women's consent, and he blew Pisco's operation up. The
the operation him and Joe worked very hard to build. And Destiny
still sees himself as the victim. That Pisco wronged him. He
doesn't understand that he wronged his friends. He wronged his
friends by spreading their without their consent. He wronged
his friends by recording them without their consent. He wronged
his friends by sending that that same material to a however old
Discord kitten. Okay. And and then when it was leaked, okay,
refusing to take any responsibility. He wronged his friends all
the way along, right? The whole way he wronged his friends and
he sees himself as the victim. That's what the issue is here.
He doesn't understand how to take accountability. He sees Pisco
is the one who wronged him. And he wronged Pisco. He wronged
Pisco. He wronged Cherry. He wronged Pixie. He wronged everybody
that he's maligned over them stepping away over this issue and
he refuses to acknowledge it. >> Every single time Dan
goes in generally on you guys or anything else, I'm usually saying
like, "Bro, come on. Like this is like we're not doing a personal
attack or like this is weird or I >> No, Ethan. When when
they go after you, I say that you're like propaline, Ethan. I've
never called you a Zionist, Ethan. Do I call you a Zionist, Ethan?
It's like the same thing, right? It's the exact same. It's the
exact same conversation happening right now. Now, you could argue
that like, oh, uh, Hassan purported to like Ethan more at that
exact moment in time, but I don't think that's true. It's still
the same amount of it's the idea is the control and what is right.
Is it right to let that person be maligned like that? It's not
right. Right. It's not right. I don't know. I It feels like it's
totally wrong. It's obviously wrong. And he doesn't care to actually
engage with that. And Pisco is totally justified in feeling this
way. And if Destiny had proof of anything he'd done to stop Pisco
from feeling that way or stop that impression from being formed,
then I'm sure he would say it. >> I don't care about that.
Like that's like 95%. >> Oh, I don't care about that. I
don't care about that, guys. I don't care about that. >> Time
Dan is like attacking anybody. And even on like the Dan Clinton,
I'm like, "Oh, boy. More Dan Clinton shit." Like he's like is
begging me for mod to ban people who are yes honeying him in
chat. Like you're it's you're going by like what people in chat
have told you on this. Like I know what I know for >> Stoping
me, bro. Stop trying, bro. You're It's not working. Oh [__]
I did not expect that response. That's an outofline response
with some of the stuff that he said. That's cool. Yeah. Like
I'm just being gaslit right now. Like obviously I'm being gaslit
right now. You can't you can't go around the internet and attack
a bunch of people's reputations and do anything you can and say
you'll go on on streams and say I'm going to do anything to to
do this. And then when people are like, "Oh, I think you're doing
it to me." They're like, "Well, I I couldn't control. I couldn't
control that. I can't do that, brother.
>> He's unhinged, too. >> No, you don't. No. No.
Pisco, we all We all actually hate Dan, actually. Guy, don't
you guys all Don't all the DJers actually hate Dan? Don't we
all hate Dan, guys? Guys, don't we just hate Dan? Isn't that
like the Isn't that what we all say? We just all hate Dan. Isn't
Dan unhinged and crazy? Don't we totally disavow Dan? No. Destiny
does a podcast with him. Destiny literally does a podcast with
him. >> No, you don't. What is this, >> bro? The
memes in chat are literally always banan talking about the nothing
burger and the fact that like like if I were to show you my DM
like >> this clip is literally one day before this call.
What is this clip?
Hold on. This stupid social stream. Sorry. So annoying. Oh you
no. Oh cool. Destiny threatens that popped up first. Whoops.
I got the chat logs in here. Whoops. This it's hard to highlight
messages from the social stream like UI. I'll fix it at some
point. is wrong with like what this is not at all like to what
we're talking about and then and then he pulls out the he pulled
out the Andrew Wilson uh I'm just engaging actually in an internal
critique
actually internal critique like what the you don't even understand
your own positions how the can you critique mine what the are
you talking about you just learned half this vocabulary yesterday
and you're trying to internally just totally spuring out it's
totally valid he's literally saying can I critique your position
for consistency
and that's what he was trying to do critique like literally we
need to so I can't remember for sure but I believe this is over
the all communists are MLS all socialists are communists and
all communists are MLS and it's like I don't think you could
possibly believe this so I'm going to internally critique your
position and I believe Destiny's response was you don't even
know what was I don't even know what internal critique means
was it was that his response was that his >> my position
the or just low stakes more >> what was what was the hold
on I have to actually go see when wickv go youtube.com I actually
want to see what it is we'll just go look at it I think it's
wick Dash TV. Actually,
it's Wick Dash TV. Let's just go look. Was about a I just want
to I just want to go see what it was precisely.
this one. Let me go see what it was internal critique. I forget
what Destiny's response was. It did not seem like it was very
good faith. And I pointed out I remember that. Okay, what is
this about? We'll go back a little bit here.
I remember pointing out cuz I thought Destiny said something
like, "Oh, I don't even know what that is." And I'm like, "Wait,
you you watched Andrew Wilson?" Andrew Wilson, I watched him
slow walk you through what he thought an eternal critique was.
You totally know what that is. You're totally familiar with philosophy
and this kind of stuff. I don't think it's >> He No, no,
come on. You know, he me, you know, he me there. He's
making a point. Quick, stop. I making a >> He's like a
white blood cell. He's a white blood cell and he's trying to
stop this cuz you know, I'm not my point. >> This is my
point. >> Conor had a legitimate point on the question
whether or not he should make a TV show has no bearing on any
other part of this convers. >> Oh, right. So, uh, we can't
allow socialists into our media sphere. What if somebody who
we said is an avowed socialist or somebody who has socialist
ideals, what if they went from a politician to being a media
figure? Would they be allowed to be a media figure? And Connor's
completely
brain damaged point that nobody asked for, nobody wants, yourself,
you loser. Sorry, hold on. No, back up, back up, back up. I That's
in a video game. That's a joke. That's a joke. That's a joke.
But the position nobody wanted was, um, so you're saying AOC
can't have a show, but nobody would want AOC to be disallowed
from having a show. Would we would we would do that? It's like,
no, it's literally a Would you apply this consistently as soon
as she goes from politician to media figure? Would that mean
she can no longer engage with us? Do we no longer engage with
her? That was the question. There was a
It's called an internal critique. It's called You had a standard.
You had a >> What is an internal critique? What is an internal
critique?
What is an internal critique? Apparently, he doesn't know here
what an internal critique is. >> Wait, and everyone knows.
Holy, Connor, everyone knows your your standard was I don't really
have a problem using the socialist label of your >> This
is why it's just a total hatchet job on Pis Pisco, right? They're
just talking over him. They're just totally talking over him.
What is an internal critique? What is it? I don't know what it
is. Now, when he's having a calm discussion with Pisco, how's
it going? What's wrong with Well, sorry. I'm going to watch this
again. >> You're like, what? This is not at all like central
to what we're talking about. And then and then he pulls out the
he pulled out the Andrew Wilson. Uh I'm disengaging actually
an internal
internal critique. Like why? Uh it's basically like your position
is really stupid. Uh obviously, it is inconsistent and I'm going
to pose a question to you that if you answer honestly will show
you that it is inconsistent, that it couldn't possibly be consistent.
Right? But we see Destiny spuring, seething, being a total sped.
I'm going to keep, by the way, as soon as I as soon as he gives
me a word that I that he because Destiny can't help this, right?
The sped thing, him making a huge deal over the sped thing, that
actually just points you at exactly what upsets him. He can't
help it. He can't help himself, right? So, I'm going to use that
word always, right? I I'm just going to use it always now. He's
a total sped. He spurs the out. Andrew Wilson hit him. I I know
you guys don't like Andrew Wilson because he argues for things
that are quite bad with his uh debate stuff, but he has done
a lot of work to make sure consistent. And when he when he like
says, "Destiny, you're just going to spur out. You're just going
to spur out. I know you're spuring out right now, right?" When
he does that, that's what I said in the debate Pisco needed to
do is just point out that he's being a child. You're 36, 37 year
old man who can't stop acting like a
child throwing a tantrum. When you come back to reality, when
you decide to age back up, when you've done when when you finished
with your diaper fantasy with the 18-year-old e-girl, okay, and
you filled your diaper and you've gotten cleaned up and you're
ready to have an adult conversation again, let me know and we
can have that adult conversation. But if you're just going to
sit here and try to upend the table and spur the out, I'm not
interested in listening. Act like an adult or get treated like
a child. What the you don't even understand your own with you.
Like what? This is not at all like central to what we're talking
about. And then and then he pulls out the he pulled out the Andrew
Wilson. Uh I'm just engaging actually in an internal actually
internal critique. Like what the Yeah. Just literally
act like an adult or get treated like a child. Like you're just
a total loser right now. Nobody takes you seriously. Nobody can
take you seriously when you talk like this. Um and we all know
this. We all know that he knows it as well that he's like not
really got an argument. So he's got to do this, right? Did he
go with the Norm Finkelstein debate and did he do any of this?
Did he do the spuring? The super embarrassing spuring that like
makes him look like a child? I don't think so. I don't think
so. Anyway, so apparently he didn't know what an internal critique
is. And I pointed out, which is why I know, by the way, that
he must have watched some of my coverage, right? Or he he watched
somebody who quoted me because I pointed out, hey, Andrew Wilson
explained an internal critique to you. It was literally fundamental
to your debate over January 6th. I know you know exactly what
an internal critique is. That was my commentary here. And then
when he goes to respond to it and and talk about it a couple
days later with the streamable clip, he goes, "Oh, you're doing
the Andrew Wilson wrong with you." Like what? This is not at
all like central to what we're talking about. And then and then
he pulls out the he pulled out the Andrew Wilson. Uh I'm just
engaging actually an internal
>> Yeah. So this is interesting that he's going to go,
"Oh, no. I knew what an internal critique was." Very funny. Very
funny. Very funny. Very funny. There's like the the meme of like
peace goes world is like Dan's DMs with Stephen and it's like
okay today we're gonna call a peace go fake lawyer then tomorrow
we're going to go after tomorrow >> you guys talk off stream
it's not your DMs you guys talk off stream didn't Destiny go
on his stream when he was do first doing his like skitso the
first skitso mind map he did not today which maybe we'll cover
that tomorrow I'll have to see how that skitso mindm map session
went u maybe we'll cover it tomorrow but when he did the first
one a day or two ago didn't he explicitly say I actually should
have talked this talked about this with Dan on anything else.
We talked about it offstream and then we didn't talk about it
on stream. Is that not talking about like this exact topic offstream
with Dan in a way you're implying you would never do right here
or like why are you acting like Pisco is insane for thinking
you talk to like your best friend and business partner off stream
and not in DMs?
That's not crazy at all. And again, I believe the the moral compulsion
here should be the moral driver here should be I Pisco over by
by refusing to act in a way that that um by refusing to, you
know, minimize risks and take him into account and take my career
into account. I treated this like it was like uh I'm just like
a 18-year-old even though I was 32 or whatever the when I first
started sending all these news to people when I first started
violating women's consent taking the videos that they recorded
with me but didn't agree for me to share and I started sharing
them around. Right? I'm acting like an 18-year-old who doesn't
know what the world is or how people treat these things and and
he's cavalier with his platform and Pisco was a victim of that.
Right? It actually over Pisco's aspirations over the thing he
was doing with the DNC over all the work he did building up that
DNC studio in New York City. Destiny should feel like he has
to apologize to Pisco. He should be the person who goes to Dan
and say and says, "Dan, I this guy over. I made him rebuild from
scratch without me as somebody around him. And I we we can't
with him. We have to let him go and build his own thing. And
we shouldn't stand in his way. So when you say you're going to
go tell Ethan not to talk to him, that's wrong. It's not just
that." Oh, I don't say anything to Dan. It should be Dan, that
is wrong.
Wrong. Do not do that. But I don't I believe that that exists.
He'd just produce it, right? And like Dan's actual DMs with Destiny
is like, "Please give me mods so I can ban these people. Please
give me mods so I can ban these people. Why don't I have mod
yet so I can ban these people?" Like, that's literally all we
talk about. And you can watch and again for any of these subhuman
pieces of whether we're talking about Queen or Erin or any of
these losers, ask them. Give me an actual clip of Destiny like
going in personally or being an attack dog or using >> Oh,
I see why. I see why DJGs were in here saying, "Can you give
me any clips of him doing this? Can you give me any clips of
him like lying about Pisco or his positions?" Uh, yeah. It's
all the DG chat logs. It's him saying, you know, when Pisco has
a position on the word inifata, it's Destiny's response when
somebody is like, "Oh, he must be talking to commies about this,
right?" And Destiny's response is, "Many many many of our bros
have been lost to socialist girlfriends."
Right? But Destiny will pretend that's nothing. Oh, that that
was nothing. When I when I do the same mind control meme I said
was totally wrong to do with Lykan and Aaron and I banned from
my community, right? When I did that with you and and Joe, that's
totally fine, actually. And that's not me talking at all. But
find me a clip. Find me a clip. How disrespectful to Joe, too.
Uh,
yeah, it is disrespectful to Joe. I well I think the straight
raid thing was more disrespectful. This one was I think girlfriend.
I don't think I don't think it was implying straighter was a
girlfriend to be honest with you. But anyway, we as an attack
dog on these people. It literally never happened. >> I'm
just I'm going to back this up like 15 seconds talk about and
you could watch and again for any of these suck subhuman pieces
of whether we're talking about Queen or Eron or any of these
losers, ask them give me an actual clip of Destiny like going
in personally or being an attack dog or using Dan as an attack
dog on these people. It literally never happens. It doesn't.
Why should Why shouldn't you be cancelled for I don't know. Listen,
I got to go to bed. >> Yeah, sorry. I backed it up. So,
we got the same No, that was the same mention, guys. I backed
it up. That was the same mention that I just talked about. Like,
why? Here are the here are the um clips we got. >> This
is stupid. I I don't I guess I don't I'm left not knowing I'm
left not knowing what what uh what the criticism is. What is
the disagreement? I like I started that conversation saying I
don't think there's a disagreement. Um I don't think there's
a substantive disagreement. And it it seems like we're boxing
in shadows because it's kind of illdefined in what way that bangar
called call didn't go that way like the right way. It's kind
of illdefined. It's just maybe my association and the timing
>> the topic of the the topic of the show is like do we
appeal to like the left? I'm sorry. Do we do do we appeal to
socialists? And some of the conversation with Hutch, although
it kind of goes back and forth a little bit, it's harder to track
was like should the Democratic party be trying to appeal to socialists?
And then when you say socialist, >> I guess it depends
what you mean by socialist and if what you mean by socialist
just that, but even if we all agree, even if I grant that AOC
and and um Bernie and um Econ boy are socialist, right? It's
like saying like do you think that our our movement should be
full of like criminals? And it's like, well, I don't know. And
you're like, well, wasn't MLK technically a criminal cuz you
got arrested? Like, okay, sure. But clearly that's not what we're
talking about. That's that's the issue is just like the broad
appeal of appealing to socialist by appealing to socialist values
rather than just like pushing hard on the lip message and not
like having another show and another group of people that are
like, "Oh, well, look at what happened 12 months later. It's
another group of people that got turned to hardcore socialists
and now they're all just >> Hold on. Sorry. I'm uh just
give me two seconds here." of the show is like, do we appeal
to >> Sorry, I I I'm backing I'm backing this up just a
little bit here because I don't want to miss the end and I'm
uh just give me a >> clip of Destiny like going in personally
or being an attack dog or using Dan as an attack dog on these
people. It literally never happens. It doesn't. >> So why
should why shouldn't you be canceled for I don't know. Listen,
I got to go to bed. This is stupid. I I don't I guess I don't
I'm left not knowing. I'm left not knowing. >> Why shouldn't
you be cancelled for >> what? What the criticism? What
is this agreement? I like I started that conversation saying
I don't think there's disagreement. Um I don't think that there's
substantive disagreement and it it seems like we're boxing in
shadows because it's kind of illdefined in what way that bangar
called call didn't go that way like the right way. It's kind
of illdefined. And it just made me my association and the timing
of >> the topic of the the topic of the show is like do
we appeal to like the left or I'm sorry do we do do we appeal
to socialists and some of the conversation with Hutch although
it kind of goes back and forth a little bit is harder to track
was like should the Democratic party trying to appeal to socialists
and then when you say socialist >> I guess it depends what
you mean >> depends on what you mean by appeal that that
is entirely appeal means what here appeal means hey we both share
this platform position we both like could push in this direction
and be good then yeah we get appeal if appeal means I'm going
to change what I think to court socialists then no but obviously
you couldn't possibly think I've done that because you can produce
no evidence that I've changed anything I believe to appeal to
socialists if you could do that then we could have this conversation
on how we should change tac but you can't so we don't have to
mean >> thought JC was conservative confused on where you
come in uh a lot of the conservative stuff was a lot of populism
and I've come to the to I've come to the position that populism
is the worst cancer are growing in the world right now and that
I I'm like totally on the global homo squad now. Okay. We're
we're totally awful. We're like basically liberals the whole
way. Yeah. Voted for Mark Carney. I I can't do the populism thing.
I'm still like a little more socially conservative than probably
a lot of progressive types, but like I like I'm just doing the
liberal thing. That's that's it. I I can't I can't I've seen
and a lot of the arguments against populism are done. Wow. He
addressed that question directly. Why won't Destiny? That's a
great question. socialist and if what you mean by >> just
that but even if we all agree even if I grant that >> oh
it depends on what you mean by socialist and um Bernie and um
econom boy are socialist right it's like saying like do you think
that our our movement should be full of like criminals and it's
like well I don't know and you're like well wasn't MLK technically
a criminal cuz he got arrested like okay sure but clearly that's
not what we're talking about that's that's the issue is just
like the broad appeal of appealing to socialists by appealing
to socialist values rather than just like pushing hard on the
lip message and not like having another show and another group
of people that are like oh Well, look at what happened 12 months
later. It's another group of people that got turned to hardcore
socialists and now they're all just on Dems constantly saying
both sides are the same. Um I like I don't know if that's the
only thing that would bother me. I think it would bother Hutch.
I don't hate any of you guys, you know. I think you're nice.
I still love you, buddy. Um but yeah, that's I I just I don't
know. Listen, I still love you, buddy. I still love you, buddy.
I still love you, buddy. I'm going to lie about you a whole bunch
in my chat and make sure that they all know that you're a total
piece of actually. But I still love you, buddy. I still love
you. But I'm going to let them all know you're like a complete
utter piece of [__] But I still love you. This is
right before this conversation, by the way. This is like a day
before this conversation, I think. Yeah, a day before this conversation.
This is like so transparent. Listen, I hope I'm wrong. I hope
that in 12 months you're dancing on my stream's grave and all
these socialists are out like supporting the Dems, even if all
their primary people don't win. That would be great and amazing.
But I don't think it's going to happen. I think it's go the exact
opposite way. And yeah. Um, and even even when you bring up examples
of me talking to other radical people like, "Oh, didn't you talk
to the Daily Wire people like even I and I think you've even
better said this." I hate those. >> Why are you Can you
just calm down and speak clearly so everybody can understand
you? He's saying, "Okay, well, even though you can find inconsistencies
from my past on this, like I think I've I've like rejected those."
Unfortunately for him, the eight-month old clip, not two years
old, but eight-month old clip clearly clearly proves that after
the most recent election, he still didn't believe this, right?
He didn't believe this at all. So, when he says, "Well, I got
stabbed in the back and these people became socialists." That
is not what's motivating your thinking here because that was
true in this clip, right? This was after all the Daily Wire stuff.
This was after all of this. This was when you were basically
agreeing with Josiah on everything. You were just aping all of
Josiah's positions one to one. So tell me what's changed now.
What has caused the change in your understanding or the way you
look here or the way you look at this? But he he he basically
says like, "Oh, I regret the Daily Wire stuff." That was the
same here. You regretted the Daily Wire stuff. You had your whole
thing where you said conservatives are children. I have to talk
to them like children, right? I hate them. I hate these people.
That all happened before this
before this clip,
right? It all happened before this clip. So,
what has changed? That's what I need to know. And he can't provide
anything that's changed that's not older than this clip. It >> conversation.
Now, I think I was way too nice of this. And I regret the conversation
I had with Ben Shapiro and Jordan Peterson and Can. And even
those were combative um in ways that like I don't think you guys
were with >> I'll just remind you at the time of this clip,
he was openly sharing like a dialogue with with Straight Aid,
right? the person he says is like an ML who can't be trusted
with like any sincerity towards her political beliefs who also
canvased with DG. I It's really hard to go through all of the
um over the pixie stuff. Like it's really hard to go and do all
of the mental jumping or gymn gymnastics, all the mental gymnastics
that you need to like follow what he's saying and try to be somehow
understanding in his belief or consider it consistent in some
way. The fact that you knew that is questionable though. Knew
what? I don't even know if you're talking to me. You might be
talking to somebody in chat. I can't see. >> Not to say
you dict him or anything, but yeah. Uh that's my broad perspective,
but you know, I hope I'm wrong and yeah. >> Bye. All right,
we're done. >> I think Pisco's got a good idea that this
is like totally disingenuous and I think he was pretty I I feel
like he could have been upset. I don't need him to be any Dude,
if he decides he wants to be friends with Destiny again, uh as
long as I don't have to listen to Destiny, I like whatever. Um
I I do think that would be questionable. I do not think Destiny
has seen uh the consequences of his actions yet. I do think there's
stuff looming, but if Piscll wants to do that, if he's decided
that that's the way it is, like as long as I don't have to listen
to Destiny, I feel like I can engage with politics, right? Like
he's uh I just assume I won't have to listen to Destiny arguing
with him on a whole bunch of stuff. So anyway, I I feel like
I would be a little disappointed in that I would feel like he
would be getting gas lit on what was happening, right? Okay,
this this Queenman with a cute guy is also like a counter propagandist
here. So let me let me see what's the counter propaganda. the
top post in DGG is lying about Pisco as well. How Pisco approaches
random claims from chat versus Destiny.
Okay, let's see what this is. Let's see what this is. We got
some DG propaganda here. Let's Let's engage with some DG propaganda.
What I appreciate about Destiny is that he always ask for clips
or proof and approaches every claim with immediate skepticism.
That's not true. That's not true at all. That's what Okay, that's
why I tend to side with him on most things. He always makes sure
the facts are on his side first. That's literally not true. That's
Wait. He always makes sure this the facts are on his side first.
Okay, hold on. I'm trying to think of some of the stuff. What
about the Aaron ML thing? Did he make sure that the that Aaron
was a Marxist Leninist before he made that claim? I'm just trying
to think of stuff from the debate, right? Because I'm going to
go to the Aaron Marxist Leninist thing that he made sure the
facts were on his side with that. Where? How? How did he do that?
The reason it appears to you, dear DGG viewer, that the facts
are on his side is because when Destiny says something, you believe
that is truth. You take his word as the word of God. So he always
has the facts on his side because no matter what he says, he
is correct. Anyway, so what I appreciate Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Pisco
though, who's a lawyer, by the way, instantly believed a random
claim from Chad about Destiny. Didn't watch a single clip. Didn't
get his own interpretation. Just immediately believed it. And
to be fair, I don't think he does it out of malice. In my opinion,
he just gets very emotional, which I think clouds his judgment.
Still, I can definitely see how anti-fans would take advantage
of this and with Pisco to drive a wedge between him and Destiny.
Again, I made no comment on Pisco or Destiny until Destiny was
already firmly trying to drive a wedge in the middle of Live
and Learn until Destiny was trying to push Hutch to like understand
that these people were totally disingenuous engaging with him,
which is a lie. Those people are Hutch's genuine friends. Destiny
is not your genuine friend. Okay. Okay. If Pisco is planning
to split from DGG, that's completely fine in my opinion. But
I hope he notices when he does when he does this and takes the
Destiny approach when reading anything from chat because not
going to lie, I'd hate to lose another left-wing streamer to
anti- Destiny brain rot.
Like the kind of brain rot where you're like, I kind of don't
like jokes about children under 15 and I kind of don't like um
like not respecting women's consent. that that that like anti-destiny
brain rot. They call that being human. Actually, just so we're
clear that that's like like don't joke about kids and respect
women's consent. They just call that being human. I understand
the concept evades you. Or if he's going to be flirting with
socialists and commies, at least adopt their best proverb. Trust
but verify.
Okay, let's see. The claim about Destiny that he just trusts
without evidence. >> Oh, he called me the the poster boy
for Kiwi Farms. For Kiwi Farms. Never been to Kiwi Farms.
Uh, that is Oh, that is probably what happened here. I'm going
to chalk that up to Pisco being a new streamer, right? If if
that happened, unless that was somebody he trusts. Hold on. Let's
see who the chatter was. Kiwi Farms. Destiny calling Pisco, the
poster boy for Kiwi Farms is deranged.
Did that happen? I don't know if that happened. I would definitely
not if I heard something like that, like a a harsh assertion
like that, I would immediately go and say no, I don't think so.
Right.
that 90% happened. I'll send a clip. Okay. There's no way.
There's no way. Oh, wait. Is this when um
I see. So, it's the it's the implication that like Destiny saying
Pisco is a Kiwi farmer, but what Pisco's what was probably being
said is Blav loves Pisco. Blav constantly talks about Pisco.
Why the he sounds so calm? Uh because I've watched Destiny spur
the out like a total like a totally embarrassing 37y old child
and I've decided that like when I'm analyzing political content
that's probably the way I should be. This is probably the way
I should be because hon it just is so embarrassing. He's actually
shamed me from my normal like more bombastic style into being
like holy I I think I'm more compelling when I just speak calmly.
I think I'm very capable of being compelling when I speak calmly.
And I actually really I really I'm so grossed out watching what
he did to Pisco that I'm like I don't I don't want to be even
close to that. I think that's completely that's just disgusting.
So yeah, just be calm review stuff. Did Porter Bella get that?
Just send it on uh Oh, you did. Okay. Okay. Let's check this
clip out. We'll check the clip out. We'll see what it says. So
this is the clip. Um they love having a So I would say that if
Pisco believed this, right? If Pisco believed this, it could
be because he'd already seen the clip, right? Oh, the Queen with
a Q guy
the queen with a Q guy is um sending me all of it. This guy is
uh this guy is a cabal member. I believe the queen with a Q guy,
right? Like Qanon, but Qan Qan, he's a cabal member. Pomeo the
for a while, I don't remember how many months ago this was, but
I know that um Blav is my number one obsessive guy on Q. Yeah,
it's gonna be about Blav liking Pisco
>> about me. It was like hyping up Pisco's life because
Pisco distanced himself from me. He hyped up Pisco as basically
being like the better version of me in any way, such, shape,
or form. So, that became like the obsession. Now, that's not
to say that there aren't legitimate reasons to like Pisco. Like
I think still think he's like one of the most fun people to debate
and he's incredibly knowledgeable when it comes to law and even
if he gives dumb political takes that I super disagree with sometimes,
I don't think he's I don't think he's like an actual or anything.
I think P is a really smart dude. I think he does have the potential
to be like a huge streamer and everything. Um that so I'm not
trying to say that like the only reason anybody watches him is
because they hate watching him. That's not true. But he became
like the kind of like the icon for uh Kiwi Farms and everything
to be like juxtaposed to me to show that like oh um I could find
it wasn't for Kiwi Farms at all. This is this is Destiny takes
like my positions that I have independent of KF and he tries
to make it so that these are KF positions, right? That's like
what he tries to do. He just watches he or he has people watch
possibly has people watch me and Queenman figures out what we're
saying and then says these are Kiwi Farms
right? And it's just silly. This is very silly, right? I've explained
to you why I like Pisco's content. I've explained it and I've,
by the way, I've been saying the same thing to everybody who's
missing political content, right? I might start doing more political
content. We'll see. I'm enjoying it quite a bit. But I said this
to everybody like months ago. It was if you want a replacement
for Destiny, Pisco is the replacement.
The primary reason Pisco is the replacement is because he has
impulse control and he has drive. He will never put his movement
above him uh sorry below himself. He will never put himself above
his movement. He will care about the movement. He will push for
principles and he will make himself himself subservient to those
principles. He will not let his ego override everything. At least
from everything I've seen, he's very driven person. He is a very
smart person. He works very hard.
I believe that he will be a far better representative and there
will not be the risk there that is there with Destiny. You also
don't have to go uphill against the existing optics that Destiny
has, right? Destiny continues to tweet about like when he asked
that Republican dad, hey, you're a 12-year-old girl that kid
those 12-year-olds actually like none of that with Pisco, right?
Zero of that with Pisco. Zero optics. Not that Destiny's, but
zero optics.
That's a price. That's That's awesome, right? That's you love
to see it. Pisco Pisco is funnier, too. Um, I mean, I'm probably
gonna say no on that. I think that's probably just not true.
I don't think Pisco talks anywhere near as well as Destiny does,
right? Destiny to just pretend that Destiny does have he's got
like zero redeeming qualities would be to like be ignorant of
how he became a big influencer in the first place. I don't I
don't want to go like totally outside the lines on that and just
pretend that there's like nothing positive about that guy at
all. But most of the positive things are totally outweighed by
the negative, right? With Pisco, the negatives are way way way
way smaller, right? He was super funny today. Pisco is funny.
Pisco is very capable of being funny. It's a dry kind of humor.
It's a different kind of humor, right? But he is very funny.
I just don't think I think like Destiny's probably his strongest
his his best strength was his humor.
Um, unfortunately, it's like uh dude, it's like the Method Josh
thing, right? where I'm sure Method Josh was entertaining, but
he kept talking about like how he was a weirdo and stuff and
Destiny's kind of gone way too far down the I'm proving out that
I'm actually like a super weirdo that it just feels weird when
he makes dark jokes now. It's like it's just it's really like
Yeah, it's not the same, right? And I assume that's what like
the method Josh as well. It's like dude I
No, that's not true. Mark Carney, that's not true either. He's
just he's a boomer and he he doesn't get it. Yeah, his use of
the soundboard is red baresque, right? It's like the shock jock
version of the soundboard. It's fine. It's fine. Anyway, we could
continue with this. I'm never ever ever going to comment on this
stuff. So, I don't have like these posts saved. I don't know
how many months back you'd have to go, but um Lav was like super
obsessively hyping up Pisco for a while and being like my successor
now that I'm like a rapist or whatever. >> Yeah, true.
What is this? This is the poster boy clip. said, "Destiny calling
Pisco the poster boy for Kiwi Farms is deranged." Have I ever
said anything even remotely like that? Well, you did say it precisely.
Now, I'd say the implication of this when it's like by
um when like to call him like the poster boy or something when
somebody said something nice about him once, right? That seems
pretty gross, pretty weird. >> Oh, he called me the the
poster boy for Kiwi Farms. For Kiwi Farms. Never been to Kiwi
Farms. Don't look at Kiwi Farms. Don't touch that issue at all.
>> It's a projection. Oh, just see. It's a projection of
other of other grievances and me and I'm responsible. >> Well,
I mean, Destiny kind of is the poster boy. Destiny literally
reads Kiwi Farms on his stream, right? Kind of weird that he
would even make that criticism when he reads Ka on stream like
openly. I And I can't even give you because I because I respect
people too much. I'm not even going to give you what the actual
criticism should be there. Okay. There's an actual criticism
for his behavior, for Destiny's behavior that is far more scathing
than the than the criticism of, "Oh, you're the the poster boy
for you read on stream." There's actually other stuff going on
there that I can't talk about, but he's a psychopath. Okay? Doesn't
care about Pisco's wellbeing. Doesn't care about anybody's well-being.
It's a total joke that he pretends. Anyway, man.
Man, oh man. Man alive. Okay. Man alive.
So, he said it directly. I would say the implication of this
is whatever. Um the projection thing I guess I can see Pisco
took that the wrong way. Pisco does need to check into like that,
but he'll get used to that streaming more where people will say
things in a way that's meant to be inflammatory.
Um I don't really hold that against him. You should he should
go like, "Oh, do you got a clip of that so I can see the context?"
I feel like he would never have said that, right? I feel like
you get used to that after you stream for a while of people telling
you something happened and then you click through and you look
into it and it didn't happen at all and then eventually you learn.
You got to touch the You got to touch the top of the stove sometimes
to learn that it's hot. You know, AMC should do promotion with
Atlantis Moriceette. Wait, what?
Why would you say this? Who's AMC? Like American Movie Company,
American Movie Channel. I don't even know what the were saying
there. Yeah, you got to get you got to get burned by chat a couple
times to learn that. I don't think he said anything crazy there
to be honest with you. You said, "I've never been there. I don't
I don't use it. I don't care about it." Oh god, the Darius stuff.
Okay, there's Dude, I should stop closing these. I don't even
know what what's in these tabs. What the I don't even know what's
in the tabs. See here. Um, so thinking about that post, I just
don't think that's like crazy. And I think if that was given
Pisco is like a new streamer, that's like getting fooled by chat.
That has nothing to do with like your discernment. You're like,
"Oh, somebody's bringing something to me. I expect them to tell
the truth, right?" That's just naivity. You'll you'll burn through
really quickly. What prison does to a man. True.
Apparently, there's a bunch of Darius content, too. So, we got
lots of stuff for tomorrow. Shui and Zena blown up. All this.
All this and more.
What else we got in the docket for today? July 31st. I'm looking.
I'm looking. I'm looking. Ao boy versus Anna. Russian. Sorry,
not Russ. Not Russian Anna. Ukrainian Anna. Ukrainian Anna.
So, okay. Watching it was made more bearable simply due to counter
Connor calling these two useful tanky. Thank you, sir. Have my
Eastern European gratitude for that one. uh European or Ukrainian
is like a total like it's it's not sincere engagement. She's
fundraising for like people she wants not to die. It's not serious
engagement. It's not serious political opinions. It is like
it's basically building an image and fulfilling an image to to
make money so people she cares about don't die. I don't have
like a particular like like morally it's like kind of gray, but
I totally get it and I would not judge anybody around me for
doing it if I were in a similar situation. So, I'm not going
to like go off on this person. I think this is totally incorrect
and I think uh any response I'd give to this would be like delicate
in general, right? Like I I I feel like I would be delicate with
my responses to this because I don't have to deal with like life
or death circumstances and I'm not trying to fund like um you
know sho string military budgets via via DG simps, you know.
So, hi Anna. I think it's frankly absurd to think I'm a useful
tanky if you really engage with what I said during the discussion.
10% of the Democratic base are socialist. Another 10% are extremely
liberal. I believe these people should stay in the coalition.
All A Connoy has to say is if you think I support the kind of
socialism that led to the Soviet Union, you're wrong. I believe
I support a different kind of socialism that is more in line
with, you know, that is more in line with today's principles
like Western democratic principles and I believe it's made meaningful
contributions to Western liberal democracies.
That's that's what something like he could say. It's like I don't
want the Soviet Union. I don't I don't romanticize the Soviet
Union or any tankies. And the the like assertion that I do is
frankly insulting.
See if uh she responds at all. I believe in democracy as a means
to my ideal system. Obviously MLS do not believe in democracy.
Uh and Ukrainian correctly points out that socialism is immoral.
And no wrong. Just wrong. American deist.
Just wrong. Socialism is
socialism is absent. Socialism is like a state of being absent
implementation. Right. Socialism is moral. Socialism and communism
are moral. The implementation of them is probably impossible.
Right? That's the problem. The systems themselves are moral.
If you say that the you can say I think any attempt at this would
lead to immoral outcomes,
but just saying socialism is immoral is like a 70 IQ take. It's
just very silly, right? I don't agree with socialism, by the
way, for the exact reason I outlined. I believe that socialism
in practice cannot be achieved. And I believe that like broadly
like sorry socialism in practice I believe you can move in a
socialist direction you can become more socialist but true socialism
or communism I don't know if they can be achieved right or maybe
they can once you like achieve a level of computing that you
can have like a planned economy and have people taken care of
and AI builds a utopia for us or something maybe something like
that right but like given you know normal human beings the stuff
we still have access to now I don't believe like socialism is
achievable true socialism true communism and chasing them can
often lead to far worse outcomes than just pretending they're
evil. Saying it's moral doesn't really make sense. An economic
system either works to produce maximum liberty, happiness, freedom,
or it doesn't. Oh, I sorry, maybe I should say communism. The
idea that like to each their own by their ability. I I think
that's like a moral idea. I think that's like a not like not
an immoral idea. Yeah. I just don't think so. I think like they're
broadly like you can broadly say it's like like I don't know.
It's It's just like being a good person put into like like coded
codified, right? Yeah. But um anyway,
it's fine. I don't know if she would have replied or not. Maybe
she quote tweeted him back. Didn't quote tweet him back. Oh,
it's it's Barrett Derry Cipher. Watching a man get shamelessly
and blatantly misrepresented. You're a comedy tanky America hater
now to these people. Enjoy the label. There's no argument or
changing people's minds here. There is just sucking up the leaders
of the respective communities until they like you enough to change
how they labeled you. Hope you've been paying attention to how
people convince Trump because that is more effective than what
what than whatever reasonable you're
Um, probably that might not be untrue to be honest. Just being
a good person but codified I sorry like the the ideas of socialism
that hey we could all work in like they just don't work right
humans respond to incentives. The ideas of socialism that like
we could all work together and we'd all you know own a share
of the profits and everybody would be happy. These like the ideas
of socialism just doesn't work. It's stupid right? Human beings
respond to incentives. I'm a lazy. If I don't have incentives,
I'm a super lazy. I will sit there. If I could go in the in the
like um what do you call it? Like the jerkoff experience machine,
right? The thing that with like the the heroin and all that.
Like I would probably be I'm like one of those people who probably
like ruined my life if I didn't have positive incentives, right?
I just feel like the best thing in my life for me has been when
I've found positive incentives and negative incentives that motivate
me, right? That's been where I've been the the most effective
in my life when I don't have things. Streaming is actually like
quite bad for me in some ways. I don't have like uh like when
I have the had the motivation of, hey, I need a job and I'm going
to go to work and then I have like social interactions at work.
When I had like all of those motivations to go and do stuff,
I was much healthier person than streaming. Streaming is very
easy to just like come here, talk to chat, and you get paid money
and it's like decent money and then you don't really have to
do anything outside of that in the day, right? Like that's that's
not great for somebody like me. I'm not super self motivated
a lot of the time. I'm better than a lot of people, right? I'm
especially better than a lot of people in the streaming space.
But uh it's a positive incentive. Well, I guess the opposite
of a negative incentive. You probably just call it an incentive.
Man, do you want to swap? No, I'm telling you, it's probably
it's probably good for you, gentle whale. Trust me, it's probably
good for you to like have to go into work and like make these
social connections. It'll be good for you in the long run. I
promise. Doesn't feel like that sometimes, but I promise. Do
you see the Do you see this guy? Hey, you see this guy just doing
propaganda all day? Was IRI shading Pisco today? Probably not.
Probably not. Probably not. But I'll I'll take a look. Maybe
I should start a liberal podcast.
No, I don't I don't know. I don't think so. You could I don't
know, man. I should talk to our relevant before things go off
the rails there. I feel like I feel like he's I feel like he'd
be taking uh I don't know. I got to know what he'd say. I heard
a take the other day where I was like, "Oh, I don't I don't like
where this is going." But it wasn't the Ethan stuff. Ethan stuff
I'm fine with his opinions on. You can have a difference of opinion
there even if I think it's silly. Um with some of this stuff
I'm like oh I really hope he's not like you know going like oh
Josiah and Pisco are like going towards socialism. I would I
would feel personally compelled to intervene in that case.
If he if he believes that Josiah and Pisco are going towards
socialism or something I would I would feel compelled to intervene.
I would feel compelled to say
Uh, I'm saying I'm just giving you like my thoughts on it. Someone
post a video of RI in a DG DGL hoodie for Jubilee, assuming it
was filmed ages ago, but a sevenmon. No, that that is an old
old old episode. Omnilletic is a very old episode. And I don't
really care if if IRI wants to do that. You can be associated
with these people. I think I just think it'd be like really bad
for your career to have that be associated with these people.
Personally,
just how I personally feel about it, you know. Apparently, Shuvi
and Zena are leaking all of their DMs back and forth. So, that's
a thing, too. What career? Oh, I'm just saying for these people,
I think if you're like going to if you're like going to farm
the DG audience, I just think that's probably not going to go
great unless you do so pretty covertly. Like all the people in
that audience will try to push you back towards interacting with
Destiny 2. It is like weird. It is like like the Plantation meme
is like a real meme. It is a real thing. Okay, the Plantation
is kind of real. They'll all try to pull you back in. I'll try
to like push you back to interacting with Destiny, right? Tread
went through it. I remember I mean, yeah, everybody goes through
it. I mean, even now, like we're still covering content that
involves Destiny, right? Like at some point you got to find a
way to break away from that. And I think the only way that you
break away from it is like doing harsh like blockades, okay?
Harsh like, yeah, you mentioned Destiny here, you're banned.
You you talk about Destiny here, you're banned. Just off. I don't
want you around. Right. Chud did it. Yes, Chud did it. We will
see
some yearn for the shackles. Jesus. Watch this Destiny clip.
Watch this destiny clip. Yeah, I'd
unfortunately for Chud. Well, maybe not unfortunately. Chud's
going to Chud's going to end up winning. Chud didn't have to
do anything. Chud didn't have to come out and like uh what do
you call it? You didn't have to come out and like refute Destiny's
like Kiwi Farms allegations. He just ignores it and then Destiny's
going to blow himself up. So, Chud is Chud is in Denim's mode
right now. Okay. Chud's in Denim's mode. He's doing his thing.
He's in his lane. He's thriving, right? He's in Denim's mode.
This is This is Chud Logic right now. Okay,
he's in fullon denims mode. It is what it is. Okay, it is what
it is. Sometimes you can just be in full-on denims mode. I don't
know. Desi reading his full his Kiwi Farms thread is pretty funny.
I think that is like the death nail for somebody entering LCAM
in a way that like even the Sonichu necklace is not right. Once
you start reading full Kiwi Farms posts on stream, you are like
it is over. You have spiraled into Latum and you do not you've
reached like terminal velocity. Okay. You've you've gone past
the event horizon. You cannot escape. Okay. You cannot escape.
Yeah. It's like it's totally over.
He did a rebranding post 2016 to be normal. So it's okay if people
fell for him. Maybe.